SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK. AND DIMICK FOR
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH OUR
PROCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THOUGH IT
AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
I'M GONNA COVER SOME TECHNICAL.
ASPECTS OF THINGS FOR TODAY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IT
HERE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NOMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS.
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY. OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO THIS HEARING. TO
THE EXTENT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR ONE. I WILL REPEAT
THIS A FEW TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING. ARE FOR THOSE WHO NEED
IT TO BE REMINDED THAT WE HAVE
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE. AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE IN THIS. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AND IS CUSTOMARY. ARE AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OUR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAPTOPS FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW ONLINE
TOOLS SO. AGAIN BE PATIENT SO
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD THROUGH
THE THROUGHOUT THE HEARING
PROCESS. ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR A
COURT REPORTER. I'M GONNA ASK
ALL SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES IN
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND A REMINDER TO OUR
CALL OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
MEMBERS YOU'LL NEED TO TURN YOUR
MICROPHONE ON FOR THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME THAT WE VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. YEAH
KAMLAGER I'M LONGER HERE LAYERED
HERE THEY'RE HERE BATES ATKINS
HERE HE WAS HERE THANK YOU AND I
JUST FOR THE PUBLIC AND PEOPLE
TUNING IN- VICE CHAIR BATES WILL
BE HERE VERY SHORTLY AND I HAVE
TO RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT
SERVE ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
WHICH IS ACROSS THE STREET IN
THE- STREET BUILDING SO ARE WELL
YOU MAY SEE PEOPLE COMING GO
PLEASE KNOW THAT IT HAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH MULTIPLE
PRIORITIES AND ASSIGNMENTS. AND
WE WILL CERTAINLY GET THROUGH
THIS AND MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SIX FEDERAL BUT ARE
THEY ARE DEFINITELY WORKING AND
DOING DOUBLE DUTY NOW THAT THEY
HAVE TO TRAVEL ACROSS THE
STREET. SO IF THERE ARE NO
OBJECTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
UP- FIRST ON TODAY'S AGENDA
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES THAT ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR. WE HAVE
ITEMS R. TWO E. THROUGH G. AND
THAT IS APPOINTMENTS TO MEMBERS
OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. LET ME FIRST ASK DO
I NEED TO SEPARATE ANY OF THESE
OUT. I'LL GIVE A SECOND- NUMBER
WITHOUT A SENATOR LAYERED I
WOULD MOVE ITEMS TO E. F. AND G.
THANK YOU SENATOR BEN OF
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH I KAMLAGER I'M LONGER I'D
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES ATKINS
HI ATKINS I ON CALL THAT WILL BE
ON CALL FOR THE VICE CHAIR WHEN
SHE ARRIVES THANK YOU I WOULD
HAPPILY TAKE A MOTION ON TODAY'S
AGENDA ITEMS THREE AND FOUR THIS
IS REFERENCE OF BILLS TO THE
COMMITTEES AND FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. I'D LOVE THREE
AND FOUR CENTER LAYERED THANK
YOU MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROTHE RO FIVE
KAMLAGER. AND WATER AYE LAYERED
AYE AIRED AYE BATES ATKINS HI.
HI I'M COOL THAT IS ALSO ON
CALL- WE WILL NOW TURN THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR ITEMS ONE HEY AND THAT
IS THE APPOINTMENT OF MICHELLE
SEA BASS AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. SO LET ME- WELCOME
DIRECTOR BASS. I AM. PERFECT I
NEED TO MAKE SURE I SEE THE
DIRECTOR ON MY SCREEN AND I DO-
LET ME SAY WELCOME INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE OF
THIS- THAT YOU WOULD LIKE IN
YOUR INTRODUCTIONS AND THEN MAKE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS YOU WOULD
LIKE AND WE WILL GO THEN RIGHT
TO MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO BE CONSIDERED AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. I AM VERY
PROUD TO BE JOINING VIRTUALLY BY
BY PARENTS JOHN AND SO I LEFT
AND MY HUSBAND MICHAEL AND WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR LOVE AND
SUPPORT. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR AND SECRETARY
GALLEY FOR THIS APPOINTMENT. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE HEALTH
CARE IS A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT AND
I AM EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CHANCE TO LEAD A DEPARTMENT THAT
PROVIDES THIS RIGHT TO MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS. BY EIGHTEEN
YEARS IN STATE GOVERNMENT MOST
RECENTLY AT THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS. AND
PRIOR TO ABOUT WORKING ON HEALTH
POLICY AS LEGISLATIVE STAFF HAS
PROFESSIONALLY PREPARED ME FOR
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ROLE. AND
PERSONALLY GROWING UP AS A FIRST
GENERATION AMERICAN MY MOTHER
AND FATHER ARE IMMIGRANTS FROM
ECUADOR IN ITALY. TAUGHT ME THE
VALUES OF HARD WORK RESILIENCE
AND PROBLEM SOLVING. THESE
EXPERIENCES HAVE SHAPED MY
PERSPECTIVE ON THE POWER OF
MEDIC HEALTH AS THE ULTIMATE
EQUITY TOOL AND A CORNERSTONE OF
THE STATE'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
EVERY ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIANS.
TO POSITIVELY IMPACT INDIVIDUALS
AND LEAD TO THRIVING
COMMUNITIES. BY LIFTING THE
EXPERIENCES AND OUTCOMES OF
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WE ARE
LIFTING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. FINALLY I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY SINCERE GRATITUDE TO
THE DH CS TEAM I'M INCREDIBLY
PRIVILEGED TO WORK WITH SO MANY
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS AND
UNSUNG HEROES WE'RE COMMITTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT'S MISSION. AND
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIANS. THAT CONCLUDES MY
OPENING REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
YOU SO MUCH DIRECTOR- CENTER
LAYERED WHAT I GO AHEAD AND LET
YOU START US OFF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR. AND MADAM
DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND FOR WILLING TO BE
WILLING TO MEET WITH ME I REALLY
ENJOYED IT. AND I THOUGHT I'D
FOLLOW UP ON A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT BECAUSE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THINGS IN YOUR
DEPARTMENT IS TO. THAT EFFECT
AND AS THE CHAIR OF EDUCATION
WHERE I'VE CALLED OUT ACRONYM
ALERTS I BETTER SAY THE ACRONYM
FIRST. THERE ARE THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INNOVATING MEDICS
HELP THAT WE ALL KNOW AS
CAROLINE. THAT THE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST INITIATIVES IN YOUR
DEPARTMENT- AND I KNOW WITH%
REACHES OUTSIDE INCORPORATES
PEOPLE FROM OTHER NON PROFITS
AND THINGS THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE
BEEN IN THE SYSTEM THE SAME WAY
PRIOR TO THESE REFORMS. I
WONDERED IF YOU WOULD JUST TALK
ABOUT. THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
REFORMS BUT ALSO HOW YOU. INTEND
TO MONITOR AND EVALUATE THEIR
SUCCESS. GREAT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CALLEVA IS REALLY OUR
MULTI YEAR INITIATIVE TO
TRANSFORM THE WAY WE DELIVER
CARE IT MOVES AS TED POPULATION
HEALTH APPROACH THAT REALLY
PRIORITIZE PREVENTION. WHOLE
PERSON CARE AND REALLY EXTEND
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES BEYOND
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS DIRECTLY INTO
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES WE
REALLY WANT TO MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE IN LIFE ADDRESS SOCIAL
DRIVERS OF HEALTH AND REALLY
BREAK DOWN THE WALLS OF HEALTH
CARE AND BRING DOWN THOSE SILOS
BETWEEN THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS. I'M I THINK ONE OF THE
KEY FEATURES THAT IRAQ THAT
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT AND
COMMUNITY SPORTS FEATURES OF
CALAIS MAINE I WILL SAY THIS
MORNING I WAS AT A SEPARATE
SACRAMENTO COVERED WHICH IS A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND SACRAMENTO- AND
IT. IS GOING TO BE PROVIDING ARE
DESCRIBED WRITING ENHANCE CARE
MANAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
TO HEAR THE EXPERIENCES OF OUR
COMMUNITY OF THEIR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS REALLY MEETING
INDIVIDUALS WHERE THEY ARE
WHETHER IT'S ENCAMPMENTS. OR YOU
KNOW IN IN CORNER SHOPS I REALLY
HOW THE APP PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET IT
THEIR ID'S TO GET A PHONE.
ESCORT THEM TO. AT A MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS AND REALLY REALLY
ADDRESS ALL THE NEEDS THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAS IN IN NAVIGATING
THIS COMPLEX DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
AS PART OF CAL AIM WE ARE
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO EVALUATE THE KEY
COMPONENTS IN SOME OF THESE
PIECES THAT THAT ARE REALLY
TESTING THE BOUNDARIES OF HEALTH
CARE AND SO WE WILL BE WORKING
WITH. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
TERMS OF EVALUATIONS ON THESE
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS EVALUATIONS
ON SOME OF THE OTHER REFORMS
THAT ARE PART OF CAL AIMED I
MEAN REALLY DEMONSTRATING THE
VALUE OF THESE INITIATIVES. AND
HOW DOES THIS HELP YOU DEAL WITH
PREVENTION RATHER THAN JUST SORT
OF. REIMBURSING PEOPLE FOR THE
HEALTH COSTS. AFTER THEY'VE HAD
THE INCIDENT. I WANTED TO KEEP
THE- OF. ARE POP HEALTH
MANAGEMENT APPROACH AND THIS IS
REALLY MEANT TO IDENTIFY REALLY
UPSTREAM MISSED OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY ADDRESS.
THAT THE IMPACTS OF HEALTH CARE
YOU KNOW A TRADITIONALLY OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
MODELED ON- YOU KNOW REACTIONS
TO FALLS REACTIONS TO
HOSPITALIZATIONS. REACTIONS TO
CHRONIC OUTCOMES AND SO WITH
THIS POPULATION HEALTH APPROACH
REALLY LOOKING AT THE DATA
LOOKING AT WHO ARE THE MEMBERS
OF THE MEDICAL PROGRAM AND HOW
DO WE DEVELOP DEVELOP.
INTERVENTIONS THAT ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE UPSTREAM IMPACTS I
THINK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ONE OF
THE COMMUNITY SUPPORTS WE HAVE
IS IT'S HOME MODIFICATIONS. AND
SO THINKING THROUGH A YOU KNOW A
RAIL IN A PERSON'S HOUSE MIGHT
PREVENT FUTURE FALLS INTO HOW DO
WE GO UPSTREAM TO DESIGN. AN
ENVIRONMENT DESIGNED SYSTEMS
THAT REALLY ADDRESS OUR OUR
INDIVIDUALS NEEDS AND YOU'RE
ALSO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER AND
IN THE QUESTION. YOU'RE ALSO
ENGAGING MANAGED CARE PLANS. AND
OTHER STRATEGIES THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE TRADITIONAL. THAT
HAS EXISTED AND- OF WHILE YOU
JUST MADE THE CASE FOR WHY
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
CAN HELP YOU REACH OUT INTO SOME
OF THESE THINGS HOW DO YOU
ACTUALLY ENGAGE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
NONTRADITIONAL OR NOT
TRADITIONALLY BEEN IN THE SYSTEM
TO SORT OF BRING THEM IN. TO HOW
YOU'RE MANAGING. I THINK ONE OF
THE KEY INITIATIVES THAT WE HAVE
IS OUR OUR PATHFINDING AND THESE
ARE AND IT'S OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS I'M REALLY DEDICATED TO
BUILDING OUT THESE PARTNERSHIPS
BUILDING OUT THE CAPACITY
BETWEEN OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS
AND SOME OF THESE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. I THINK
ABOUT AGAIN SACRAMENTO COVERAGE
JUST SO VIVID IN MY MIND GIVEN
THIS MORNING'S EXPERIENCE BUT
REALLY THEY WENT FROM ABOUT I
THINK IT WAS ABOUT SIX COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS I'M IN HAS GROWN
TO TWENTY SEVEN AND ARE ALREADY
THINKING ABOUT HOW THEY MIGHT
USE THESE DOLLARS- IN THE FUTURE
TO BUILD OUT EVEN MORE AND HOW
TO BECOME A- ACCOUNT THE
BROADER. COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT CAN CAN SERVER
SERVER THAT THE MEDICARE
POPULATION SO I THINK STATEWIDE
THESE DOLLARS ARE INTENDED TO
REALLY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
TERMS OF HOW DO YOU BECOME A
MEDICAL PROVIDER COLLABORATION
DOLLARS B. YEAH IN ORDER TO
REALLY. MATCH THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OUR MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND THEN CAPACITY
DOLLARS REALLY ACTUALLY BUILDING
OUT SOME OF THE WORK FORCE
BUILDING OUT SOME OF MAYBE EVEN
THE I. T. INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MIGHT BE NEEDED. IT REALLY
SUPPORT THESE PROVIDERS AS THEY
BECOME REALLY CRITICAL PARTNERS
IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM AND THEN
WHEN THE- AND THE LAST QUESTION
A HUNDRED MILLION ASKING THIS.
IS BY THE NUMBERS I HAVE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE UPDATED IS
THAT YOU'RE CARRYING A 14%
VACANCY RATE IN THE DEPARTMENT.
A. N. HOPEFULLY SOME OF THAT IS
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC AND YOU
COULD RECOVER BUT POWER YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH.
THIS AMBITIOUS REFORM ALL
CARRYING A VACANCY RATE OF THAT
. WE JUST HAD A REALLY ROBUST
DISCUSSION YESTERDAY WITH SENIOR
STAFF ON THAT POINT AND WE'RE
THINKING THROUGH AT OTHER ARE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY WEEK
STATEWIDE TO KIND OF FIND ITS
STATE WORKFORCE THAT IS MAYBE
NOT TRADITIONALLY BEEN PART OF
THE DH YES PORTFOLIO AND HOW WE
CAN REALLY ADVERTISE AND RECRUIT
FROM MANY DIFFERENT FACTORS I
THINK. I REALLY AT THE PANDEMIC
HAS TAUGHT US THAT WE ARE KIND
OF WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TELEWORK WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BUILD TEAMS VIRTUALLY AND I
REALLY THINKING THROUGH
STRATEGIES ON HOW TO DO THAT
MORE EFFECTIVELY. THANK YOU I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE A YOU
ALLOWING ME TO WALK THROUGH
THESE IT'S BEEN REALLY HELPFUL
I. LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
YOUR POINT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED SENATOR COM
L'ARBRE. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
AND- THANK I WAS GOOD TO SEE YOU
DIRECTOR BASS I KNOW WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO- MEET IN PERSON BUT I.
HAVE HEARD WELL WE'VE MET BEFORE
AND I HAVE TO SAY- BRETT
FELDMAN- WITH- THE DIRECTOR
STREET MEDICINE AT USC- AND A
CONSTITUENT. HAS BEEN RAVING
ABOUT YOU AND SO I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT BECAUSE IT IS NICE TO
GET FEEDBACK FROM FOLKS IN MY
DISTRICT YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW.
LAST YEAR I CURATE AB THREE SIX
NINE WHICH WAS A STREET
MADISONVILLE AND IT WAS VETOED
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT EIGHT
SPARKED A CONVERSATION WITH THE
STATE ABOUT HOW WE WORK TO- MEET
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE. IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE AND IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT'S ALSO BEEN
INTEGRATED INTO- THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. AND I DO KNOW THAT- DOUG
DR FELDMAN- AS PART OF THE AD
HOC GROUP THAT HAS BEEN CONVENE
ALSO AS A RESULT- AND THAT
YOU'VE HAD- THERE'S A GROUP
CONSISTING OF FOUR HEALTH PLANS
AND FOURTH STREET MEDICINE.
ORGANIZATIONS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE. AND I HAVE HEARD A LOT OF
POSITIVE FEEDBACK- IS COMING
FROM THOSE MEETINGS AND SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR TAKING
THIS ON- I GUESS DO YOU ALSO
PLAN ON ISSUING AND ALL PLAN
LETTER TO ALLOW EIMBURSEMENTS
TO OCCUR. WHICH HAS BEEN THE
THING AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE.
THAT- DR FELDMAN SAID. YOU KNOW
HE HAS BEEN PROVIDING STREET
MEDICINE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS HE
HAS COBBLED TOGETHER MONEY FROM
NONPROFIT FROM GRANT. AND FROM-
THE INSTITUTION IT WORKS WITH
THE SCHOOL TO GO INTO THE
STREETS. TO PROVIDE CARE FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE ON HOUSE AND HE
HAS NEVER BEEN PAID. AND HE IS
NOT ALONE THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER PROVIDERS OUT HERE DOING
THIS WORK WHO HAVE NEVER BEEN
PAID AND THIS IF IT IS TO HAPPEN
THROUGH CALTRAIN. WILL ALLOW
THAT TO OCCUR. SO I WANNA JUST
THANK EVERYONE FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE A PAIN IN THE SIDE. TO
SPARK THIS KIND OF CONVERSATION-
I'M RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
STILL DELAYS WITH CAL AIM. SO
WITH ALL OF THAT. AND I AM
APPRECIATE DEEPLY HOW YOU HAVE
REMAINED ENGAGE WITH THE STAKE
HOLDERS AND HAVE REALLY TAKEN
THE FEEDBACK AND WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM YOU WHERE WE ARE AS IT
RELATES TO- ST MEDICINE IN
MANAGED CARE THAT PARTICULAR
SPACE. A CALENDAR. THANK YOU FOR
THAT FOR THE QUESTION AND AGREED
IT'S REALLY BEEN A GREAT
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND YOU KNOW I
THINK OF SOME FRUITFUL DIALOGUE
BETWEEN THAT KIND OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO I PLANS
AND PROVIDERS REALLY RECOGNIZE
THE OPPORTUNITIES HERE IT
RELEASED THREE MEDICINE PROVIDES
IS JUST IS IT IS SO IN A LINE
WITH WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH CAL AIM IN TERMS OF REALLY
MEDIAN INDIVIDUALS WHERE THEY
ARE BECOMING TRUSTED PROVIDERS
BECOMING TRUSTED- YOU KNOW-
INDIVIDUALS THAT AT THAT OUR
ENROLLEES I REALLY. LOOK TO YOU
AND KIND OF RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
THAT THERE IS- YOU KNOW THERE'S
THAT TRUST THEIR TO PROVIDE KIND
OF THE PATHWAYS TO CARE WE'VE
BEEN MEETING AND WE'RE WE'RE
EXPLORING AT FLEXIBILITIES
BETWEEN OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS
AND OUR PROVIDERS AND CONTINUE
TO WORK THROUGH WAYS TO
STREAMLINE AND REALLY I PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY SO THAT- THE R.
STREET MANAFORT ST MEDICINE
PROVIDERS CAN. PROVIDE SERVICES
SIMILAR TO I THINK ABOUT THE WAY
THE OBGYN- SERVE OUR INDIVIDUALS
TODAY IS REALLY VERY STREAMLINED
PROCESS NOT HAVING TO GO THROUGH
PRIMARY CARE AT POINT OF CONTACT
IN REALLY HAVING THE ABILITY TO
REALLY KIND OF WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THE PLAN SO THAT- THIS IS A
STREAMLINED AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT- ANOTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFIT OF THAT I AM HAPPY TO
KNOW IS BEING RECOGNIZED. IS
DOING SERVICES- AND I KNOW THAT
THIS HAS BEEN ADDED TO THE LIST
OF PREVENTATIVE SERVICES THAT
ARE COVERED UNDER THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM. SO THEY PROVIDE-
CRITICAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS
TO ENGAGE IN A HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT MAKES SENSE
FOR THEM AND I THINK THAT
DILUTES SERVICES ARE CRITICAL
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
MISTRUST- WITH THE BIRTHING
MEDICAL INDUSTRY- AND I
APPRECIATE IN YOUR RESPONSES
THAT YOU ALSO UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT A ROLE DOULAS PLAY AND
HOW WE DELIVER CARE. HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO ENSURE THAT HOSPITALS
AND SOCIAL SERVICES UNDERSTAND.
I THINK AT. MATERNITY CARE IS
ONE OF OUR AS THREE TOP-
COVERAGE OF QUALITY STRATEGY
METRIC AND GOALS AND SO REALLY
ORGANIZING OUR ENTIRE DELIVERY
SYSTEM TO FOCUS ON THOSE THOSE
THREE IT SO ITS MATERNITY CAROL
TO SEE THE THREE THE MATERNITY
CARE THOUSAND PREVENTIVE
SERVICES AND BAD BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INTEGRATION SO WE'VE
REALLY KIND OF I'VE BEEN VERY
CLEAR WHAT OUR PLANS ARE
PROVIDERS THAT WE WANT TO SEE
I'M VAST IMPROVEMENTS IN THOSE
CRITICAL AREAS WE HAVE A- GOALS
SEPT FIFTY BY TWENTY FIVE WHERE
WE WANT. I'M CERTAIN PERCENTAGE
INCREASES IN SOME OF THESE
METRICS RELATED TO THOSE
CLINICAL. THE GOAL GOALS AND SO
REALLY ORGANIZING OUR ENTIRE
ENTIRE DELIVERY SYSTEM TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF KIND OF HOW WE CAN
MOVE THE MARK THERE AND I WILL
ALSO SAY YOU KNOW THE WORK FORCE
IS CLEARLY. AN ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN RAISED WITHIN THE HEALTH
CARE- SECTOR AND I THINK AS WE
THINK THROUGH NEW OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH AS JEWELERS WE CAN
RECOGNIZE THE ABILITY FOR THEM
TO DRIVE DOWN SOME OF THESE
COSTS TO BE PARTNERS. WITH SOME
OF OUR OUR TRADITIONAL HEALTH
HEALTH CARE- PROVIDERS SO THAT
WE CAN REALLY MAXIMIZE THE
ABILITY TO TOUCH THE LIVES OF
OUR MEDICARE ENROLLEES. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT MY- MY LAST
QUESTION FOR YOU IS. BECAUSE YOU
YOU YOU TALK ABOUT WORKFORCE AND
YOU ALSO MENTIONED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH A COUPLE OF TIMES. AND WE
KNOW THAT- EMERGENCY ROOM
DOCTORS ARE SAYING THAT THEY ARE
OVERWHELMED BY THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE COMING IN
AFTER TRYING TO HARM THEMSELVES-
THERE'S BEEN A 51% INCREASE IN
SUICIDAL ATTEMPTS BY YOUNG GIRLS
. WE HAVE A REAL SITUATION ON
OUR HANDS WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. ACROSS ETHNICITIES-
GENDER ORIENTATION I MEAN THIS
IS REAL THIS IS SO REAL. AND SO
WHAT IS THE OVERALL PLAN TO
COMBAT. THIS OVERWHELMING
INCREASE IN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH HEALTH ISSUES. BEYOND
MONEY WHAT'S OUR STRATEGY. I
THINK SOME OF THE WORK WE HAVE
UNDERWAY AND REALLY HAVE
DEPLOYED TO DATE IS SOME OF THAT
THE CAL WORK BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
POLICIES WHERE INDIVIDUALS CAN
NOW RISKY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES WITHOUT A DIAGNOSIS
DURING THE ASSESSMENT PERIOD
WE'VE ALSO SIMPLIFIED THE
CRITERIA FOR SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SO THAT CHILDREN
EXPERIENCING A SIGNIFICANT
TRAUMA SUCH AS HOMELESSNESS HOT
WATER SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT OR
JUVENILE JUSTICE- INVOLVEMENT
HAVE ARE AUTOMATICALLY ELIGIBLE
FOR SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WE ALSO CREATED A NO
WRONG DOOR POLICY TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS DO NOT NEED TO
DISRUPT ANY OF THEIR TRUSTED
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THAT ONE
SYSTEMS THE MANAGED CARE SYSTEM
FOR THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM ENSURE THAT THEY GET CARE
SOON AS THE AS IT REALLY IS AS
THEY PRESENT- I THINK ONE OF THE
OTHER PIECES THAT WE'VE KIND OF
THAT DEPLOYED RECENTLY IN THE
FALL WE AWARDED ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION TO FIFTY ONE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AUTHORITIES
AT. EIGHT FIVE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN SKEWS
ME- MOBILE CRISIS RESPONSE TEAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO REALLY
RECOGNIZING THAT SOME OP ED THAT
WE WANTED TO BUILD OUT OUR
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THOSE DOLLARS WERE
AWARDED IN THE TRUTH THAT TOOK
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET SO
REALLY GOT THOSE DOLLARS OUT TO
THE COMMUNITY AND THEN IN TERMS
OF OUR FUTURE KIND OF. OUR
FUTURE WORK IN WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON NOW IN TERMS OF
PLANNING AND PREPARING FOR IS
THE CHILDREN NEED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE WE WILL BE
LAUNCHING A VIRTUAL SERVICES AND
AECOM PLATFORM REALLY TO ENGAGE
UPSTREAM WITH WITH CHILDREN AND
YOUTH I'M- BE A RESOURCE FOR THE
OUR MOTION ALL AND SOCIAL HEALTH
AND- WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
CONVENING A THINK TANK TO REALLY
THINK THROUGH HOW WE CAN DEPLOY
AND BUILD OUT THIS PLATFORM.
YEAH ADDITIONAL DOLLARS RELATED. TO BUILDING. IN OUR OUR- CARE
. OUR SCHOOLS IN OUR COUNTY BE
HEALTH. AND REALLY I JUST
DOLLARS IN TERMS CAPACITY
BETWEEN THOSE PARTNERSHIPS. AND
THEN- I WOULD FINALLY ALSO NOTE
WE ARE HAVE SOME AND SOME
DOLLARS THAT WE ARE AT WILL BE
ISSUING REGARDING EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES REALLY STATEWIDE WHAT
ARE SOME OF THOSE. COMMUNITIES
DEVELOPED PROGRAM SOME OF THOSE
REALLY REALLY ARE RESPONSIVE
PROGRAMS THAT WE WANT TO SCALE
STATEWIDE YOU TO ADDRESS THAT
THE CONCERNS AND NEEDS OF OUR
YOUTH. AND THEN FINALLY IS PARTY
PUTTING YOU FOR HER HELP
INITIATIVE WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION RELATED TO
BUILDING OUT THE CONTINUE MUCH
INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER IT BE
WELLNESS CENTERS. IF YOU YOU
KNOW MORE RESIDENTIAL TYPE
SETTINGS THOSE DOLLARS WE WILL
BE RELEASING OUR PEOPLE ARE THE
RK FOR THOSE DOLLARS I'M COME
EARLY JACK GEODE AND SO REALLY
WANTING RECOGNIZING WE NEED TO
BUILD OUT THIS CONTINUUM AND
REALLY ATTRIBUTING. SOME
RESOURCES TO DO SO. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- REALLY INFORMED
RESPONSE I HAVE TO TELL YOU I
HAVE GOTTEN MORE INVOLVED IN
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THAN I
CARE TO FOR OF A NUMBER OF
REASONS THAT I'M NOT GOING TO GO
INTO. I HAVE BEEN SPENDING MUCH
MORE TIME WITH JEWELERS IN MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
THIS KIND OF WORK. AND OBVIOUSLY
I MEAN STREET MEDICINE I JUST
GIVEN THE DISTRICT AYE MAN AND
WHAT IS UPON US AS A STATE I
BELIEVE THESE ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES. I APPRECIATE
THE TIME THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT
HAS SPENT WITH MY OFFICE ON
THESE ISSUES. I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO SAY IT AGAIN AND MY COMMUNITY
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS FEEL LIKE
THEY FACE UNDUE BURDENS AND
TRYING TO BECOME. MEDICARE
PROVIDERS I HAVE HEARD THAT IN
THE SPACES THAT I HAVE
REFERENCED IN MY QUESTIONS- IT
SO I JUST ASK THAT YOU. CONTINUE
TO FIND A WAY TO BREAK.
PROVIDERS IT IS TRUSTED PARTNERS
THAT MY CONSTITUENTS RELY ON I
BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN MAKE IT
HAPPEN- I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR APPOINTMENT CONFIRMATION
TODAY BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. BUT JUST FOR THE RECORD
I'M ASKING THAT YOU ALL WORK TO
COME FIND A WAY TO MAKE THIS
WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR CAMARGO SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM. A GOOD
AFTERNOON HOW ARE YOU. IT SO I
DO WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS THAT AND WERE
BROUGHT FORTH BY MY COLLEAGUE
AND I EVEN GAVE A VERY VERY
INFORMED RESPONSE EVERYTHING CAL
AIM THAT I HAVE A COUPLE MORE
QUESTIONS REGARDING CALLIE MYTH
THAT'S OKAY. SO I GUESS I'M HOW
DOES DHS PLAN TO WORK WITH THE
LOCAL AGENCY PROVIDERS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO ENSURE A
SUCCESSFUL ROLLOUT OF THE
VARIOUS COMPONENTS OF CALLIN I
DON'T THINK THAT. THE
COORDINATION PIECE WAS MENTIONED
IN YOUR RESPONSE I'D LIKE A
RESPONSE TO THAT IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE. NO DEFINITELY THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I THINK.
AGAIN HELLO I'M IS REALLY
BREAKING DOWN THE WALLS OF
HEALTH CARE IN THE SILOS OF OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND YOUR POINT
WE NEED TO BUILD THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN SOME OF
THESE NEW PROVIDERS OR NEW.
ORGANIZATION THAT WE WANT TO
ENGAGE IN THE MEDICAL SYSTEM AND
SO THOSE POP DOLLARS THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER I'M REALLY
AREN'T OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORTS TO THESE ORGANIZATIONS
TO BRING THEM INTO THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. WE HAVE OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE WILL- START
REALLY SEEN- COME THIS SUMMER
REALLY TOOK TO IT. I KIND OF PUT
A AND M. THREE BIG BUCKETS
REALLY THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ON HOW DO YOU BECOME A MEDICAL
PROVIDER HOW DO YOU ENGAGE AND
KIND OF BUILD. BUILD OUT YOUR
YOUR- YOUR A CAPACITY. I THAN
COLLABORATION DOLLARS REALLY HOW
DO WE BUILD OUT THE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS.
AND THESE ORGANIZATIONS OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN BE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OF LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS DIFFERENT
COUNTY DEPARTMENTS- HOUSING AND
HOMELESS- ENTITIES. HOW DO WE
BUILD OUT THOSE COLLABORATION
DOLLARS ARE INTENDED TO REALLY.
BUILD AND BRIDGE THOSE-
PARTNERSHIPS TO REALLY THINK
THROUGH HOW WE CAN BREAK DOWN
THESE WALLS AND REALLY I'M- KIND
OF LOOK AT A PERSON A
COMPREHENSIVELY. AND THEN WE
HAVE CAPACITY DOLLARS. THERE'S
ACTUALLY INTENDED TO BUILD OUT
CAPACITY WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW
DOLLARS THAT MIGHT ADD SUPPORT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OR SUPPORT
WORKFORCE ON DAHLE ONBOARDING
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT IT PURCHASES ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE NECESSARY
SUPPORTS TO REALLY BUILD UP THIS
PROVIDER NETWORKAND- INSURE
THIS COLLABORATION BETWEEN OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND OUR
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU THINK YOU
MEMBER IMAGE I OFTEN SAY IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHER COMMITTEES
THAT WERE SHAPED BY THE
ENVIRONMENT OR WHAT ARE. AND YOU
KNOW OUR LIVES WHERE WE ARE AND
WHERE WE LIVE IN WE'RE SHAPED BY
OUR OWN EXPERIENCES. IN SO. OF
BEING A BUSINESS OWNER WHEN WE
SET OUT NEW PLANS IN- OF THE
BUSINESS. WE WANT TO TABLE GOALS
OR- MEASURABLE GOALS AND SO. IN
THAT ASPECT WITH CITIES WHICH DH
CS PLAN TO MONITOR EVALUATE THE
SIX SUCCESS OR MEASURABLE GOALS
OF AND- OF THE AIMED KILLING HIM
PLAN. THAT WE WILL BE COLLECTING
REALLY ROBUST INFORMATION
REGARDING ENCOUNTER DATA- IN
TERMS OF. WHAT SERVICES ARE
BEING AS THE PROVIDER SUPPORTED
I HOW THESE SERVICES ARE BEING
AND- YOU KNOW YOU I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE HOW WE WILL STRATIFY THE
INFORMATION TO KNOW IF DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS ARE RECEIVING
CERTAIN SERVICES IN OTHER
POPULATIONS ARE RECEIVING OTHER
SERVICES. HOW WE THINK THROUGH
WHERE ARE STATEWIDE PRESENCE
WITH OUR OUR ROLL OUT OF TELLING
HIM I'M AND THEN I THINK ALSO
REALLY TO POINT OUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS IS A PART OF A
DEMONSTRATION PART A PART OF
THIS IS. YOU KNOW THROUGH
WAIVERS AND SO WE WILL NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH A ROBUST
EVALUATION I'M HOW WE ARE
DELIVERING ON THE CALENDAR
DIRECTIVES AND HOW WE PLAN TO
KIND OF. CONTINUE THE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROCESS AS AS WE
WORK THROUGH THIS INITIATIVE.
OVER THE OVER THE NEXT FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS. THANK YOU MA'AM FOR
THAT RESPONSE I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE LAST QUESTION I HAVE TO-
ACTUALLY IF TO MAURY APOLOGIZE
BUT THAT THE SECOND TO THE LAST
QUESTION IS. WHAT ARE THE TRADE
OFFS IF THE ANNIE LIKE WHAT ARE
THE TRADEOFFS OF ENTERING NTO A
SEPARATE STATE WIDE CONTRACT
WITH KAISER PERMANENT TAKE.
RATHER THAN- A RECONFIRM A PER
CLAIM PROCESS FOR IMPLEMENTING A
DIFFERENT PROCESS OF REALLY
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES INTO
KAISER. IS THERE A TRADE OFF
AND- WITH THIS NEW PLANNER IS IT
NEEDING HOW BENEFICIAL WILL BE
PRESS. AT WE ARE PROPOSING THAT
WE HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL TO ENTER
INTO DIRECT CONTRACT WITH KAISER
AND WE'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE
KAISER IS A BIT DIFFERENT FROM
OTHER OUR OTHER MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS THEY ARE BOTH THE
PLAN AND A PROVIDER I'M THEY
REALLY BASED ON KIND OF THEIR
STRICKEN ORDERS AT A FACILITIES-
AND ARE DIFFERENT IN THAT OTHER
MANAGED CARE PLANS CAN REALLY
BUILD OUT THEIR NETWORKS BY
CONTRACTING OUT WITH DIFFERENT
PHYSICIAN GROUPS ARE PROVIDER
OFFICES. HI THERE IS A BIT
DIFFERENT- AND SO UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY WE ARE GETTING
MORE FROM KAISER- IN THE MEDICAL
SPACE THAN WHAT WE DO TODAY
TODAY KAISER HAS SOME EXEMPTIONS
FROM CERTAIN- CERTAIN MANAGED
CARE REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
FACILITY SITE REVIEWS MEDICAL
REVIEW PROCESSES UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL KAISER WOULD BE TREATED
NO DIFFERENT FROM OUR OTHER
MANAGED CARE PLANS THEY WOULD
HAVE TO FOLLOW ALL OF THE SAME
RULES- AND SO WE WOULD HAVE MORE
OVERSIGHT OF THEIR FUNCTIONS I'M
TODAY KAISER HAS ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEDI CAL
ENROLLEES- AND THEY ARE IN
TWENTY TWO I COUNTIES WE
DIRECTLY CONTRACT WITH THEM IN
FIVE COUNTIES. AND THEN WORK
THROUGH- THAT KIND OF A PRIVATE
PLAN SAYS DELEGATE PLAN IN IN
THE UPPER COUNTIES UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL HIGHS ARE WILL BE- IN
THIRTY TWO COUNTIES SO ANY PLACE
THAT THEY HAVE A COMMERCIAL LINE
OF BUSINESS THEY WOULD ALSO BE A
PARTICIPANT IN THE IN THE
MEDICAL SPACE. UNDER IS. HIGHS
ARE ENROLLMENT IS REALLY. ON SO
OPEN ENDED HAS SIR IT HAD HIGHS
ARE AND ALLOW. SIX TO TWELVE
MONTHS AND LET'S SAY FOR EXAMPLE
BE USED THEY LOSE. THEIR JOB.
THEY WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
DAY'S TIPS MAINTAIN OUR SELECT
KAISER AS PART OF. AS A MEDIC
CAL IN ROLE THAT PLAN. UNDER OUR
PROPOSAL. WE WOULD MAINTAIN THAT
CONTINUITY ABOUT FAMILY LINKAGE
I'M ABILITY BUT WE ALSO BE AN
OPENING ACT AND RULE MEANT YOU
DO ELIGIBLES. I MEAN SO IF
INDIVIDUAL SELECT KAISER FOR ART
THERE MEDICARE'S- PLAN THEY
WOULD ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ALIGN HIGHS ARE FOR THEIR
THEIR MEDICAL SPACE OF THESE ARE
SOME OF OUR- I'M INDIVIDUALS
WITH CHRONIC HEALTH NEEDS SOME
OF OUR COMPLEX CASE MANAGEMENT.
I'M AT. INDIVIDUALS AND THEN
FINALLY A FOSTER CARE. YOU'VE
CROSSED COUNTY LINES- AS
PLACEMENT CHANGE THINKING
THROUGH OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
FOSTER YOUTH TO HAVE TEIR
HEALTH INFORMATION TRANSITION
WITH THEM AS THEY MOVED ACROSS
COUNTY LINES. SO THAT FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE NOT UNIONIZED
TWICE OR THEY THAT THE PROVIDER
KNOWS THAT THAT THAT THE CHILD
IS ALLERGIC TO CERTAIN.
MEDICATIONS ARE REALLY THINKING
THROUGH SOME OF THESE POLICY
QUESTIONS ON HOW. A KAISER
SPOKESMAN IN THE STATE COULD
REALLY BENEFIT THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM. I ALSO AND AS AS A
RESULT OF SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE
PROPOSAL. REALLY THINKING
THROUGH OPPORTUNITIES TO
DIVERSIFY THE MIX OF ENROLLEES
OF MEDIC HOW- PARTICIPANTS AS
WELL AND SO. I THROUGH THE
DEFAULT ENROLLMENT PROCESS ALSO
WORKING THROUGH AN AD THE
ABILITY TO ASSIGN A RANDOM MIX
OF MEDIC HOW- INDIVIDUALS THAT
THE CASE MIX OF KAISER. IS VERY
SIMILAR TO OUR CASE MIX OF OTHER
MEDICAMENT LANDS. AND THEN
FINALLY I THINK ONE THING TO
NOTE IS- UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
KAISER IS COMMITTED PROVIDING IN
PERSON SPECIALLY CARE ACCESS IN
SOME OF OUR- AREAS. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I WHERE WE KNOW WE
HAVE SPECIALLY CARE ACCESS NEEDS
WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH KAISER
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND-
I'M OUR COMMUNITIES ARE WITH
REGARD TO THE LOCATION AND WHAT
TYPES OF SPECIALTIES. BUT
REALLY. UNDER THIS PROPOSAL
WE'RE GETTING HIGHS ARE TO
PARTICIPATE AND MEDICARE MORE
THAN TODAY WE'RE GETTING THEM TO
WORK ON WITH NINE KAISER MEMBERS
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE WORK
WITH OUR AND OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS AND SPECIALLY
CARE ACCESS. I'M AND WE THINK
THAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
BENEFICIAL- A PROPOSAL FOR THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM. IN OUR MEDICAL
BENEFICIARIES. THANK VERY MUCH
FOR THE I. THAT RISK. I'M DO YOU
HAVE AN IDEA THE CAMPAIGN. OR
THE- OF MEDICARE I'M- PATIENTS
IT WOULD BE SEEN. AT BECAUSE- IS
THEIR ESTIMATE OR- ADD DATING
SERVE ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEDI CAL ENROLLEES WE
KNOW THAT- WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. I'M WE KNOW
THAT OUR OUR ENROLLMENT IN MEDI
CAL AS WE START GOING TO RE
REDETERMINATION WILL- WILL GO
DOWN AND SO LIKELY THAT THAT
NUMBER WILL GO DOWN FOR KAISER
IS WELL SO. FROM THE START OF
THE TERM OF THE CONTRACT IT
WOULD BE A REQUIREMENT TO GROW
ABOUT 25% SO. TODAY THEIR
CAPTAIN ROMAN IN THIS IS REALLY
PUSHING MEDIC AT KAISER TO GROW. IN THE MEDICAL SPACE MORE THAN
THEY DO TODAY. OKAY WAS GOOD I
DIDN'T PLAN ON ASK THAT. BUT
BASED ON RESPONSE THANK YOU THE
LAST QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU. IS
GIVEN THE RECENT SIGNIFICANT
FINES. AGAINST LA CARE WITH YOUR
EXPERIENCE- SKEWS ME AND WITH
THE EXPERIENCE. WE NOW HAVE
ROUGHLY OVER THIRTY YEARS AND
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE. DO YOU
THINK IT'S TIME TO DECIDE DH CS
AND THE LEGISLATURE CONDUCT A
TOP TO BOTTOM REVIEW A BIT. YES
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS THAT ARE IN PLACE.
INCLUDING THE TWO TIER MODEL OR
THE TWO PLAN MODEL. I THINK I'M-
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I WOULD
POINT TO OUR OUR NEW MANAGED
CARE CONTRACT THAT WILL GO LIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND THIS IS
REALLY OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS. WE'VE
INSTITUTED AN ADDED MANY NEW
REQUIREMENTS WITH REGARD TO
MANAGED CARES. ARE OUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO BE TRANSPARENT TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE. IT REALLY MOVE
TOWARDS QUALITY AND EQUITY AS
THEY DELIVER THEIR SERVICES. AND
SO I THINK UNDER THAT WITH WITH
OUR NEW CONTRACTS WE'RE REALLY
GONNA HAVE A LOT MORE INSIGHT
INTO HOW OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS
OPERATE HOW THEY DELEGATE THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES- THEY DELEGATE
THE RESPONSIBILITIES TO YOU. AND
WHY THEY'RE DELEGATING THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WITH THIS
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE MADE
PUBLIC I THINK WE WILL ALL HAVE
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING FOR HOW
OUR PLANS DELIVER THEIR
SERVICES. I'M AND REALLY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO HOLD THEM MORE
ACCOUNTABLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS BASS THAT YOU'RE VERY.
YOU'RE VERY QUALIFIED AND YOU
HAVE A GREAT GRASP OF THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM SO- IT. APPEARS THAT WITH
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED.
FOR MY COLLEAGUES AND MYSELF SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR LETTING
ME ASK THOSE QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR GROWTH- AGAIN AS ALWAYS
IT'S GREAT TO GO LAST BECAUSE OF
PEOPLE HIT A NUMBER OF THE
TOPICS THAT ARE RELEVANT AND-
CURRENT TODAY INCLUDING. THE
KAISER PERMANENTE A CONTRACT
EXTENSION I WANT TO THANK YOU IN
YOUR DEPARTMENT FOR RESPONDING
ON QUESTIONS THAT HAVE COME UP
BEFORE THIS HEARING ON THAT
ISSUE AS WELL AS- CERTAINLY THE
MEDI CAL- PRESCRIPTION PROGRAM I
WANT TO THANK YOU YOUR YOU AND
YOUR DEPARTMENT HAVE BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE- SENATOR GROVE ARE
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT K. E.
CALLAHAM THAT MADE ME THINK OF A
QUESTION AND SHE TALKED ABOUT
THE VARIOUS. COMPONENTS OF THAT
IN YOU MENTIONED- HOMELESSNESS
IN PARTICULAR. HOW DOES THE
HOUSING COMPONENT OF THAT GET
PAID THROUGH THIS PROCESS IN THE
SYSTEM WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND
I'M NOT REAL CLEAR. WHERE WE ARE
TODAY AS OPPOSED TO WHEN WE
STARTED THIS DISCUSSION YEARS
AGO FRANKLY. WELL IT'S PART OF
CAL A WE HAVE THOSE FOURTEEN- I
HAVE PROPOSED OUR STATE PROPOSED
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS AND THREE OF
THEM RELATE TO HOUSING WE HAVE
HOUSING DEPOSIT HOUSING
TRANSITION SERVICES AND HOUSING
AYE NAVIGATION SERVICES. I'M AND
THOSE ARE REALLY MEANT TO KIND
OF. BE THE BRIDGE OR HOW
INDIVIDUALS MIGHT FIND- FUTURE
AND FUTURE LONG TERM AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
FOR AND IS SUPPORTED HOUSING IS
WE AS I MENTIONED EARLIER I WAS.
VISITING WITH SAP AS SACRAMENTO
COVER THIS MORNING AND REALLY
HEARING FROM THEM. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SUPPORTS AND
THEN THE BRIDGE TO KIND OF LONG
TERM HOUSING AND HOW WITH CALLIE
ALL OF THESE PIECES TOGETHER ARE
ACTUALLY. PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. YOU KNOW FURTHER ENGAGE
WITH INDIVIDUALS TO KIND OF
THINK THROUGH ITS IT IT DOES NO
LONGER STOPS WITH HOUSING UNDER
KALANICK CONTINUES TO GO THROUGH
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS RELATED
OKAY WHAT ARE YOUR FUTURE
INTERESTS. WE HAVE WE HAVE
FAVORABILITY OF SERVICES IS ONE
OF OUR COMMUNITY SUPPORTS AND
REALLY THINKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR JOB TRAINING
AND THAT LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY FOR FUTURE AND-
FUTURE JUST TIED ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A MEDIC CAL
ENROLLEES. I APPRECIATE THAT I
STILL DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND.
WHO PAYS FOR HOUSING. HOW DID
THE HOUSING SORRY WHO HAVE NO
IDEA FORGIVE ME- I KNOW ABOUT
ALL OF THE SURROUNDING
COMPONENTS OF. THE. SYSTEM BUT-
HOW DO YOU. BILL FOR HELLO. OR
WHO. THE UNIT OF HOUSING. AND IS
YOUR RENEWAL AND IS IT CONNECTED
TO THE INDIVIDUAL. THE HOUSING
ITSELF IS NOT FUNDED UNDER CAL
LAME BUT IT IS THE GOAL IS
THROUGH THESE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
VIC ADD THAT THOUGH AND- THE
LOCAL ENTITIES AND THAT
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE THAT HOUSING
AUTHORITIES THAT THROUGH THESE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE KIND OF.
MORE POSSIBLE WITH KELLY MADE
SOME OF THAT COLLABORATIVE
PLANNING DOLLARS THAT THESE
PARTNERSHIPS WILL- REALLY RESULT
IN RECOGNIZING HOW TO CONNECT
PEOPLE TO SOMEBODY'S HOUSING
SUPPORTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
OTHER OTHER SECTORS OF THE
COMMUNITY. OKAY THANK YOU I'M
THEIR IN LAWS MY WORDS HI. HI HI
HI HI I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR DECADES AND IT'S THE
HOUSING UNIT. AND THEN YOU KNOW
WE'VE TRIED TO I WILL. YES
WAIVERS DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION- I HAVE
FRIDAY SINCERELY HOPE THIS WORKS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A HOUSING
UNITS. I MEAN I JUST WONDER
ABOUT THE CONNECTIVITY BUT- YOU
CAUGHT MY ATTENTION THERE I
APPRECIATE- AND I AGREE WITH
SENATOR GROVE AND- AND MY
COLLEAGUES OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
OUR IN DEPTH EACH OF THESE
ISSUES. TO LIGHT TO TRACK IT'S A
LOT TO KEEP TRACK OF- I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT- WE GOING
TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC-
THAT WE SHOULD BE IN SUPPORT. AN
WE'RE GOING TO START RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE AND I WOULD
ASK PEOPLE TO APPROACH THE- THE
MICROPHONE WANTED TO TIME
KEEPING IN MIND SOCIAL DISTANCE
GIVE ME YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND VERY
BRIEFLY BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE MANY PEOPLE WAITING
ON THE TELECONFERENCE I'M GOING
TO- THE FOLKS HERE CAN SPEAK A
MOMENT OR TWO BUT WHEN WE GO TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE%
GONNA TAKE NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND SUPPORT OUT WITHOUT EXTRA
COMMENTS BUT I WILL GIVE THE WAY
BECAUSE YOU ARE HERE GO AHEAD
AND WELCOME. THANK YOU AND MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M DARBY KERN IN
REPRESENTING THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS OF CALIFORNIA. THE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS
SIXTEEN NONPROFIT. AND HEALTH
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS FROM AROUND
THE STATE WE ARE HERE TODAY AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
DIRECTOR MICHELLE BOB. AND HER
TIME IS THE UNDERSECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AND A LONG TIME AND STAFFER IN
THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE HE
IS MORE THAN QUALIFIED TO DO
THIS JOB. AND AS WE LOOK AT
KATHLEEN AND MEDIC CALYX MANSION
THERE IS NO ONE BETTER TO DO
THIS WORK WITH HER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT
WITNESS. WELCOME HI GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER SNIDERMAN
HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITIES
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR AND THE APPOINTMENT
OF MICHELLE MASS STRUCTURE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES- HEALTH FACILITIES- THE
CESSATION REPRESENTS SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED AND STATE AND ALSO
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES ARE
FOR HUNT CALIFORNIA. MANY MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MICHELLE
WORKED WITH MICHELLE OVER THE
YEARS BOTH AS DEPUTY SECRETARY
AND ALSO AS A BUDGET. CONSULTANT
AND WE JUST WANT TO SAY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT- THE
APPOINTMENTS AND WE SEE HER AS
VERY ACCESSIBLE SMART REASONABLE
INDIVIDUAL. HER ABILITY TO WORK
WITH GROUPS AND BE DIRECT BUT
ALSO- THE- ACCESSIBLE AND
REASONABLE AND SMART WE REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THAT- HER
ACTIVITIES ALSO DURING A CODED.
AS DEPUTY SECRETARY I DON'T-
WERE UNDENIABLY EXCELLENT ON
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK SHE'S DEDICATED TO
HER JOB AND HER SERVICE SO AGAIN
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT A
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON PAULA
VAZQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HERE REPRESENTING OUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
DIRECTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MISBAH SPURRED DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES C. TO
MEDIATE HAS AN EXCELLENT HISTORY
OF WORKING WELL WITH MISS BASS
DURING HER TIME- AS A STAFFER IN
THIS CHAMBER AND WITH SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AS WELL AS HER MORE
RECENT TENURE BOTH THE DAY. A.
ANNA'S UNDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
. GOOD AFTERNOON HELLO GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF KAISER PERMANENTE
HERE IN SUPPORTERS APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE WITH
HER OVER THE YEARS- FINDER TO BE
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS AND
REALLY WORKING FOR THE GOOD OF
THE HEALTH OF THIS OF THE
STATE'S OUT WORDS PARTICULAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OKAY SEEING NONE WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR THOSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT- I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE PUT THE-
NUMBER BACK UP ON THE SCREEN. OF
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR ONE.
AND THE- I WILL WELCOME THE
MODERATORS AND ASK TO IF YOU
WILL UPDATE ME ON HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
YES WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN Q.
RIGHT NOW. FROM IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU'LL NEED TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK UP THEY
HANDSET BEFORE PUSHING THE
NUMBERS. WHAT WILL GIVE YOU A
LINE NUMBER BEIJING BACK IN
QUEUE ONCE AGAIN IT IS ONE NINE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TEN KEEP GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BUT THE ARMSTRONG
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION- URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR DIRECTOR PAUL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
TERAFLOPS OF THAT CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT
OF THE NOMINATION OF MICHELLE BY
HE'S ALREADY WORKED TO ENSURE
QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND EQUITY
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS WE
APPRECIATED HER VISIONARY
LEADERSHIP THAT WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN HER WALL AND WE COULD NOT
THINK OF A BETTER CANDIDATE TO
RUN G. H. YEAH. THANK YOUNG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. BY NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS
IS SERRA DAY CAME ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES I JUST WANT THE ECHO
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY SAID THERE
IS NOT A BETTER CANDIDATE HOME
BE IT YEAH HI WE ARE DRAWN.
BEFORE OF THE BAQUBA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
. WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE MORE IN Q.
WE WILL GO NEXT OKAY MY NUMBER
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ERICA MURRAY PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND TRUMP APART AT
DIRECTOR BAPTIST NOMINATION. THE
TWENTY ONE PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM THAT FORM THE CORE OF THE
HEALTH CARE SAFETY NET
CALIFORNIA AND ARE ESSENTIAL
PARTNERS IN MEDIC CAL
PARTICULARLY ON ACCOUNTING FOR
THEM DIRECTOR BASKET MANY YEARS
IN THE LEGISLATURE AT HHS. AND
NOW WITH THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SHOWN HER TO BE DEEPLY DEDICATED
I DON'T LEADER AND PROBLEM
PALMER AND AS SOMEONE WHO
RECOGNIZES THE EXPERTISE OF
PUBLIC HOSPITAL. IN HELPING TO
IMPROVE CARE AND ADDRESS EQUITY
ISSUES THAT TRUMP THE QUARTER.
NOMINATION THANK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
LOCALI NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE
HAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
RUNNING PARTICULAR HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ARE MORE
THAN. OR IN YOUR HOSPITAL TO
HELP SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
WORKERS FORGET PAYMENT OF I'M
SHALL OF THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. I THINK HER POINT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS THAT I HAVE
YOU HEARD- AND ENGAGED- AND BEEN
COLLABORATIVE IN OUR SHARED
EFFORT. TO IMPROVE THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM AT THE FOR THESE READ
AND- SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. BROUGH LINE UP
THIRTY TWO BASEBALL. THANK YOU
MEMBER TEN MAHER WITH CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL. HERE IN STRONG OF
CONFIRMATION OF INSURANCE. CARE
ACT YOU'RE OF EACH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
YOUR AVAILABLE LINE NUMBER TWO
NINE THE BILL HAS. HI MADAM
CHAIR ANTHONY WRIGHT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATEWIDE
HEALTHCARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
GROUP. IN SUPPORT- THE SHOW BY
STATE DIRECTOR. NUMBER PREPARE
FOR YOU. I CHAMBERS MY EDUCATION
AND- WE'RE WORKING THAT AREA SO
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK THAT ABOUT TWO LEFT IN THE
QUEUE WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN. I NEVER THIRTEEN YEAR
OPEN. OKAY WE WILL MOVE TO THE
NEXT LINE WHICH IS THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY NAY GALLAGHER
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM IN
OUR STATE AND WE APPLAUD AND THE
FACTORS THAT COULD NOT HIT THE
TASK OF WRITING SUCH A
COMPLICATED. PROGRAM AND HAVING
THE PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH THE
FIVE IN A ROW WITH THE AGENCY
INTERNET I JUST COMMITTEE WE
HAVE NO DOUBT SHOULD BRING THE
SAME RIGOR AND WHILE WELL THAT
POLICY. ANY QUESTIONS ARE FOR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY FOR WITNESSES
. NO WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE Q.
MENTIONED THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU IN JUST A MOMENT ARE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AND WE
WILL START IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
SEE NO ONE- APPROACHING THE
PODIUM TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SO- MADAM MODERATOR I'M GONNA
COME BACK TO YOU. AGAIN I'M
GOING TO DO ONE LAST REMINDER.
FOR THIS PORTION OF THE HEARING
THAT THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR
ONE. FIVE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION- MADAME MODERATOR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEETING DOWN IF
YOU ARE NOT POSITION WE'VE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
OPPOSITION. ONE NINE ZERO. I DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY KILLING A
PREPOSITION. MADAME MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WILL HEAR
FROM YOU A LITTLE BIT LATER IN
THE HEARING FOR OTHER
APPOINTMENTS LET ME BRING IT
BACK- TO OUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
DYESS AND SEE IF THERE ARE
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY I THINK THE OVER ONE. YEAH
BY OKAY THANK YOU VICE CHAIR THE
SAN LAYER A MADAM CHAIR I WOULD
MOVE THE CA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROTHE RO
FIVE KAMLAGER. I'M LONGER I'D
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES. BATES
AYE ATKINS. FIVE WELL THAT IS
WONDERFUL NEWS- DIRECTOR BOSS-
WE WILL MOVE THIS APPOINTMENT ON
TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CONGRATULATIONS AND WITH OUR
INCREDIBLE THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUCH
AN HONOR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU-
LET ME SEE IF WE NEED TO TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE BREAK- WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE. OUR NO NO DOUBT WE
WILL NEED ONE A LITTLE BIT LATER
BUT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND WE
HAVE- TWO APPOINTMENTS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP. ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM ONE B.
AND ONE C. THESE ARE THE
APPOINTMENTS TO THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. OF MARCO
MEET AS UNDERSECRETARY AND
BRENDAN J. MCCARTHY MCCARTHY. AS
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF PROGRAMS IN
FISCAL AFFAIRS- TO BOTH
GENTLEMEN PLEASE FORGIVE MY
INABILITY TO SPEAK SOMETIMES I
THINK IT'S THE MASK AND OTHER
TIMES IT'S MY- MISPRONOUNCING
ATION OF NAMES RIGHT NOW IT WAS
BOTH. SO HOT BUT I DO WANT TO
WELCOME BOTH OF YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
PATIENCE- AS WE DID EARLIER ALL
START WITH- THE UNDERSECRETARY.
MEECH AND INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF WE HAVE SEEN
YOU BEFORE NOT THAT LONG AGO-
BOAT WE WELCOME YOU HAVE FEEL
FREE TO OPEN IN MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS IT KNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU
WANT. AND THEN WE WILL. GO AND
THEN TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR MCCARTHY
BUT RIGHT NOW UNDER SECRETARY
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
I IS WONDERFUL TO BE BACK IN
FRONT OF YOU SO MADAM PART TIME
MADAM VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE I'M
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE. BEFORE YOU TODAY AND
I'M THANKFUL TO EACH OF YOU FOR
CONSIDERING MY APPOINTMENT. I
ALSO WANT TO EXTEND MY THANKS TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS
YOUR PERSONAL STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK IN PREPARATION FOR THIS
HEARING. AND BEFORE I BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY FAMILY FIRST I'D
LIKE TO KNOWLEDGE MY WIFE
VERONICA MEECH. AND MY FOUR YEAR
OLD SON LUCAS THEY ARE MY
BIGGEST CHEERLEADERS AND I'M
VERY GRATEFUL TO HAVE THEIR
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE AND SUPPORT.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY PARENTS MADE US LAUGH AND
BEST NUMBER EACH AND MY MOTHER
AND FATHER IN LAW IMELDA AND
JUAN RAMIREZ AS IMMIGRANTS
STAINED BODY THE BEST OF THIS
COUNTRY. AND COLLECTIVELY THEY
HAVE TAUGHT ME THE VALUE OF
FAMILY HARD WORK AND SERVICE
FINALLY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
BROTHER PETER MEECH MY BROTHER
AND SISTER LINE MICHELANGELO
DAMAGE AS WELL AS MY BROTHER AND
SISTER LA JOLLA JOHNNY AND
CHRISTINA RAMIREZ. MY DEEPEST
THANKS AND GRATITUDE ALSO GOES
TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN SECRETARY
GALLEYS FOR HAVING THE
CONFIDENCE AND- RUN THEIR BOLD
VISION FOR GIVING ME THIS TRULY
ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY.
YES PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
FINALLY I AM SO GRATEFUL TO THE
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
THAT COMPRISE A CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
THEY TRULY REPRESENT THE VERY
BEST A PUBLIC SERVICE AND I AM
HONORED TO BE. TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM THEM
EACH AND EVERY DAY AND TWO OF
THEM ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY
MICHELLE BOSKO YOU JUST HEARD
FROM AND BRANDON MCCARTHY WHO
YOU WILL SEE HER OR HEAR FROM
YOU SOON AND YOU WILL WITNESS
FIRST HAND. THERE ON YIELDING
COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. I ALSO WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
HORRIFIC VIOLENCE THAT OCCURRED
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO THIS
WEEKEND. WE LOST SIX INDIVIDUALS
WAY TOO SOON THEY WERE EACH PART
OF OUR CALIFORNIA FAMILY I
CERTAINLY CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT
EACH OF THEIR FAMILIES IS GOING
THROUGH AT THE MOMENT. BUT I DO
HOPE THAT THEY CAN FIND SOME
COMFORT IN THE MEMORIES THAT
THEY HAVE. OF THE ONCE THEY A
LOST. THE PAST SEVEN YEARS KELLY
TO TRUST COUPLED WITH TIME AT
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION HAVE PREPARED
ME FOR THIS ROLE IS THROUGH
THESE EXPERIENCES THAT I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND THE POWER PUBLIC
SERVICE OUR JOB IS GOVERNMENT IS
NOT ONLY TO LEFT HIGHER THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN MARGINALIZED BUT TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
ABLE TO LIVE HEALTHY AND
PRODUCTIVE LIVES THIS IS THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR WORK AT
COLLEGES CHEST AND IT'S OUR
PURSUIT AND- HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL. SIMPLY PUT WE CAN AND
WE MUST WORK TO BUILD AN
INCLUSIVE JUST AND TOLERANT
SOCIETY TO ME THIS IS THIS WORK
IS PERSONAL ALMOST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS TEN YEARS
OLD I ARRIVED IN THE UNITED
STATES AS A REFUGEE FLEEING THE
WAR TORN COUNTRY AS I LOOK AT
WHAT'S OCCURRING IN UKRAINE
TODAY I'M REMINDED THAT
PAINFULLY THE PAINFUL TRUTH THAT
INDEED HISTORY HAS A WAY OF
REPEATING ITSELF WHEN I ARRIVED
IN THE UNITED STATES I SPOKE NO
ENGLISH. AND MY FAMILY HAD
LITTLE TORN NAMES BEYOND THE
CLOTHES ON OUR BACKS AND THE FEW
PERSONAL POSSESSIONS WE'VE WE
WERE ABLE TO CRAM IN OUR
SUITCASES MY PARENTS SACRIFICED
EVERYTHING SO THAT MY BROTHERS
AND I COULD HAVE A BETTER LIFE
AND A CHANCE AT A FUTURE I SHARE
THIS WITH YOU TODAY BECAUSE MY
CHARACTER IS SHAPED BY MY LIFE
EXPERIENCES AND MY COMMITMENT TO
GIVE BACK TO OUR COUNTRY AND I
STATE THAT A CHECK A CHANCE ON
ME. I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
HOPE TO EARN YOUR TRUST AND YOUR
VOTE I DON'T PRETEND TO BE
PERFECT AND I KNOW I WILL HAVE
CHALLENGES AND MISTAKES IN THIS
ROLES HOWEVER TODAY AND EVERY
DAY THAT I HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA I COMMIT TO DOING SO
WITH RESPECT INTEGRITY AND
HONESTY. IT'S EASY TO BE
OVERWHELMED BY THE GRAVITY OF
PROBLEMS THAT FACE US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND EVEN AROUND THE WORLD YET I
REMAIN HOPEFUL I REMAIN HOPEFUL
BECAUSE WHEN I LOOK AT MY SON
LUCAS WHEN I LOOK AT THE ASYLUM
CHILDREN WE SURVEYED THAT
SOUTHERN BORDER AND WHEN I LOOK
AT THE REFUGEE CHILDREN WE'VE
SERVED FROM AFGHANISTAN I SEE IN
THEM A SENSE OF OPTIMISM THAT
IT'S HARD TO EXTINGUISH THEY
COLLECTIVELY WE HAVE A BRIGHT
FUTURE AHEAD OF THEM BECAUSE
HERE ARE DIVERSITY. IS OUR- I'M
A TESTAMENT OF THAT AND- THE
FOUNDING PROMISE OF THIS
WONDERFUL STATE IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO I THANK YOU FOR HAVE GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU AGAIN. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION
TODAY. THANK YOU- UNDER
SECRETARY LET'S TURN NOW TO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR MCCARTY. AND
OFFER YOU THE SAME OPPORTUNITY
TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS LET ME SAY
WELCOME TO YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF MY
APPOINTMENT. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THIS
TIME SPENT CONCERNING MY
APPOINTMENT AND ALL THE
APPOINTMENTS TO COME BEFORE THE
RULES COMMITTEE. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM SECRETARY
GALLEY AND UNDERSECRETARY NEEDS
FOR MY APPOINTMENT. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. I'D
LIKE TO THANK MY WIFE TRACY
MCCARTHY. MY SONS DECLAN CONNOR
MY MOTHER SUZANNE MCCARTY. MY
GRANDMOTHER DOROTHY MCCARTY AND
THE REST OF MY FAMILY FOR ALL
THE LOVE AND SUPPORT THEY HAVE
GIVEN ME. FROM A VERY YOUNG AGE
MY PARENTS INSTILLED IN US THE
IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC SERVICE AND
THE VIRTUE OF WORKING TO MAKE
OUR COMMUNITY A BETTER PLACE FOR
ALL. AS A LONG TIME LEGISLATIVE
STAFF MEMBER NOW PART OF THE
KELLY CHESS TEAM. I'VE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO WORK FOR AND WITH
AMAZING PUBLIC SERVICE. I'VE
SEEN WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN
LEGISLATIVE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
LEADERS CHALLENGE US. TO PUSH
THE STATUS QUO AND MAKE CHANGES
WE NEVER THOUGHT POSSIBLE. WHEN
I FIRST STARTED WORKING ON
HEALTHCARE POLICY IN THE SENATE
WE WERE JUST STARTING TO
IMPLEMENT THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT AND UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS WERE ONLY ELIGIBLE
FOR BASIC LIMITED SCOPE MEDICAL
SERVICES. TODAY WE REFORMED OUR
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETS CREATED
A THRIVING COVERED CALIFORNIA
MARKETPLACE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY. WITH EXPANDED FULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY TO
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN YOUNG
ADULTS SENIORS AND NOW THIS YEAR
WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF MAKING
UNDOCUMENTED ALL UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE AMAZING PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE IN CALIFORNIA AND
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M PROUD TO
PLAY EVEN THE SMALLEST PART. I'M
HONORED AND EXCITED TO BE PART
OF THIS WORK AND TO CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH OUR PARTNERS IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIRMAN I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- N. F. TO MADAM VICE
CHAIRMAN IF WITH YOUR PERMISSION
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO GO TO OUR
TO MEMBERS THAT MAKE IT PULLED
FOR HEALTH COMMITTEE JUST IN
CASE- SO. AND WE'RE WORKING ON
SOME TECHNOLOGY HERE SO CENTER
COME LONGER WHY DON'T I START
WITH YOU. SO THAT YOU CAN AND
YOU CAN ASK I WOULD ASK YOU TO
DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO EITHER
THE UNDER SECRETARY OR THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. OF SINCE WE'RE
TAKING THEM BOTH AT THE SAME
TIME BUT THEY'RE NOT THE SAME
POSITION I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES
KNOW THAT SO IF YOU'LL JUST
DIRECT THE QUESTION. AND MY
COLLEAGUES FOLLOW SUIT I WILL
LET YOU GO AHEAD. THANK YU
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM AND IT
IS GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH AGAIN I
APPRECIATED THAT TIME- THAT WE
HAD TOGETHER THE OTHER DAY- AND-
YOU KNOW I'M STILL IMPRESSED. I
YOU KNOW MR MCCARTHY WHEN YOU
WERE TALKING YOU SAID YOU KNOW
THAT- GRATEFUL FOR THE PUSH PUSH
PUSH TAT COMES FROM. THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE ALSO
INVESTED IN THIS JOURNEY THAT
YOU ALL ARE ON. AND- YES TO THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE TO SAY YOU ALL
HAVE A HEAVY LIFT WHICH IS TO
CHANGE HOW WE DELIVER HEALTH
CARE SERVICES- IN PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SETTINGS. IN A WAY THAT
IS. EFFECTIVE AND
TRANSFORMATIVE. AND I THINK THAT
CERTAINLY DOES DESERVE THREE
PUSHES- I. WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THIS OF- MARCO- AND THAT WE I
ASK THIS WHEN WE MET. ABOUT THE
CARE COURTS- THIS PROPOSAL THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PUT FORTH THAT
IS- I THINK VERY DARING- AN
INTERESTING. AND ALSO WILL
REQUIRE THE BUY IN FROM
COUNTIES- WHO HAVE. SAID AT
LEAST IN A COUPLE OF MEETINGS
THAT I HAVE HAD- APPLAUD. THE-
TEN THE OF THE PROPOSED. AND
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
CAPACITY AND IMPLEMENTATION- AND
THE REAL WORK THAT HAPPENS YOU
KNOW BEHIND THE CURTAIN AND SO
WOULD LOVE YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ON
HOW. YOU ALL ARE WORKING THROUGH
THOSE CANDID DISCUSSIONS HOW YOU
ARE SUPPORTING COUNTIES THAT MAY
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY- BUT WANT
TO BE PART OF THIS- WOULD LOVE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON SORT OF THAT
PROCESS- THE CHALLENGES AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES. A CENTER COME
LONGER FIRST THANKS FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO MEET WITH US AND
THANK YOU FOR PUSHING US ON ST
MEDICINE AND SO MANY OTHER
THINGS SO CONTINUE TO PROCESS
THAT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT. I'M
CARE COURT IN PARTICULAR WHAT I
WILL SAY THERE IS THAT I THINK
THAT WE HAVE FAILED THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND WHAT I WILL JUST
START WITH IS THAT. THIS ISN'T
FOR ALL HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
THIS ISN'T INTENDED TO BE FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE MENTAL
UNLESS BUT RATHER FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE SEVERE SCHIZOPHRENIC
DISORDERS OR PSYCHE AS AT A
PARTICULAR SMALL GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THAT
CATEGORY. AND IT IS GOING TO
TAKE ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER
HOLISTICALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO NOT PLAY HOT POTATO WITH
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE LOOK
AT THIS FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE HOLISTIC NEEDS THAT THEY
HAVE AND THE WAYS THAT WE
ALTERNATELY WRAP OURSELVES
AROUND THEM. I TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE ON A TRAJECTORY THAT
AVOIDS CONSERVATORSHIP AND
AVOIDS INCARCERATION BECAUSE IT
IS TOO EASY TO GET TO THOSE
POINTS AND THEN ACTUALLY RECEIVE
THE NECESSARY MENTAL HEALTH CARE
WHAT ALSO WILL SAY IS THAT I'M
THIS IS A FRAMEWORK. CAN WE PUT
OUT A FRAMEWORK WITH THE IDEA
THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE A LOT OF
CONVERSATION WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES OF WHAT
THIS REALLY WILL MEAN ON THE
GROUND. TOO OFTEN WE PUT
TOGETHER IDEAS IN THEORY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT WE TEND TO NOT
REALIZE ALL THE PRACTICAL
IMPLICATIONS ON THE GROUND AND
SO WE HAVE PUT OUT A PROPOSAL OR
CONCEPT FOR A FRAMEWORK WITH THE
IDEA THAT WE ENGAGE IN DEEP AND
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS ARE CIVIL RIGHTS
PARTNERS OTHERS. IN THE
COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE THE
PRACTICAL IMPLICATIONS I THINK
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE COMING
DAYS WEEKS AND MONTHS AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE TOWARDS A PATH
OF ADOPTING. THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
YOU KNOW I THINK WE HAVE SPENT.
NOT ENOUGH TIME. AND KNOWLEDGE
IN. HOW POVERTY HOW MENTAL
HEALTH HOW ACCESS TO CARE OR
LACK OF ACCESS TO CARE OVER
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME. HOW
THAT TRULY DOES AFFECT NOT JUST
INDIVIDUALS BUT ALSO FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES. AND THE STOP
GAP SHOULDN'T BE YOU KNOW THE
CRIMINAL COURTS. WE SHOULD BE
GOING BACK TO HAVING DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT WHAT REAL HOLISTIC.
PREVENTATIVE CARE LOOKS LIKE- SO
IGUESS I'LL ASK THIS QUESTION
OF MINUTES MR MCCARTHY- YOU KNOW
AS PART OF THE- JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM REALIGNMENT OF JUSTICE
INVOLVED YOUTH. FROM ST COUNTY
FROM STATE CUSTODY TO THE
COUNTIES THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION WAS
ESTABLISHED- EFFECTIVE JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN. YOU
KNOW- WHAT'S ATTENTIONS IN THIS
SPACE RIGHT HOW WE ADDRESS- THIS
POPULATION HOW DO WE RAMP UP
WHAT THE OFF RAMPS LOOK LIKE.
AND SO JUST WONDERING YOUR
THOUGHTS ON HOW YOU'RE
SUPPORTING COUNTIES THAT MAY NOT
HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO CARE FOR
SOME OF THESE USED- THAT NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SEEING.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER SO WE ARE AT THAT AGE
YOU'RE VERY FORTUNATE WITH IN
THE OFFICE OF USING COMMITTEE
RESTORATION WE HAVE BROUGHT ON
JUDGE KATHRYN SERRA FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY TO LEAVE THAT
OFFICE IT'S A- REAL WIN FOR THE
STATE TO BRING IN SUCH A
THOUGHTFUL LEADER. SO SHE HAS
STARTED WORKING SHE HAS ACTUALLY
MET WITH EVERY SINGLE COUNTY
PROBATION OFFICER IN THE STATE.
AND SHE AND HER T. SMALL TEAM
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL BUILDING
OFFICE BUT HER TEAM ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE PLANS
THAT EACH COUNTY SUBMITS IN
ORDER TO ACCESS GRANT FUNDING-
TO CARE FOR THIS REALIGNED
POPULATION THAT IS SO
VULNERABLE. AND SO PART OF THAT
WORK IS THAT THEY ARE PROVIDING
FEEDBACK TO THE COUNTIES ON WAYS
TO IMPROVE THE PLAN SO THAT
THERE REALLY IS A GOOD
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOR HOW TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THESE ISSUES
AS THEY COME OUT OF. THE
FACILITIES. I'M JUDGE TWO ZERO
ALSO WORKING. THE STATE WITH
OTHER STATE PARTNERS TO THINK
ABOUT THIS- AND IS ALSO- WORKING
WITHIN EVEN WITHIN OUR AGENCY TO
THINK MORE BROADLY ABOUT HOW WE
CAN SUPPORT THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION SO. THE WORK IS JUST
GETTING STARTED BUT I THINK WE
HAVE A REALLY GREAT LEADER WHO'S
GOING TO TAKE US THERE. GREAT
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I HOPE ALSO
INTO YOU KNOW INFUSED IN THAT
IS. ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE WE
CANNOT ALLOW THESE YOUNG FOLKS
TO FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS- AND
THEN YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE BLAME
GAME HAPPEN AND IT'S THE COUNTY
pAT THE END OF THE DAY. IT'S
REALLY THE USE RIGHT IN MAKING
SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING WHAT
THEY NEED. I WOULD JUST MY FINAL
QUESTION IS- JUST TO THE
UNDERSECRETARY AND I KNOW THAT-
CAL HHS HAS TWO KEY STRATEGIES.
TO SUPPORT- THE COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS IS COLLECTIVE WORK
AND ONE OF THE STRATEGIES IS
INCREASING THE LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND VISIBILITY
OF THE HOMELESSNESS INVESTMENT.
AND JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN TO YOU BECAUSE WE
SPEND SO MUCH TIME TALKING ABOUT
HOW WE ARE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSING. THE HOMELESS
POPULATION I MEAN OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW STREET MEDICINE MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE GIVING IT GRANTS AND
CAMMING GRANTS ETCETERA ETCETERA
BUT PEOPLE ALSO WANT TO KNOW.
THE BANG FOR THE BUCK- AND THE
VISIBILITY OF WHAT WE ARE
GIVING. OUT TO OUR PARTNERS AND
WHAT WE'RE GETTING BACK IN SO
JUST FOR ME THE FRAME OF THE
WORK THAT YOU DO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN TO YOU. I THINK THIS IS OUR
AND THIS IS AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK
HOMELESSNESS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS IN OUR FACE ON A DAILY BASIS.
I YOU CAN WALK DOWN THE STREET
AND SEE OUR OWN NEIGHBORS WHO
ARE HOMELESS AND STUFF FOR US I
THINK THAT THE THING HERE IS
THAT WE ARE WE ARE PART OF THIS
THE R. SECRETARY CO CHAIRS WITH
SECRETARY LUIS. CASTRO TO MEET
AS THAT INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS AND THE IDEA AROUND
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IS REALLY THAT WE ARE LEVERAGING
EACH OTHER'S PROGRAMS AND
DOLLARS IN A MORE HOLISTIC WAY
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE TRYING TO
SERVE. I TAKE THAT A STEP
FURTHER AND ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE GOOD VISIBILITY AND
INSIGHTS ON HOW DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT. THERE ISN'T THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR US TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S FLEXIBILITY
WITH REGARDS TO HOW THESE
PROGRAMS ARE DELIVERED AT THE
LOCAL GROUND BECAUSE WHAT WORKS
IN SAN DIEGO MAY NOT ORK IN
OAKLAND OR IN FRESNO. AND SO
THERE HAS TO BE IN A LOT AYE AYE
AND ABILITY TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THE STATE HAS TO ENSURE THAT THE
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT IN A
PRUDENT WAY AND SO WE'RE WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH OUR- PARTNERS AT
THE BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING AGENCY. TO REALLY
ALIGN THE INCENTIVES AND THE
METRICS THAT WE- THE- THAT WORK
. DOLLARS FOR THE CAN IN RE TIME
VALUE THEIR- AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE GENERATE OR JUST AS WE GO SO
THAT WE'RE NOT WAITING FIVE
YEARS LATER FOR AN EVALUATION. I
PARTICULAR GRANT PROGRAM TO MAKE
A DETERMINATION THAT THE DOLLARS
ONCE BANNED OR THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE WERE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
WEREN'T REALLY ACHIEVED. AND SO
FOR US IT'S REALLY ABOUT HOLDING
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE FINDING. IT'S
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
HOLDING OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
WHETHER THAT'S COUNTIES ARE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
ARE WORKING WITH US ACCOUNTABLE
AS WELL IN THAT PROCESS. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS I
JUST I JUST WANT TO SAY AND I
SHARED A LITTLE BIT OF THIS WITH
YOU WHEN WE MET. YOU KNOW SOME
PEOPLE COME BEFORE US AND
THEY'RE SELLING THEMSELVES. AND
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO COME BEFORE
US. AND THEY BELIEVE WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING. AND THEY ARE HONEST
ABOUT THE WORK THAT IS IN FRONT
OF THEM. AND THEY ARE PREPARED
BECAUSE THEY ARE AWARE. AND
THAT'S YOU TO I HAVE EXTREME
CONFIDENCE IN YOU ALL AND I AM
VERY EXCITED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONFIRM YOU
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN YOU AND I
BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE WALKING
EYES WIDE OPEN INTO THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
AND- SO I JUST I HOPE YOU ACCEPT
A COMPLIMENT AND I WE ARE VERY
LUCKY. VERY LUCKY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU
SENATOR COM AUGUR A SENATOR
GROWTH THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEN
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE
TODAY I DIDN'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. VISIT WITH YOU
PRIOR TO THIS HEARING BUT I DO
REMEMBER YOUR CONFIRMATION- AS
UNDERSECRETARY MR MEET. IN
TWENTY I WAS TWENTY TWENTY M.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
THAT YOU MADE I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS NOW THAT I SUPPORTED
YOUR CONFIRMATION THE PAST AND
I'M JUST GOING TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU AND SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS. THERE'S NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND WHATSOEVER THAT AND
YOU KNOW YOUR JOB WELL YOU DO
THERE I HAVE NO DOUBT IN THAT
AND I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT YOU
KNOW HOW TO PRIORITIZE AND GET
WORK DONE AND YOU DO SHOWS THAT
QUALITY. SO I HAVE A HUGE
CONCERN WHEN OUR STAFF AND ON
HAVE ASKED YOU ABOUT THE VALENSI
LAB AND YOU CAN'T GET THAT
INFORMATION TO OUR STAFF. I
BELIEVE IN WHAT MIKE A COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES SAID ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY SOMEONE TO TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT IT ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE- LAB-
BRANCH LAVISH YOU. SO ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE FOR YOU
MISTER MAGE IS THAT. IT TOOK
ROUGHLY NINE MONTHS FOR CD PHP
COMPLETE REVIEW THE VINCE
BILLION SEALAB- THE BRANCH LAB
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE YOUR FOCUS
WITH THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITH THE UNACCEPTABLE DELAYS IN
MY OPINION IT COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE DELAYS. IN THE
REVIEW AT THE. VALENCIA BRANCH
LAB. THE FIRST I OF. YOU ASKING
ME THIS QUESTION AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE. BECAUSE I MADE MADE
MYSELF AVAILABLE TO YOUR STAFF
AS WELL AS THE REPUBLICAN STAFF
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS. AND HAVE
ALSO ANSWERED ALL QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SENT MY WAY. I ALSO AM
EXTREMELY PROUD OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO WITH THE
VALENCIA LAB I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF MISINFORMATION AROUND THE
VALENCIA LAB IN PARTICULAR. BUT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. YOU
AND OTHERS WERE WATCHING TODAY
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THAT
WE DAD AND HOW IT IS THAT WE DID
AT. THE FIRST AND FOREMOST THERE
WAS A DELAY IN TERMS I HAVE. HAD
THEIR THE REVIEW IN THE REPORT
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO HAVE. A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION THAT WAS
INDEPENDENT WE ASKED NOT ONLY
OUR OWN INVESTIGATORS TO GO WHEN
WE ASKED A THIRD PARTY
ACCREDITING BODY TO GO IN. AND
WE ASK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
GO IN AND TO REVIEW ALL THREE
CAME BACK AND CLEARED THE
LABORATORY. I SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND. THE
DELAY WASN'T BECAUSE WE WERE
HIDING ANYTHING BUT RATHER WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WAS MULTIPLE LAYERS INDEPENDENT
OF OURS. REVIEWING THE
LABORATORIES BUSINESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WAS RIGHT. THE
OTHER THING THAT I WILL SAY
SENATOR IS THAT THE GOAL HERE
WAS TO DISRUPT THE MARKET AND TO
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTING. UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC MORE
THAN 50% OF THE SPECIMENS
COLLECTED AND PROCESSED AT THIS
LABORATORY. CAME FROM LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS IN DISTRICTS FROM
ALL OF YOU ARE AT THE DIETS
ADDITIONALLY WE WERE ABLE TO
RECOUP ALL OF THE DOLLARS THAT
WE SPEND FROM EITHER FEMA OR
INSURANCE COMPANIES. AS A RESULT
OF THE TESTING THAT WE DID AT
THE LABORATORY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY ALL FOUR SEARCHES
ARE FIVE SURGES THAT WE'VE HAD.
THIS LABORATORY HAS BEEN THE TOP
PERFORMING ONE OF THE TOP
PERFORMING VOLUME LABORATORIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
THERE WAS A LOT OF UP AND DOWN
WITH REGARDS THIS AT THE VERY
BIG.I THINK THAT THERE WAS- A
LOT OF MISINFORMATION- IN
REGARDS TO WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED
AT THE LABORATORY BUT I WILL SAY
THIS UNEQUIVOCALLY I AM
EXTREMELY PROUD OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS ENDEAVOR THERE
WAS ONLY THE ABILITY TO DO TWO
THOUSAND TAX A DAY TO DAY
THERE'S A COMMERCIAL CAPACITY
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OF NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND TESTS
PER DAY. WAS IT PERFECT
ABSOLUTELY NOT COULD WE HAVE
DONE A BETTER YES BUT WE WERE IN
THE MIDST OF A WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC. AND OUR GOAL HERE WAS
TO TRY TO SAVE LIVES AND WE DID
EXACTLY THAT. THANK YOU AND I
AND I APOLOGIZE I CUT JUST THE
FIRST PART OF IT BUT NOT THE
LAST PART YOU SAID IT WAS
DISTRICT- IT WAS THE- PLAN WAS
DISRUPTED WAS THEIR PURPOSEFUL
PLAN TO DISRUPT THAT IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SELLING ME- NO
SENATOR HAD APOLOGIZED FOR THE
WHOLE PLAN WAS TO DISRUPT THE
MARKET TO REDUCE THE COST OF
TESTING. ANDMAKE SURE THAT
THERE WAS ADDITIONAL PLAYERS
THAT CAME INTO THE COMMERCIAL
MARKET. IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND TESTING SO WHAT
WE DECIDED TO DO THIS PARTICULAR
ENDEAVOR WE WENT INTO IT WITH
THE IDEA OF THAT. TEST SHOULDN'T
BE COSTING TWO OR THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. I SAID THAT ONLY RICH
INDIVIDUALS CURRENT OR AFFLUENT
INDIVIDUALS CAN GET ACCESS TO IT
BUT THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN COULD
HAVE ACCESS TO TESTING. OKAY I
APOLOGIZE I JUST DIDN'T CATCH
WHAT YOU SAID. BUT IT WAS
DISTRICT THE MARKET SO I GOT
DISTRICT BUT I WASN'T SURE SO
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT.
AND I DO I DO UNDERSTAND THAT-
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING I REALLY DO I JUST THERE
WAS THIS INFORMATION IT CAME
BACK TO US VIA STAFF AND OUR-
CAUCUS STAFF. THAT THERE ARE
SOME SERIOUS PROBLEMS THERE AND
THERE WASN'T A LOT AND BEING
DONE. BUT I DO FOR RESPONSE IN.
NOW I'M NOT SAYING WE'RE TRYING
TO DO YOU DIDN'T DO YOUR JOB
BECAUSE I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
YOU ARE. VERY EFFECTIVE AT WHAT
YOU DO I MEAN IT'S VERY APPARENT
TO ME AS AN EMPLOYER IF I WAS
INTERVIEWING FOR A POSITION.
THAT YOU ARE SOMEONE THAT WOULD
WALK IN HAVE TWENTY ITEMS ON THE
SCHEDULE EVERY DAY TAKE THEM IN
TASK OF EMERGENCY SHOWED UP
EXCITED AND- AND THEY GO RIGHT
BACK TO THE IMMEDIATE TASK AT
HAND. THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT YOU
ARE THAT TYPE OF PERSON. I AM SO
I DO HAVE LIKE I SAID IT
QUESTIONS ON THE LAND SEALAB IN
THEN- I WANTED TO MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTOOD THE DISTRICT THE
MARKET PIECE. AND I APPRECIATE-
THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IS NOW
RESPONDING WITH TESTING. THAT IS
A FOR EVERYBODY THAT EVERYBODY
CAN AFFORD BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE
INCLUDING MYSELF RUNNING AROUND
TRYING TO FIND TESTING IN THE
COST OF TESTING WAS EXPENSIVE.
AND IT DOES MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE AND WE WANT.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
TEST. M. AS WELL. I DO YOU HAVE
A QUESTION AND FOR. THANK YOU
SIR ANSWERING QUESTION. AND
NEXT. POLICE TO REACH OUT TO ME
DIRECTLY NEXT TIME IF YOU FEEL
THAT YOUR STAFF THEN GET WHAT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU WANTED. I KNOW
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO CHAT
WITH YOU ABOUT NURSING HOMES IN
YOUR DISTRICT BEFORE. AND SO IF
THERE IS AN INSTANCE IN THE
FUTURE WHERE YOU FELT LIKE OR
YOUR STAFF LIKE I HAVE NOT
PROVIDED YOU ARE MY TEAM HASN'T
PROVIDED YOU WHAT YOU NEED. YOU
CAN REACH ME BY CELL PHONE AT
ANY POINT IN TIME AND I WILL
MAKE SURE TO. RESPOND TO YOU
DIRECTLY. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
DO. YOU WERE VERY HELPFUL WHEN I
WAS AND DEALING WITH AS THE
NURSING HOME CRISIS IS IN OUR
DISTRICT THAT WORK. AT CODE
RELATED SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND MR MCCARTHY THE QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU IS- I SPENT A LOT
OF TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY NOT SO
MUCH IN THE SENATE BUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY WITH THE DD COMMUNITY
THE IDEA. THAT DEVELIN TO SAVE
THIS ABILITY COMMUNITY. N. M.
SELF DETERMINATION IS THE FUTURE
SELF DELIVERY FOR PERSONS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL. ABILITIES IT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM IS LAGGING
- WHAT CAN DDS EARTH. C. H. S.
C. H. H. ESSAY DUE TO IMPROVE.
AS THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION CENTER YES
I AGREE THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAMS IT'S A REAL SORT OF
PARADIGM SHIFT IN HOW THE D. D.
SYSTEM WORKS. GIVING CONSUMERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES A LOT MORE
DIRECT SAY OVER THE SERVICES
THEY GET AND- REALLY GIVING THEM
THE DECISION MAKING POWER- FOR
THE SERVICES SO. IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT SOMETHING THAT WE
SUPPORT AND WANT TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT- I THINK THE ROLLOUT HAS
BEEN SLOWER THAN WE WOULD LIKE
BECAUSE IT IS A NEW THING FOR.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
IMPLEMENTED AND THEY ARE NOT
ALWAYS COMFORTABLE WITH HOW TO
DO IT. AND I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT ON THE DEPARTMENT AND
US. TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEM
AND ALSO PUSH THEM TO ROLL IT
OUT. ONE THING THAT ISN'T AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT PROGRAM
IS HAVING SOMEONE. WHO CAN DO.
PERFORM THE FINANCIAL WORK FOR
THE CONSUMER THEIR FAMILY AND
THAT. THAT'S NOT AN EASY JOB AND
I THINK WE- PROBABLY NEED TO
FOCUS MORE ON SUPPORTING THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO MAKE SURE
THOSE PEOPLE ARE IN PLACE. FOR
THE CONSUMERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
REALLY ARE COMFORTABLE.
UNDERSTANDING THE CHOICES
THEY'RE MAKING AND HOW THEIR
THEIR SERVICES ARE GOING TO BE
PROVIDED. BUT I AGREE WITH YOU
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT SERVICE
WE WANT TO SUCCEED. I APPRECIATE
THAT COMMENT I WAS ACTUALLY IN
THE ASSEMBLY WHEN THAT BILL WAS
. BEFORE AVENUE. AT THE
COMMITTEE. INDEM YOU KNOW SOME
OF THE COMMENTS IN THERE AT THAT
WERE BASED ON IN THAT COMMITTEE
WHEN I WAS I THE ASSEMBLY LIKE
I SAID IS. IS SEVEN. WAS IT WAS
A LITTLE DISTURBING BECAUSE IT
IT WAS SOMETHING AMENDMENTS
CONTINUE TO HAD TO BE TAKEN SO
THAT WE COULD HAVE SELF
DETERMINATION SO. PARENTS DID
HAVE THE RIGHTS. AND TO MAKE
THOSE DETERMINATIONS FOR THEIR
CHILDREN THAT WERE DEVELOPED
REALLY DISABLED. AND SO I WAS
JUST CURIOUS WHY THERE IS A LAG
TIME ON THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR-
COMMENTS. I REALLY DO THAT- YOU
GUYS ARE WORKING HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM GETS BACK
ON TRACK. AND BECAUSE- WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR PARENTS
HAVE THE RIGHT TO. TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR KIDS
WHETHER IT'S- WHAT DIVERSE TO
BUY WHAT. IF THEY NEED DIAPERS
WHAT- WHAT HEALTH PLAN THEY
THINK IS THE BEST FOR THEM IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER. AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS SO I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH THANK YOU YOU.
BOTH AND- AGAIN MISTER UNDER.
THAT SECRETARY THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE ON THE VALENSI
ELEVEN OFFERING UP TO. YOUR CELL
PHONE TO HELP WITH IF WE HAVE
OTHER ISSUES AND STAFF HAS
COMMENTS ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU
SIR BOTH OF YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK OU SENATOR
GROVE OF MADAM VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU I'D LIKE TO DIRECT MY FIRST
QUESTION TO YOU- MARKLE IF I'M
GOING TO SO I DON'T KNOW IF OF
YOUR LAST NAME BUT I THINK WE
HAD IT THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
PERSON PERSON. A COUPLE YEARS
AGO- AND WE SHARED I SHARED WITH
YOU THAT MY GRANDSON WAS GOING
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF UTAH IN ARE
YOU IN THE DIRECTION THAT YOU
GAVE ME BUT T<c.cyan> HE'S DOING VERY</c>
WELL HE WAS ON THE DEAN'S LIST
YOU KNOW ALL THE TIME BUT HE
DIDN'T DIE TAKE UP MY-
RECOMMENDATION. THAT YOU SHARED
WITH ME TO GO IN AND TALK ABOUT-
YOU KNOW BEING IN THE GOVERNMENT
OF. I MAYBE BECAUSE GRANDMA'S
BEEN. IN GOVERNMENT A LONG TIME
WHO KNOWS BUT- ANYWAY I'M MY
COLLEAGUE- CENTER COM LONGER
ACTUALLY- HOUSE THE QUESTION I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT AND THAT'S
THE- CARE. COURT PROPOSAL. WHICH
IS SET UP TO ACTUALLY ARE
TREATED TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN I HAD AN INTERVIEW WITH THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. CONSORTIUM
FOR THE STATE NOT TOO LONG AGO
AND THEY WERE CONCERNED. ABOUT
WHAT'S GONNA COME THEIR WAY AND
I THINK IT HAS A LOT TO DO WITH.
I DO WE HAVE THE WORKFORCE. I
DEVELOPED THAT'S REALLY GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DELIVER ON THE GOALS
THAT ARE PROMISE THERE. I LOOKED
AT THE BUDGET- THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING IS ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS. OF FOR THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND WHEN I
WENT DOWN THAT LIST MARK
WILLIAMS. I NOTICED THAT THE
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENT TRAINING
PROGRAM. WAS THE- NOT THE LEAST
BIT IT WAS LOW ON THE ON THE-
THING AND IT IS REALLY. THOSE
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
REALLY LACKING. THEY WHEN A
PERSON ARRIVES AND EMERGENCY OF
THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY AND- THE
TRIAGE THERE AND THEY DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE REALLY THEY'RE
SERVING. SO THAT'S GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT- IN THIS PROGRAM.
SO DO YOU WILL YOU HAVE ANY.
OPPORTUNITY THE LETTER TO DO. ON
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL. TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE THERE AFTER YOU DO AN
ASSESSMENT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
PARTICULAR AREA. REALLY NEEDS.
MORE RESOURCES AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. OF FOLKS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHO ARE REALLY GOING TO BE
RUNNING ARC- COUNTY AGENCIES. IN
RECEIVING IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM. IF YOU WILL AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. BETTER FIRST IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU AND I SO TO
HEAR THAT YOU'RE- IS DOING WELL
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF UTAH SO
THAT'S WONDERFUL. I WILL JUST
TELL YOU YOU'RE CORRECT THAT I
THINK THAT WE COULD DO
ABSOLUTELY MORE AND I THINK
WORKFORCE MORE BROADLY. ACROSS
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES BUT
PARTICULARLY IN BABY HAVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT. THAT THAT ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL WAS DESIGNED TO BUILD
ON TOP OF PRIOR INVESTMENTS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
MADE. AND ONE AREA THAT I WILL
POINT YOU TO IS OUR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVES WHERE WE HAVE
SPECIFIC WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS
BEING MADE. TO BUILD UP THE WORK
FORCE AROUND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND SO THERE IS ADDITIONAL
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS.
I BY INCREASING RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS BY CREATING PIPELINES
THAT ARE PROGRAMSTHAT CHECK
TRACKS THAT ARE INTENDED TO
BUILD ON TOP OF EACH OTHER AND
NOT BE DUPLICATIVE SO WHAT WE
TRY TO DO WITH THE ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL.
IS REALLY LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE
EXISTING GAPS THAT WE HAVEN'T
FUNDED NOW THAT IS NOT TO SAY
THAT SOME OF THOSE THINGS THAT
WE FIND AND AREN'T UP AND GOING
I THINK. PART OF IT IS TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE X. RAYED. MAKE
IT. PEOPLE IN CHAIRS AND
PROVIDING IN THE CAN AND SO PART
OF OUR WORK ON CALIFORNIA'S
REALLY WORKING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT ADDITIONAL GAPS
THERE MIGHT BE IN THE SPACE OUR
INTENT WITH THE ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL WAS
REALLY TO LOOK AT WHAT ADICIONAL
GAPS THAT WE HAVE THAT WE DIDN'T
FIND OR DIDN'T HAVE ALREADY IN
THE PIPELINE TO ADDRESS
WORKFORCE IS HANDS DOWN I AM
ISSUE THAT HAS ONLY BEEN-
ESCALATED EVEN MORE- THE
PANDEMIC IT WAS A CUTE PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC IN THE BEHAVIOR
HOUSE BASED. IT IS PERHAPS EVEN
MORE OUT GIVEN THAT ARE UNDER
STRESS ANXIETY OUR FROM THE PAST
TWO YEARS SO I HEAR YOU 1%
SENATOR SOMETHING WE THANK VERY
CLOSE ATTENTION TO AND CONTINUE
TO ENTER AND WORK ON. AS AS WE
CONTINUE THE BUDGET PROCESS
THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR ESPECIALLY
WHEN I SEE A VERY CLOSELY TIED
TO THE OPIOID. YOU KNOW PROP I'M
- GOING TO CRY FOR FIVE BECAUSE
- FRANKLY- WITHOUT FOR KIA
TREATED. HEALTH THREE FOR THOSE
AND SAW IT'S JUST GETTING BACK
SO THE FACT THAT YOU'RE TO INTO
A AND YOU'RE GOING TO THAT. I
HAVE YOU KEEPING ME ON FROM UP
TO THE MINUTE I CERTAINLY CAN
REACH OUT TO YOU BUT IT IS AN
AREA THAT I THINK OF A CRITICAL
IN TERMS OF US REALLY ARE DOING
WHAT WE'RE SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
END HOMELESSNESS AND WE'RE GOING
TO REDUCE ALL WOULD BE GREAT IF
WE COULD REDUCE IT TO ZERO. OUT
OF A LOFTY GOAL OF COURSE BUT
THE- SUBSTANCE ABUSE SUBSTANCE
USE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE AMONG
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. SO WITHOUT TO-
THEY HAD ONE OTHER QUESTION THAT
I DO BELIEVE THAT TOM MY
COLLEAGUE- FINISHER ROBERT WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE- SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM AND ARE
YOU ANSWER THAT VERY WELL IN IN
THE OFFICE SO THAT SAW VERY GOOD
TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE LOOKING TO
BE ABLE TO RAMP THAT. AND IT. IT
FINAL DECREE. BECAUSE DURING THE
- COALBED. THAT IS GOING TO BE A
- WAIT A- OF EFFORT ON THAT PART
. PROGRAM VERY IMPORTANT. THE
WITHOUT THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON. YOUR
NOMINATION HANDOFF IT CERTAINLY
WILL BE SUPPORTING. THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR US SENATOR LAYERED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR. AND
THANK YOU. BOTH FOR YOUR
SERVICES IS FASCINATING FOR ME
BECAUSE I WAS A CABINET
SECRETARY FOR EIGHT YEARS AND I
NEVER HAD TO HAVE A DEPUTY
SECRETARY UNDERSECRETARY BE
SUBJECT TO CONFIRMATION SO I
THINK. I VERY I THINK IT'S A
TRIBUTE TO WHAT A BIG DEAL THEY
ARE SO- YOU JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT AND MAY BE AND NOW THAT
IT'S BEEN MENTIONED BY TWO
PEOPLE. OF MR MCCARTHY MAYBE I'M
GETTING INTO THE WEEDS BUT TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE TO SELF
DETERMINATION ARE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THE LEGISLATURE GAVE
MONEY LAST YEAR. BORN OMBUDSMEN
AND FOR THE RECORD THAT'S A
SWEDISH WORD SO IT'S NOT. AS THE
ONE GUY ON THE COMMITTEE- ON
NOT. BEING ON GENDER NEUTRAL BUT
THE- ON OMBUDSMAN FOR THE
FAMILIES TO ACTUALLY TRY TO
NAVIGATE THE PROCESS AND I JUST
DIDN'T KNOW OFFICIALS TOO IN THE
WEEDS TO KNOW. WHETHER THAT'D
BEEN IMPLEMENTED TO WHETHER
THERE'S ANY FIRST RESULTS FROM
THAT OF. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER THAT THE TRUTH
IS I HONESTLY DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE A CREW THAT- WAS ONE PERSON
BUT I WILL FIND OUT AND I'LL GET
THAT INFORMATION TO YOU. THAT'S
VERY MUCH AND THEN. WHEN THE
DISCUSSION WENT A LITTLE BIT OF
HOMELESSNESS AND- LET ME START
WITH THE UNDERSECRETARY AND SEE
IF THE DEPUTY SECRETARY WANTS TO
CHIME IN. I'M CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR
PERSPECTIVE OF HAVING TO ADDRESS
STATEWIDE PROBLEMS FROM
SACRAMENTO WHERE IT IS REALLY
DIFFERENT AND TO. TAKE A LEAF
OUT OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD'S OF BOOK WHAT ME
ASK A DISTRICT RELATED QUESTION
AND THAT IS THAT. YOUR WE SOME
CITIES IN MY DISTRICT WITH
HOMELESS POPULATIONS. THE ON A
PER CAPITA. SORT OF DOLES OUT.
MONEY ON A PER CAPITA BASIS OF
SOME OF THE CITIES THAT HAVE AN
OVERWHELMING IMPACT CAN'T GET IN
FRONT OF THE ISSUE. IT ONE YEAR
IN SACRAMENTO AND YOU'RE LOOKING
AT TRYING TO ADDRESS THINGS TO
YOU. DOES THAT COME ACROSS TO
YOU IS THAT SOMETHING YOU TRY TO
COMPENSATE FOR HOW YOU'D
MINISTER THE PROGRAMS. SENATOR
THANKS FOR THAT QUESTION
FUNDAMENTALLY I THINK ONE
PRINCIPLE THAT I OFTEN TELL OUR
TEAM IS THAT. WE REALLY HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT OUR POLICY IDEAS IN
THEORY BUT THEN WE NEED TO
REALLY TEST THEM AND UNDERSTAND
THEM IN PRACTICE AND WHAT DO I
MEAN BY THAT. IT MEANS THAT WE
NEED TO GET INTO THE GROUND AND
YOUR STAND WHAT ARE STAKEHOLDERS
AND PARTNERS REALLY THINK ABOUT
IT BECAUSE IN SACRAMENTO HERE WE
MIGHT HAVE THIS NOVEL IDEA
AROUND X. Y. NZ BUT THEN WE GET
ON THE GROUND AND WE REALIZED.
WELL THAT REALLY IN PRACTICE
DOESN'T WORK AND SO I THINK WHAT
WE'VE TRIED TO DO OR WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SHOW BY EXAMPLE IS
REALLY HOW DO WE GET INTO THE
COMMUNITY TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND ONE BEAUTIFUL
THING ABOUT THE STATE IS THAT WE
ARE BIG AND DIVERSE AND SO PART
OF IT IS THAT EACH LOCALITY IS
GONNA HAVE DIFFERENT CHALLENGES
AND ONE THING THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO STRIVE FOR IS HOW DO YOU GIVE
PEOPLE FLEXIBILITY WHILE STILL
AT THE SAME TIME. MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE HOLDING PEOPLE LOOK
PAUL AND THAT WE'RE BEING
TRANSPARENT ABOUT PROCESS FEEDS
ON THAT PARTICULAR TOPIC AROUND
HOMELESSNESS THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING
ADMINISTERED BY OUR COLLEAGUES
AT THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES IN HOUSING AGENCY WHERE
WE COME INTO PLAY HOW DO WE
THINK ABOUT. OUR HEALTH BEING
PART OF HOUSING HOW DO WE THINK
ABOUT WRAPPING AROUND THE SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND THE HEALTH
PROGRAMS IN A HOLISTIC WAY SO
THAT WHEN YOU HOW SOMEONE THAT
YOU HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES SO THAT THEY CAN STATE
HOUSE OR IF THEY'RE ON THE BRINK
OF BECOMING HOMELESS SAYS. THAT
WE REALLY HAVE TO SERVE. I'M
THEM SO THAT. I'M HOME. AND SO I
THINK FOR SERVICE ME. I TO YOUR
YOUR DIRECT QUESTION IT'S ALL A-
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT OUR POLICIES AND OUR
IDEAS IN SACRAMENTO. I'D GET
TRANSLATED INTO PRACTICE IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY AND I THINK PART
OF THAT IS. BEING WILLING TO
TAKE REST AND PART OF THAT IS
BEING WILLING TO ITERATE
CONSTANTLY. IT'S OKAY IF
SOMETHING DOESN'T GO AS WE
PLANNED BUT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO BE NIMBLE ENOUGH TO ARE JUST.
SO THAT WE CAN CORRECT AND
ADDRESS THAT CHALLENGE OR THAT
ISSUE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION DOES WHAT I THINK IT IN
THE INTEREST OF HAVING A
CONVERSATION. A. R. WOULD JUST
SORT OF SAY ON THE GROUND. THE
MARKET IN THE TOWN WHERE I USED
TO BE MAYOR YEARS AGO AND THEY
HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
POPULATION COMPARED TO THE URBAN
AREAS. THE LARGEST PROGRAM YES
THEY DO. OVERNIGHT SHELTER THEY
DO FAMILY SHELTER THEIR SHOWERS
THE AND THEY HAVE ALL THESE
THINGS BUT THEY ALSO HAVE. AN
OUTPATIENT CLINIC THAT PEOPLE
CAN ACCESS EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT
THERE. THEY HAVE BEDS FOR PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF THE HOSPITAL. SO
THAT THEY CAN HAVE A REHAB PLACE
AND NOT GOING TO THE STREET
AFTER BEING RELEASED FROM THE
HOSPITAL. THEY EVEN FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME HAD LOCKED. A
LOCKED FACILITY FOR THINGS THAT
WERE RELATED THERE. THEY HAD
ALCOHOL AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT. ALL THOSE THINGS
MIGHT FALL WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF
YOUR DEPARTMENT EVEN THOUGH. THE
SUBJECT OF HOUSING IS OVER AND-
OF THE BUSINESS AGENCY HOW DO
YOU ACTUALLY COORDINATE FOR
THOSE HOLISTIC WRAPAROUND
SERVICES SINCE YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR SOME OF THE
FUNDING STREAMS THAT MIGHT TIED
TO THOSE THINGS. THAT FIT IN
THAT LARGER CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES. BUT I THINK THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION AND I THINK
I'M GREAT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I THINK.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I THINK WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE BUILD
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES BASED ON
THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE NOT BASED
ON. STRUCTURES OF GOVERNMENT
THAT DOESN'T MATTER THAT I THAT
I SERVICE IS BEING DELIVERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OR SOCIAL SERVICES OR-
PARTNER. SERVICE AND ABOUT AND A
MATTER IS. VISUAL FRIEND OF. TOM
AT. A B. ALSO THIS AND WE- A
MATTER. THEM TO ONE AND HAVE US
AROUND THEM TO THE CHALLENGE
HERE TO VERY FOR IN ON WITH YOU.
IS THE WAY FIND IS OUT OF BOTH
THE STATE LEVEL BUT- A THE
FEDERAL. IT'S BAY ON. ARE PIECE
AND WHAT WE TRYING DO AND
DIRECTOR BOSS ALLUDED TO THIS
AROUND OUR WORKAROUND CAL AIMS
SOME OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING AROUND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUUM. AND COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSIONS IS REALLY FIGURING
OUT WAYS IN WHICH WE BLANDON
PARADE DOLLARS IN ORDER FOR US
TO SERVE THE INDIVIDUAL. IN A
MORE HOLISTIC WAY ON THE GROUND
SO. FOR US IT'S LESS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT HAVE SOMEONE HAS
DIABETES OR HIV AND AIDS BUT
REALLY WHAT ARE THEIR NEEDS AND
THEN HOW DO WE WRAP AROUND THEM.
IN A MUCH MORE HOLISTIC WAY AND
THAT IS HARD THAT IS QUARTER
CHANGE BOARD AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE
WE'RE SO ACCUSTOMED. TO DOING
THINGS AND BUCKETS AND WE'RE
ACCUSTOMED TO SAYING LET US
TREAT ACTS AND ARTISTRY WHY
RATHER THAN SAYING- HOW DO WE
LOOK AT YOU AND IN TOTAL AND A
GOOD EXAMPLE HERE IS. YOU CAN
PROVIDE SOMEONE HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE YOU CAN PROVIDE A CHILD
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
THROUGH MEDICAID OR COVERED
CALIFORNIA THEY MAY GO TO A
DOCTOR. THEY MAY GET A
PRESCRIPTION FOR AN ANTIBIOTIC
BUT IF THAT KID DOESN'T HAVE
FOOD ON THE TABLE OR A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD. THAT NOT ANTIBIOTIC
REALLY DOESN'T DO THEM ANY GOOD
AND SO FOR US IT'S ABOUT HOW DO
WE BRIDGE THE GAPS BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES WITHIN OUR
OWN ORGANIZATION. AND THEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY HOW DO WE PUSH
FUNDING DOWN TO THE LOCAL
PARTNERS TO BE MORE HOLISTIC
AROUND THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE IN
ONE BIG COMPONENT OF THAT IS OUR
WORK. PLAN WHICH DIRECTOR BASS
REALLY TALKED ABOUT IN GREAT
DEPTH. IN IT AND SINCE WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION IT
CALLS TO MIND- I RAN AN AIDS
SERVICE AGENCY AT THE HEIGHT OF
THE EPIDEMIC. AND I REMEMBER ONE
APPLICATION FOR HOUSING WHERE
ONE TO THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR GRANT. AND. THERE WAS AN
INCH. OF TYRAEL STATE I HAD FILE
THAT WERE ON. BE ARC. IN THAT IS
WHAT I HEAR FROM THE NONPROFIT
ACROSS MY DISTRICT ON A WHOLE
HOST OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THANKS THAT. THAT IT
REALLY IMPLIES. THE CAPACITY. IN
WHEN I WAS AT RESOURCES WE WOULD
HAVE THIS ON LAND CONSERVATION
AND SO WE WOULD DO A THING.
WHERE WE WOULD EXPECT A ONE PAGE
LETTER OF INTENT AND THEN JUDGE.
WHETHER THERE WAS A REAL
APPLICATION HERE AND THEN TRY TO
WORK WITH THEM ON THE CAPACITY
TO GET IT DONE SO THEY WEREN'T
INITIALLY SCREENED OUT. BY THE
BASIS OF THEIR CAPACITY. DO YOU
KEEP THAT IN MIND WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING ACROSS THE STATE WITH
MAYBE SMALLER ENTITIES THAT.
THAT ENGAGE WITH YOUR AGENCY.
SENATOR YOU COULDN'T OF SAID I
COULDN'T HAVE SAID IT BETTER I
THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON AND I THINK
PART OF OUR WORK NEEDS TO BEAND
IT CONTINUES TO BE. HOW DO WE
KIND OF CREATE ARE THE ABILITY
FOR US NOT TO HAVE THE OVERLY
CUMBERSOME PROCESS FEES FOR
NONPROFIT PARTNERS AND OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ARE DOING BUSINESS
WITH PASSED. TO BE ABLE TO
ENGAGE WITH US AND I THINK TOO
OFTEN WE SCREEN OUT FOLKS OR WE
DON'T OUT WE LOOK AT PEOPLE
BASED ON EXPERIENCE BUT NOT ON
APTITUDES ARE CHARACTERISTICS
THAT WILL MAKE THEM SUCCESSFUL
IN PARTICULAR. OUT ROLE OR
RESPONSIBILITY AND SO I WHAT YOU
JUST SAID IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO ACROSS ALL TWELVE
DEPARTMENTS AND FIVE OFFICES
WITHIN THE AGENCY. REALLY TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE DELIVER
BETTER GOVERNMENT SERVICES IN
REAL TIME AND THEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE CAN ADJUST ACT
ROCK MORE RAP. H. R. IN ORDER
FOR US TO ADAPT BUT I THINK WHAT
ENDS UP HAPPENING TOO OFTEN IS
THAT WE'RE SO RISK AVERSE. ADD
THAT IN IT REALLY STIFLES OUR
ABILITY TO INNOVATE AND THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX AND WHAT I'M
TRYING TO PUSH THE TEAM ON. IS
REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE
REALLY ENGAGE PEOPLE FASTER
QUICKER. AND LEARN IN REAL TIME
I JUST LIKE WE DID WITH THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC I MEAN
IF ANYTHING WE LEARNED FROM THIS
IS THAT COVERED HAS BEEN SUCH A
GREAT EXCELLENT FOR CHANGING. MY
BISECTOR GALLEY SAYS I TOOK ALL
THE TIME I THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE OUR CALL
THAT EXPERIENCE AND APPLY IT IN
ALL AREAS OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. K. I. A- I COULD KEEP
GOING ON THIS BUT THIS IS BEEN
REALLY HELPFUL NO NO WE HAVE. A
PEOPLE N THE LINE. FOR SERVICE
SERVER SUPPORTING YOU BUT
MOREOVER I WOULD FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON EXACTLY SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AS WE GO. WE WOULD
LOVE THAT SENATOR- THANK YOU-
CENTER LAYERED- JUST A QUICK.
UPDATE I'M GONNA GO BACK TO OUR
VICE CHAIR WHO MEANT TO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR- FOR- MR MCCARTHY.
AND THEN I HAVE A ONE QUESTION
BUT THEN I'M GOING TO TAKE A
BREAK BEFORE WE GO SPEAKERS. I
AM- OF A CORPORATE. WHO ARE IN
THE DEATH OF THIS DISCUSSION
WITH THESE TWO APPOINTEES AND-
DIRECTOR OF VICE. WE'VE GONE ON
FOR QUITE A WHILE AND SO I AM
GOING O TAKE A BREAK BEFORE WE
GO TO SPEAKERS. ARE AFTER WE
CONCLUDE HERE IN JUST A COUPLE
MOMENTS SO I WANTED PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE LAY OF THE LAND.
MANBIJ STEER VERY QUICKLY MR
MCCARTY I DID NOT MEAN TO. OF
PASS YOU BY BECAUSE I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND- MY QUESTION IS
VERY QUICK AND IT MIGHT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ASKED BECAUSE I
MISSED THE FIRST PART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS ON. ON THE WHOLE
CARE ON AGENCY APPOINTMENTS BUT
IT'S THE HOSPICE CARE FRAUD. IN
THE STATEAUDIT. AND ARE
WONDERING IF YOU HAVE FOUR OF
THERE ARE ANY IMMEDIATE ACTIONS
THE AGENCY IS TAKING OFF. WORK
TO HELP THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. TO STOP THE FRAUD SUCH
AS I HEARD THERE MIGHT BE A
MORATORIUM ON NEW HOSPICE
PROVIDERS- SO THEY CAN REALLY
DIG DEEPER INTO. WHETHER THERE'S
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
IN POVERTY. SOME OF THE PROBLEM
. LEGAL IF ACTIVITIES AROUND THE
- AND IT. QUICK YES OR NO
THAT'S- WE A LITTLE OF INTEL.
SURE YEAH TO ANSWER THANK YOU
THE QUESTION CENTER IS A REALLY
IN. ISSUE BECAUSE PEOPLE IN
HOSPICE AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
SO VULNERABLE AND SO IF THERE
ARE ENTITIES OUT THERE THAT ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THOSE PEOPLE
FAMILIES IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO STOP SO YOU ARE CORRECT
THERE IS A MORATORIUM IN PLACE
THAT WAS PART OF A LEGISLATION
PASSED BY SENATOR ALLEN- THERE'S
A ONE YEAR MORATORIUM IN PLACE
ON LICENSES- TO ALLOW OUR
DEPARTMENTS TO GET A HOLD OF
THIS ISSUE AND IT CUTS ACROSS
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS SO.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
LICENSES THE PROVIDERS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS THAT METCALF- WORK
OUR DEPARTMENTS WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WHEN THERE IS FRAUD- PART
APARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES ALSO
FALL BECAUSE THEY- PROVIDE
SERVICES TO FOLKS IN HOSPICE SO.
WE ARE TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY
THERE ARE SOME ACTIONS THAT ARE
DEPARTMENTS CAN TAKE AND ARE
TAKING NOW. TO BETTER PARTNER
AND TO ADDRESS THE FRAUD WORKING
TOGETHER BEEFING UP THEIR
SYSTEMS TRAINING THEIR WORKERS
AND ALSO WITH. THE PROCESSES FOR
REVIEWING FOR REFERRING FRAUD
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I'M-
BERMAN OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
REVIEWING THE REGULATIONS AND
WORKING ON UPDATES. IT IS
IMPORTANT ALTHOUGH THE OTTERS
EXCELLENT REPORT HAD A LOT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS MANY OF WHICH
WERE ACTUALLY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE THEY REQUIRE
STATUTORY CHANGES. TO THE LAWS
SURROUNDING HOSPICE LICENSURE
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE ARE
VERY EAGER TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY CHANGES. TO PROTECT
THIS VERY VOCAL POPULATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- AND THAT'S
VERY GOOD TO HEAR SO. AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS AND I WILL
CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING ON. YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WELL THANK YOU I THANK YOU
BOTH I B. R. ONLY HAVE ONE.
QUESTION AND CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE I THINK MY- MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE CERTAINLY. ARE
GONE INTO GREAT DETAIL AND OF
COURSE BECAUSE- MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL AND YOU
COVER. REALLY IMPORTANT ROLES-
THE QUESTION AND IT WAS ASKED
RELATED TO ANOTHER PROGRAM BUT
BECAUSE OF YOUR ROLES IN THE
BREATH OF WHITE- THE OVERALL
DEPARTMENT DOES- AS IT RELATES
TO THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING AND
WE VERY RECENTLY DID ANOTHER
APPOINTMENT. ARE RELATED TO- TO
THAT ISSUE AND AN OVERSIGHT OF-
AGING ARM. YOU KNOW. IT'S
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE M. BOTH OF YOU WERE
ENGAGED IN THAT HAVE FROM
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES WHEN WE
LOOK AT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
SPENT. OF FUNDING- RELATED TO
THE PANDEMIC TO DEAL WITH SOME
ISSUES- AROUND- ISOLATION R. AS
WELL AS RELIANCE ON HOME
DELIVERED SERVICES DURING A
PANDEMIC. A LOT OF ONE TIME
FUNDING AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
BE SHIFTING- IN A DIFFERENT WAY
AND CERTAINLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE FIVE BOLD GOALS IN THE
TWENTY THREE STRATEGIES. AND BY
TWENTY THIRTY FOUR FIVE
CALIFORNIA OF ALL AGES. HOW ARE
WE GOING TO KIND OF BUILD ON
THAT PROGRAM AND THEN TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE AGENCIES THAT YOU'D
EVEN HAVE DIRECTION OVER. THAT
WILL BE AT TEN DOESN'T UNDER
SECRETARY I WILL ASK IF YOU WANT
TO COMMENT FIRST AND THEN I'LL
GO ABSOLUTELY THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY AFTER YOU. I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU ASKING THIS
QUESTION I APPRECIATE YOU IN
YOUR OFFICE ALSO BEING PART OF A
ROUND TABLE DISCUSSION IN SAN
DIEGO I WHEN WE WERE BUILDING
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING I
THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON IN THE
SENSE. THIS REALLY IS A WHOLE OF
SIX EIGHTY AND IT'S A WHOLE OF
AGENCY PLAN AND YOU GOT TO THIS
WITNESS OUR NEW DIRECTOR
DIRECTOR SUSAN TO MORRIS I WHO
CAME BEFORE YOU LAST WEEK WAS
LEADING THAT'S- HER JOB TO BE
AT. THE TABLE BECAUSE AGING IS
NOT AN ISSUE THAT IS JUST FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF BEIJING IT IS
A CONVERSATION AROUND CALTRAIN
IT'S A CONVERSATION AROUND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IT'S A
CONVERSATION AROUND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES SO. OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE AT EVERY TABLE
THE ONE UNDER SAYING THAT THE
MASTER PLAN RAGING AS WE MADE
THIS COMMITMENT THAT WE WOULD
NOT CREATE A PLAN THAT. THAT CAL
BACKED. AND A APRIL. WE HAVE OUT
IS OUR PERMIT ALSO HAS CALVET.
ACTS DEPARTMENT TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE I WITH THREE TO THE FIVE.
PERCENT YOU ALLUDED TO AND I'M
HAVEN'T DONE. TO HOLD THE SIX.
TO ME SURE THAT WE'RE TRACK TO
THE GO. THAT WE FIGHT IN THE
MASS PLAN. FOR AGING FINAL YOU
WILL LOSE TO THE- THAT THERE'S
LOTS MORE. JUST OUR OWN AGE. AND
IF I THIS AFTERNOON SECOND
GALLEY WILL BE CAN. A CABINET
WORK GROUPS AROUND. ALL THE
OTHER SECRETARIES WHETHER IT'S
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY
TRANSPORTATION BUSINESS TO
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING TO
REALLY TALK ABOUT HOW WE FURTHER
INTEGRATE SOME OF THOSE PIECES
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE PART
OF MOVE. IN THAT NEEDLE THE
PARTICULAR MATCH THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED SO WHAT I WILL SAY TO
THIS IS THAT THIS IS NOT A LAME
DUCK. LAN IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
ACTIVELY. OUT USING THERE'S A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY INITIATIVE
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN LAUNCHED
ARE IS A DATA DASHBOARD
THAT IS REALLY HELPING US MOVE
THE NEEDLE. AND THEN THERE'S
LOCAL PLAY BOOKS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED AS A RESULT TO
GALVANIZE LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
DO THE SAME THING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPUTY SECRETARY
MCCARTY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SO I WE JUST HAD ALL
ALL ON THIS ISSUE MAYBE DRILL
DOWN A LITTLE AND- YOU KNOW ONE
AREA THAT IS OF SUCH A
PARTICULAR CONCERN IS ARE.
HOMELESS AGING POPULATION SO
MUCH OF THE STATE THE FASTEST
GROWING PART OF OUR ALMOST
POPULATION OUR- OUR AGING
POPULATION. AND SO DIRECTOR
TOMAR SUSPEND SO GOOD AT
REACHING OUT AND PARTNERING WITH
OTHER DEPARTMENTS WITHIN CAL HHS
AND OUTSIDE OF OUR AGENCY. TO
BRING THE PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT
OUR AGING POPULATION NEEDS AND
HOW WE SING SPACE SO. PARTNERING
WITH H. CD TO TALK ABOUT- S. S.
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS AND HOW
THOSE CAN BE. DEVELOPED IN AND
THOUGHT ABOUT IN AN AGING
FRIENDLY WAY I'M TALKING ABOUT-
SOME OF OUR OUR COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND HOW THAT CAN MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE AGING. WISHES SO
IT'S IMPORTANT. DEPARTMENT AGING
IS NOT A LARGE APARTMENT BUT
THEY CAN LEVERAGE THEIR REAL
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA BY
WORKING WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS
AND DIRECTOR TOMAR SAYS JUST
DONE A TERRIFIC JOB. THANK YOU I
ARE APPRECIATE THAT I THINK- AND
MAYBE YOU'LL CARRY A MESSAGE
BACK TO- I MISS BASS- BECAUSE I
THINK I GOT STUCK ON ONE
QUESTION ABOUT WHERE'S THE
HOUSING. BUT I THINK THE BIGGER
THE BIGGER ISSUE WHAT I'M
HEARING WHETHER WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT- ISSUES RELATED TO AGING
POWER CHORD CAL AIMED THE
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS THE CHILD HEALTH
INITIATIVE- YOU KNOW I HAVE
BEGUN TO HEAR LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT BLUEPRINTS
MASTER PLAN STRATEGIES GOALS AND
THAT'S THE WORK YOU DO THAT'S
THE DEEP DIVE THAT EACH
DEPARTMENT DOES. I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT INTEGRATION IS I KNOW
THAT WE DON'T LIKE SILOS BUT
THEN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CROSS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WITH
SPECIFIC. MANDATES WE ALL GET
NERVOUS WE WANT YOU TO DO IT BUT
WE GET NERVOUS BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T CROSS SILOS VERY WELL- AND
SO OF COURSE I WANT EVERY
SUCCESS WHEN I HEAR HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE INTO THE
SYSTEM INTEGRATE ALL OF THE
SERVICES THEY NEED WHETHER IT'S
BASIC HEALTHCARE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- DO WE HAVE THE- AT WORK
FORCE ISSUES PEOPLE WHO NEED
JOBS. BUT THEN THE WORKFORCE
ISSUES OF THOSE THAT NEED TO DO
THE JOB I GET A LITTLE NERVOUS
BECAUSE I JUST WORRY ABOUT HOW
WE CONNECT ALL THE DOTS BUT I
WILL GO BACK TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUE SAID OF WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE WE HAVE AD.
QUITE A NUMBER OF INCREDIBLE
PUBLIC SERVANTS BEFORE US
EXPLAINING. THE PROGRAMS HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO INTEGRATE HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO BREAK DOWN THE
SILOS AND WE ADD TO SENATOR COM
LONGER. WE'RE REALLY COUNTING ON
YOU TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS
BECAUSE ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
SO IMPORTANT AND EVERYTHING IS
INTERCONNECTED INTO IN TERMS OF
THE PROBLEMS. THAT WE SEE THAT
THE PUBLIC EXPECTS US TO TOUCH.
FROM THAT FORGET THE INTERAGENCY
COUNCIL HOMELESS LET ME THROW
THAT WHEN AND IF I THOUGHT I
SAID IT I WROTE IT DOWN. BUT I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU AND
MAYBE YOU'LL CARRY MY MESSAGE TO
MISS BOSS IN TERMS OF MAYBE IN
FOCUSED ON ONE QUESTION WHEN.
REALLY IT'S THE FIFTY THOUSAND
FOOT- OVERVIEW OF HOW ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE GONNA WORK
TOGETHER THAT WERE COUNTING ON
AN- YOU KNOW MR MAJOR REMEMBER
YOU FROM. BEFORE WHEN YOU SORT
OF BLEW US AWAY WITH YOUR
KNOWLEDGE. ON THE PREVIOUS
APPOINTMENT AND OF COURSE I'VE
WORKED OUT WITH MISTER MCCARTY
BEFORE THROUGH THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
REMEMBER- HIS CREATIVE IDEAS AND
SOLUTIONS FOR PIECES OF
LEGISLATION SO. I THINK WE'RE
WELL SERVED AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE BOTH INCREDIBLY BUSY BUT
BEFORE WE GO TO- WHO ONE WHO
CLEARLY WANT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF YOUR APPOINTMENTS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE OUR COURT
REPORTER A BREAK BECAUSE SHE IS
VERY HARD WORKING AND SHE IS NOW
DESERVED THIS FIVE MINUTES SO A
FIVE MINUTE BREAK AND I PROMISE
YOU WILL BE BACK AND TAKE YOUR
BUSINESS. SO WERE FIVE MINUTE
BREAK OF THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. IS. I
I WILL LIE ASK OUR COURT
REPORTER TO GIVE ME A YEAH
YOU'RE A OKAY THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR THANK YOU I HOPE YOU
GOT A LITTLE BIT OF A BREAK-
OKAY I'M GONNA CALL- THE MEETING
BACK TO ORDER AND WE WILL START
WITH PEOPLE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. AND WE'RE GONNA
START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET ME ASK YOU. AGAIN TO
SPACE YOURSELF COME FORWARD-
NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT AND-
BRIEF COMMENTS WELCOME WELCOME
BACK I SHOULD SAY. VERY LITTLE.
YEAH SHE CAN'T HANG ON A SEC I
DON'T THINK THE VOLUME LET ME
JUST ASK FOR ASSISTANCE HERE
BECAUSE THE RECORD REPORTER
CANNOT HEAR. TRY ONE MORE TIME
SURE THIRTY KERN IN PERFECT
THANK YOU- NO ONE EVER
COMPLAINED ABOUT NOT HEARING AND
THAT LOUD SO. IT'S A NICE CHANGE
AND NOT INJURED MEMBERS DARBY
KERN AND REPRESENTING THE LOCAL
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
WHICH REPRESENTS THE NONPROFIT
AND HOUSING AND SERVICES FOR OUR
AGING POPULATION. AND BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE TWO DIFFERENT
APPOINTEES- I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THEM SEPARATELY BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO AGREE WITH SENATOR LATER THAT
BOTH APPOINTEES ARE BIG DEALS
AND FIRST FOR AN UNDERSECRETARY-
MARCO MEECH I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HIM
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE OF IT
PANDEMIC. IN VARIOUS DIFFERENT
ROLES AND THE PERSON WE THOUGHT
TODAY IS THE PERSON I'VE SEEN AS
WHETHER IT WAS NINE O'CLOCK AT
NIGHT OR EIGHT IN THE MORNING OR
NOON IT DIDN'T MATTER WHATEVER
MEETING HIS ATTITUDE HIS ENERGY
AND- PERSEVERANCE IN THIS REALLY
DIFFICULT. TIME WAS EVIDENT AND
THERE AND ALWAYS A HUNDRED AND
10% AND FROM THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS PERSPECTIVE I WANT TO SAY
THAT HE MADE SURE THAT WE HAD
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO VACCINATIONS
TESTING AND- TREATMENT AND
REALLY LISTENED HE WOULD TAKE
MEETINGS WITH ALL OF THE
ADVOCATES AND ALL OF. THE
PARTNERS IN DEALING WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND IN REGARDS FOR
LEADING AGED CALIFORNIA WHO
REPRESENTS OUR AGE THE HOUSING
AND SERVICES FOR AGING
POPULATION HE MADE HIMSELF
AVAILABLE CONSTANTLY TALKING
WITH US AND HELPING US AND
KNOWING THAT THE DIFFICULTY OF
MOVING PEOPLE WHEN YOU DON'T
HAVE STAFF. SO I JUST WANT TO
GIVE A HUNDRED AND 10%
RECOMMENDATION FOR HIM AND THE
WORK HE DOES AND- THE STATE IS
VERY LUCKY AND I HAVE FOR AN- AD
DEPUTY SECRETARY AT BRANDON
MCCARTHY HE HAS BEEN A LONG TIME
COLLEAGUE HE HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
WE ARE GOING IN AND EXPANDING
MEDI L. AND WORKING IN AREAS
THAT HE IS LISTENING WORKING
WITH US ON THE FINANCIAL PIECES
GIVING IDEAS AND- TRUE PARTNER
AND SO WE APPRECIATE- THEIR WORK
AND- WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THERE ARE PLENTY APPOINTMENTS
THANK YOU. THE VERY MUCH FIVE
NEXT WITNESS I GUESS I SHOULD
HAVE CLARIFIED YOU CAN. DIRECT
TO YOUR SUPPORTERS TO ONE THE
OTHER OR BOTH AND- GORETTI HEAD
WELCOME BACK JENNIFER SNYDER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITY
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
BOTH- MARCO BEACH AND- BRENDAN
MCCARTHY FOR THEIR APPOINTMENT
AND THEY HAVE GREAT KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERIENCE THEIR BREADTH OF
EXPERIENCE AND HEALTH CARE IS
HUGE INCLUDING LONG TERM CARE SO
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IT WOULDN'T YOU'RE ABLE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THEIR
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON PAULA VS GOES ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ECHOING
PREVIOUS COMMENTS THESE ARE BOTH
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE INDEED A
BIG DEAL I AM GLAD THAT THAT WAS
HIGHLIGHTED AND NOTICED BY- BY
THIS COMMITTEE- I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF COUNTING BOTH OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS AS COLLEAGUES
AND HAVE LEARNED A GREAT DEAL
FROM EACH OF THEM SO IT'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY PLEASURE TO BE
HERE. IN SUPPORT I ALSO WANT TO
KNOW AND- CONSIDER COME UNDER
YOUR HIGHLANDER COMMENTS KIND OF
HIGHLIGHTED OUR ROLE AND
PARTNERSHIP AS COUNTIES IN
IMPLEMENTING PROGRAMS AND WHILE
WE'VE TACKLED QUITE A BIT IN THE
PAST AND HAVE A LOT MORE TO
TACKLE I KNOW THAT IN THESE TWO
INDIVIDUALS WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTATION PARTNERS AND
COLLEAGUES AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING ON- A LOT OF THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE TO DO. TOGETHER I
WANT TO TAKE ONE MOMENT AS WELL
THE SWITCH HATS AND ADDRESS YOU
AT A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER FROM
THE SAN JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THERE WAS SOME COMMENTS
THAT CAME UP REGARDING THE
VALENCIA BRANCH LAB AND I JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE AS
WELL FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK IN
STANDING THAT UP AND WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT. THAT LAB IN
THEIR WORK OF MOVING MOUNTAINS
IS WHAT ALLOWED OUR FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO COME BACK
SAFELY TO SCHOOL AND I KNOW THAT
THAT'S ECHOED AMONG STOP
HUNDREDS OF SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I SEEING KNOWS.
ALL PRESENT IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
I'M GOING TO DO TWO THINGS I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER AGAIN. 844-291-6364 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR ONE WELCOME BACK
OUR MODERATOR TO. START OUR
TELECONFERENCE FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT WOULD ASK TWO THINGS OF
A MODERATOR TO TELL ME HOW MANY
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE
AND TO THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IF
ANY AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR UNDER
SECRETARY MEECH OR DEPUTY
SECRETARY MCCARTHY OR BOTH. AND
JUST THE SUPPORT- AT THIS POINT-
JUST YOUR SUPPORT POSITION AND-
NOT OTHER COMMENTARY THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR ARE YOU BACK
WITH US. I AM FADING GENTLEMEN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT IT IS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AND WE
RECENTLY NOW HAVE EIGHT PEOPLE
IN THE QUEUE. WE WILL START WITH
Y. NUMBER THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON TEA NO REGARD
FOR THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY BOTH NOMINATIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THAT WAS PERFECT- THAT WAS A
GREAT EXAMPLE MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS. WHY NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE CALL HAD. THANK YOU
THERE ARE MITIGATING ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES STRONG SUPPORT FOR MR
BOTH MEN AND DEMOCRATIC. THANK
GOT A SENSE OF THEIR CHARACTER
AND HEART IN CALIFORNIA'S BETTER
OFF WITH THEM THANK YOU THANK.
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
YOU HAVE A LINE OF THIRTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BUT THE ARMSTRONG WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR BOTH NOMINEES THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR
I'M GLAD ON BEHALF OF THE- MORE
AWFUL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
COMBINATION OF BOTH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE
HAVE ROUGHLY FIVE THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX BASEBALL HAS. I DON'T
REMEMBER THERE ARE BLOCKS
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK AND- STRONG WORD.
OF THOSE YET EIGHT. PART AND-
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
IT WILL BE LINE NUMBER THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRANDON
MARSHALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BOTH NOMINATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUNNING PRETTY GOOD
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALVARY
HOSPITAL THE PATIENT EXPRESSING
HER SUPPORT FOR BOTH NOMINATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. MY NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN PEOPLE HAD. AFTERNOON THAT
APPROACH AND THEN MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE THIS IS DAN OPEN
POTS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF BOTH CANDIDATES. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS. YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER FORTY FOUR THE BILL HAS.
THE NEW ENGLAND REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND BECAME QUITE A FEW WEEKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OTHER
WITNESSES WHAT BEGAN IT YOU WHAT
VERY ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IMPORTANT IT IS ONE NINE ZERO.
AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN Q.
SHARE THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT
AND- I TO EACH OF YOU I AM SURE
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN EXTENSIVE
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW WONDERFUL YOU
ARE GIVEN THE NAMES OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
SO- BUT I. SO I JUST WANTED
KNOWLEDGE TYPICALLY WE LET
PEOPLE SPEAK A LITTLE LONGER BUT
WE'VE GONE ON- EXTENSIVELY TODAY
WE HAVE ONE MORE POINTY AND I'M
SURE YOU WANT TO BE CONFIRMED
AND MOVE ON- WITH THAT WE WILL
WE WILL TAKE OFF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION. I
AM IN ROOM ONE TWELVE AND I SEE
NO MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
APPROACHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SO MADAM MODERATOR I
WILL COME BACK TO YOU TO SEE IF
YOU CAN QUEUE UP ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION IT IS A ONE BANK BILL
ON YOUR PHONE. OPPOSITION. ONE
NINE ZERO. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION
AND- THANK YOU SO MUCH I WILL-
THE WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A
FEW MOMENTS I'M SURE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP TODAY. I'M
GOING TO BRING IT BACK INTO ROOM
ONE TWELVE AND WHAT WE WILL DO
JUST FOR CLARITY WE WILL-
SEPARATE THE MOTIONS AND I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM ONE
B. AND THAT WOULD BE UNDER
SECRETARY. MARCO REACH FOR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
UNDER SECRETARY OF MOTION.
SENATOR CALM WATER HAS MADE A
MOTION SO LET ME ASK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL. I
APOLOGIZE I. PLEASE FORGIVE ME
SENATOR BREAUX- SENATOR CALM
WATER MADE A MOTION ON ITEM ONE
B. THE APPOINTMENT OF UNDER
SECRETARY MARCO BEACH TO THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
THAT IS THE MOTION. MADAM
SECRETARY HI HI WATER I WONDER
THERE. EIGHT I R. I.
CONGRATULATIONS FIVE ZERO THAT
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR SENATE FLOOR
FOR FULL CONFIRMATION I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
UNDERONE SEAT MISTER BRANDON
MCCARTHY AS DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
PROGRAMS AND FISCAL AFFAIRS AT
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. SENATOR LAYERED MAKES A
MOTION MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. RIGHT WATER HI
ALL RIGHT THERE. RIGHT RIGHT HI
. THAT IS ALSO FIVE ZERO AND WE
WILL MOVE YOUR CONFIRMATION ON
TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR ABSOLUTELY- OKAY- WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD ACTUALLY MAN
SECRETARY WHILE PEOPLE ARE HERE
YOU'RE GOOD YOU VOTED ON-
EVERYTHING WE HAVE SOME OPEN
ROLE. VOTES ARE ALSO ON ITEM-
LET ME SEE I THINK IT WAS ITEM
TO E. THROUGH G. THOSE ARE THE
APPOINTMENTS TO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE THREE MEMBERS.
OF MADAM SECRETARY WE OPEN THE
ROLE. I. FIVE TO ZERO SO THAT IS
COMPLETE WE HAD OF. OUR MOTION
FOR ITEM THREE THE REFERRAL
BILLS AND FOR FLOORING KNOWLEDGE
MINTS- MAN SECRETARY WE OPEN THE
ROLE. RIGHT. FIVE TWO ZERO THAT
IS COMPLETE SO WE WILL MOVE NOW
TO- THE LAST AREN'T GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE REQUIRED TO APPEAR.
AND THAT WOULD BE FOR THE A
MEMBER OF THE ALFRED P. ALQUIST
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION WE
HAVE MISSED A LOT CRUZ MISS
ALLEGRA AND THEY LOOK RUSE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. ARE TODAY N.
WELCOME YOU. OFFER YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- ACKNOWLEDGE
THANK ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS
AND THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS BATES GROW KAMLAGER AND
BAIRD IT IS MY PLEASURE AND
HONOR TO APPEAR THIS AFTERNOON
TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE. FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CONSIDERED TO
SERVE MY BELOVED STAGE. I AM
PROUD TO BE A THIRD GENERATION
CALIFORNIA AND THE DAUGHTER AND
GRANDDAUGHTER OF MEXICAN CHICANO
FARMWORKERS AND FARMERS ON MY
FATHER'S SIDE. AND SWEDISH AND
NORWEGIAN FARMERS ON MY MOTHER'S
SIDE. MY EXPERIENCES AS A PUBLIC
SERVANT AND AN ADVOCATE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST AS WELL AS MY
EXPERIENCE AND DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY. DURING A CINEMA COUNTY
WILDFIRES OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS FIRST AS A LAWYER FOR THE
COUNTY COUNSEL'S OFFICE AND NOW
AS THE COUNTY'S DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF EQUITY. THERE'S
EXPERIENCE TO PREPARED ME WELL
TO SERVE IN THIS COMBAT CAPACITY
TO RECOMMEND POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS TO REDUCE REDUCE
EARTHQUAKE RISK. AS WELL AS TO
ELEVATE THE VOICES AND NEEDS OF
UNDER REPRESENTED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. I AM SO
HAPPY TO BE HERE WITH THE LOVE
AND SUPPORT. AND LIKE WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY HUSBAND MY
THINGS WHEN YOU GOT AND OUR TWO
CHILDREN. WHO ARE NOW EVEN MORE
WELL VERSED AND EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS AS WELL AS MY
FATHER OVER THE NEXT MOVES MY
MOTHER JAN PETERSON WHO HAS
SINCE PASSED AND- MY FATHER IN
LAW AND MY MOTHER ONLINE MY
BODY- AND I GOT TO TELL US IN
YOUR- HAPPY TO BE HERE TO
ADDRESS. ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT MY INTEREST. AND MY
QUALIFICATIONS TO SERVE AS THE
SOCIAL SERVICES REPRESENTATIVE.
COMMISSIONER ON THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE FOR
THOSE OPENING COMMENTS. OF LET
ME GO FIRST MADAM VICE CHAIR IF
IT'S OKAY IN YOUR PREPARED I CAN
GO TO YOU FIRST AND FOREMOST
THIS ONE HUNDRED FOR. THIS IS
GROSS OKAY A LOT. ABOUT DO YOU
HAVE YES THE MIKE PARKING HIS
YEAH THIS ONE MAKE SURE WE CAN
GO AHEAD SENATOR SO IF YOU DON'T
OKAY. ABSOLUTELY WELL FIRST AND
I KNOW SHE IS NOT CALLED THE WAY
TO. GET THAT IS ALSO VERY GOOD
POINT ARE WE HAVE A CENTER GROVE
WHO IS ALSO ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE SO FORGIVE ME. THAT'S
WHY THE VICE CHAIR IS SO
IMPORTANT. TO KEEP ME ON TRACK-
SENATOR GROWTH AND PRETEND S.
THANK YOU MISS DELLA CREWS FOR
MEETING WITH ME THIS MORNING I'M
SORRY IT WAS A KIND OF ABRUPT
AND SHORTENED JUST HAD DIRECT
QUESTIONS AND- AND I DIDN'T-
ANTICIPATE TO ASK YOU QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD. TODAY BECAUSE
WE HAD DISCUSSED IT THIS MORNING
THIS IS THE VICE- THE VICE CHAIR
BROUGHT IT UP I GUESS WE SHOULD
JUST PUT IT ON THE RECORD. AM I
SHARED WITH YOU THIS MORNING
THAT I HAD A LOT OF CONSTITUENTS
FARMWORKERS MAINLY- THAT REALLY
REACHED OUT I MEAN THERE WERE
OVER SEVENTY FARMWORKERS THAT
REACHED OUT WHEN THEY FOUND OUT
THAT YOU WERE GETTING THIS
APPOINTMENT TO THE SEISMIC.
COMMISSION SAFETY SEISMIC OR SIX
FIVE SIX EIGHT TWO COMMISSION.
AT WHEN WE TALK TODAY AT YOU DID
ASK THE QUESTION OF RELEVANCE
LIKE WHAT'S THE RELEVANCE OF
WHAT HAPPENED AT THE LRB AND THE
GROUND FARMWORKER VOTE AND-
FARMWORKERS BALLOTS BEING HELD
UP FOR. FIVE YEARS AND ALL OF
THAT THAT TOOK PLACE THAT I WAS
VERY VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN
BECAUSE THEY'RE MY CONSTITUENTS
RIGHT THEY WERE THE FARMWORKERS
THAT. THAT I REPRESENT. SO IN
THE SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION
THERE IS NO RELEVANCE BETWEEN
AND THE- AS I EXPRESS TO YOU
BEFORE. IT'S THEIR CONCERN ABOUT
EQUITY JUSTICE AND AN EQUALITY
OF PROVIDE. A BALANCED APPROACH
AND THEY FEEL THAT YOU DID NOT
PROVIDE A BALANCED APPROACH WITH
YOUR ROLE AT THE LRB. AND
THEY'RE CONCERNED THAT AND YOU
KNOW THE SEISMIC SAFETY OVER
PRIVATE PROPERTY OVER HOSPITALS
OVER- YOU KNOW EVERYTHING THAT
THE STATE MANDATES THAT THAT B.
S. THEY WANT TO ENSURE THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A BALANCED
APPROACH WHEN YOU DEAL WITH ALL
SIDES. VERSES WHAT DATE THEY SAW
AND FROM THEIR OWN EYES AND WITH
THEY'VE CONVEYED IN HEARING
AFTER HEARING AFTER HEARING-
WITH YOUR POSITION AT THE LRB.
REGARDING THE PROSECUTION FM
FARMWORKERS AND FARMERS IN THAT
SITUATION SO HOW ABOUT WE JUST
START THERE IF THAT'S OKAY.
ABSOLUTELY IT WAS MY HONOR AND
MY PLEASURE TO SERVE AS A
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEE TO THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD. AS A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR-
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN IN
HIS SECOND TERM AS GOVERNOR HIS
FIRST INCLUDED THE CREATION OF
THE AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD AND- WE WERE DIRECTOR AND
IN THAT CAPACITY AS HIS
APPOINTEES TO. BRING BRING
REALITY IN BRING TRIPS TO THE
PROMISE OF THE LAW AS IT WAS. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. AND IT
WAS IN THAT CAPACITY AS A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AND THEN
LATER AS A REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF
THAT I WAS PROUD TO BRING SOME
OF THE- FIRST TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDERS REINSTATING
WORKERS WHO HAD BEEN FIRED IN
RETALIATION FOR THE UNION.
ORGANIZING AND SOME THIRTY
YEARS. AND NOT EVER THERE WILL
BE AS- BOTH HISTORIC AND STILL
CURRENT ONE OF THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL AREAS- FOR. FOR
STATE ACTION BOTH IN NEUTRAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND THEN ONCE A
DISCRETIONARY DECISION IS MADE
BY THE GENERAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
TO MOVE TOWARDS PROSECUTION. AND
I WILL NOTE THAT IN MY CAPACITY
AS A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AS WELL
AS AS A REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR
THE SALINAS OFFICE- WE
INVESTIGATED AND PROSECUTED-
BOTH SIDES OF THE PROVERBIAL
I'LL BOTH EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS
UNIONS. I'M THIRD ROW IN CASE
WAS HANDLED BY THE
AGRICULTURALLY RELATIONS BOARDS
BY SELLING OFFICE AND IN MY
CAPACITY AS A REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR THE SALINAS OFFICE AND OF
THE LEADERSHIP TEAM. UNDER THAT
UNDER THAT GUIDANCE AND
LEADERSHIP OF OUR GENERAL
COUNSEL SOMETHING ADVISED AGAIN.
I DID PARTICIPATE AND IMPORTANT
STRATEGIC CONVERSATIONS AROUND
THE USE OF OUR DISCRETIONARY
POWER TO MOVE TOWARDS
PROSECUTION GIVEN. OUR FINDINGS
OF. THE FINDINGS OF OUR AND-
WITH REGARD TO CHARGES THAT WERE
FILED. BY THE UNIONS AS WELL AS
BY WORKERS ACT AROUND
INDUSTRIES- IT HAS BEEN SEVEN
LONG YEARS SINCE I'VE SERVED IN
THAT CAPACITY OF THEM CULTURALLY
RELATIONS BOARD- AND THERE HAS
NEVER BEEN A FINDING OF
WRONGDOING OR OF ANY BIAS IN THE
COURSE OF THE GENERAL COUNSEL'S.
INVESTIGATIONS OR PROSECUTIONS
OF THAT CASE SO I RESPECT THE
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE TO COME FORWARD
AND TO EXPRESS THEIR THEIR
CONCERNS- I AM REMINDED OF THE
WORDS OF SUCH CHAVEZ WHO SAYS
THAT WE DON'T NEED PERFECT
POLITICAL SYSTEMS BUT WHAT WE DO
NEED US PERFECT PARTICIPATION.
AND I THINK IT'S A WONDERFUL
EXAMPLE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
PEOPLE AND THE RECOGNITION OF
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW I
HAVE BANNED INSPIRED- TO
CONTINUE. ACTIVATING THOSE
RIGHTS AND MOVING TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR OWN FORCING REPRESENTED.
AT EVERY OPPORTUNITY- BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO I'M
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS SENATOR WITH
REGARD TO THIS CASE- I WOULD
NOTE THAT I WAS NOT. THE
PROSECUTOR ON THE GROUND CASE AS
THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR AND
SALINAS OFFICE- AND AGAIN JUST
STATE ONCE MORE FOR THE RECORD
THAT THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A
FINDING OF WRONGDOING OR BIAS.
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M LOOKING
AT THE DOCUMENTS THAT YOU
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES YOU HIGHLIGHT YOUR WORK
I'M SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHLIGHT YOUR
WORK IN PROMOTING ADVOCACY.
THROUGH LITIGATION. AT THE COW.
RULE LEGAL ASSISTANCE LEAVE C.
EIGHT C. R. L. A. AND M. CENTER
EVERY SENSE- ON A CENTER RACE
AND POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SEVERAL OTHER GROUPS IN THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD. AND YOU HIGHLIGHT THAT
AS- AS ADVOCACY THROUGH
LITIGATION SO I TAKE THAT AND IF
I'M WRONG PLEASE CORRECT ME.
THAT YOU ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THOSE PEOPLE BY FILING LAWSUITS
AGAINST THEM AGAINST OR FOR.
INDIVIDUALS IS HOW I TOOK THAT
M. IS THIS THE APPROACH THAT YOU
THINK THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION SHOULD BE TAKING AND
IS OR IS THAT YOUR INTENT TO
BRING THAT TO. THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. THE COMMISSION
. THANK YOU IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION- MY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCES HAVE PROVIDED ME
WITH THE FAMILIARITY AND A
COMFORT WITH MULTIPLE SKILL SETS
WITH REGARDS TO ADVOCACY IN
PUBLIC SERVICE I'M SO I HAVE
EXPERIENCE REPRESENTING
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
AGAINST PUBLIC AGENCIES AS WELL
AS EXPERIENCE WORKING IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
NORMA AND IT'S THIS UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THAT YOU KNOW THOSE AGAIN THE
PROVERBIAL I'LL THAT I BELIEVE
REALLY BRINGS AN IMPORTANT
PERSPECTIVE TO THE WAYS IN WHICH
I COULD ADVISE THE STATE. AROUND
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE IN
FACT AVOIDING LITIGATION AGAINST
THE STATE FOR FAILURES TO
PROVIDE FOR EXAMPLE LANGUAGE
ACCESS AFTER A DISASTER OR
EQUITABLE RECOVERY
OPPORTUNITIES- AFTER DISASTER-
AND IT IS THAT PERSPECTIVE AS AN
ADVOCATE IN THOSE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS PRIOR TO MY
EXPERIENCE BECOMING A PUBLIC
SERVICE PUBLIC SERVANT AND
MOVING INTO PUBLIC SERVICE THAT
I FEEL PROVIDES AGAIN NOT THAT
DEEP FAMILIARITY WITH THE TOOLS
THAT ADVOCATES USE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING ACCESS TO
THOSE TOOLS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW. ARE
MADE REAL BY ADVOCATES AND BY
ADVOCACY- AT AT AT THE SAME TIME
HAVING THAT EXPERIENCE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE AND AS A PUBLIC SERVANT
I THINK HELPS ME TO ENSURE THAT
I AM WORKING TO AVOID- EVER
NEEDING TO GET TO A PLACE WHERE
WE ARE HAVING TO LITIGATE- IN
ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS ARE RESPECTED AND
PROTECTED. I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I KNOW WE A DIFFERENT OF OPINION
ON THIS IS BECAUSE I KNOW. OF
TAXPAYER WERE USED IN THIS FIVE
YEAR LONG BATTLE ADDED THESE
FARMWORKERS JUST. PERSISTENTLY
FOUGHT FOR AND I KNOW WITH THEM
VOTE WAS FINALLY COUNTED IT WAS-
FIVE TO ONE I MEAN IT WAS FIVE
FOR EVERY FIVE. VOTES AGAINST
WHAT WAS BEING FORCED UPON THEM
THERE WAS ONE VOTE IN SUPPORT.
SO CURRENTLY THE COMMISSION- THE
COMMISSION'S ROLE FOR THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION. IS A
ROLL IT'S ADVISORY IS THAT
CORRECT IT IS ADVISORY YOU FEEL
THAT THE SIZING SEISMIC SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION SHOULD HAVE A
LARGER ROLE IN ENFORCEMENT AND
LITIGATION EARTHQUAKE BUILDING.
AND CODES OR I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIND OUT WHAT OUT WHAT YOUR
INTENT IS BASED ON THE
BACKGROUND AND KNOWLEDGE THAT I
HAVE ABOUT AND YOUR
PAPERWORK THAT YOU FILLED OUT
WITH THE RULES COMMITTEE ABOUT-
YOU KNOW TAKING A STANCE. FORD
YOU KNOW ACTIVISM THROUGH
THROUGH LITIGATION A
REPRESENTATION TO THE LOCATION
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT TO DO WHEN
YOU GET TO THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY
THE ROLE OF THE COMMISSION NOR
IS IT ONE THAT I UNDERSTAND THE
COMMISSION IS INTERESTING ON
TAKING NOR IS IT ONE THAT I
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
COMMISSION TAKE. I WOULD SAY
THAT I THINK IT IS A POWERFUL
STAFF THAT THE STATE HAS TAKEN
TO BRING THE COMMISSION. UNDER
CAL- YES AT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES BECAUSE
WITHOUT. YOUR SUPPORT AND NOT
CENTERING OF EARTHQUAKES WITHIN
OUR LARGER. ENVIRONMENT LARGER
EMERGENCY RESPONSE BODY I THINK
THAT WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO IS
BRING THE FULL RANGE OF STATE
RESOURCES TO BEAR- BOTH. IN
PREPARATION FOR AND MITIGATION
OF A POSSIBLE EARTHQUAKE EVENTS
BUT ALSO TO ENSURE THAT- THE
FULL RANGE OF STATE
OPPORTUNITIES IN OPTIONS ARE
AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING. IMPORTANT LABOR
PROTECTIONS THAT CURRENT FLOW
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS THE OFFICE
OF CAL STAR ARE ALSO. BROUGHT TO
BEAR IN THOSE EFFORTS. IT HAS
BEEN MY EXPERIENCE OF THE COUNTY
AND MULTIPLE DISASTERS. AND IT
IS WELL SUPPORTED BY DATA THAT
IS NOW COMING OUT NATIONALLY IN
THIS DISASTER STRICKEN
COMMUNITIES. THAT THERE ARE
SPECIFIC WINNERS AND LOSERS AND
DURING A DISASTER AND THE DATA
IS SHOWING THAT. THE MORE MONEY
THE MORE FEDERAL MONEY IN
PARTICULAR THAT FLOWS INTO A
COMMUNITY- ACTUALLY AN INVERSE.
IMPACT ON DEEPENING AND
EXACERBATING RACE AND ETHNICITY
AND RACIAL INEQUITIES SEVEN
EQUITIES AROUND RACE AND
ETHNICITY. SO IT I BRING. TO
THIS TO THIS EFFORT INSIDE OF
THE COMMISSION A PERSPECTIVE AND
THE RECOGNITION THAT THERE ARE
MANY POPULATIONS WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FARMERS
BEING ONE OF THEM. THAT ARE
STRUCTURES IN OUR SYSTEMS HAVE
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
SEE. SIR I PROVISIONS WHETHER
IT'S THE- PHONE ABILITY WITH
EXPERIENCE INSIDE OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND OUR SYSTEMS AS
A RESULT IN THEIR LANGUAGE.
SHARE THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS-
THIS COMMUNITY I THINK ALLOWS ME
TO ENSURE THAT. BANDOW'S
EXPERIENCES NOT PERSPECTIVE ARE
ARE SHARED BY THE MULTIPLICITY
OF STATE AGENCIES THAT ACTUALLY
DO YOU HAVE THAT JURISDICTION
AND NOT AUTHORITY OVER ENSURING
WORKER PROTECTIONS COMMUNITY
SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
AFTER AFTER A DEVASTATING
EARTHQUAKE. SO AGAIN JUST TO BE
VERY CLEAR IT IS NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT IS- BUT
THE COMMISSION IS CONSIDERING IS
BECOMING IN ANY WAY. A
LITIGATION ARM- TO ENSURE THAT
THAT- EXISTING LAWS OR
REGULATIONS I THINK YOU
MENTIONED BUILDING CODES- ARE
BEING ENFORCED BY TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR STATE
PARTNERS THAT WE CAN BRING TO
BEAR EACH OTHER'S. I SPECIFIC
SKIL SETS EXPERTISE AND TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE UPHELD AND
PROTECTED THANK YOU MA'AM. AND
IT WAS JUST BECAUSE OF YOUR
PREVIOUS BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE THE FARMWORKERS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY HAD- AND- WITH
HEALER BE AND SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S NOT. YOUR
INTENT AS- A MEMBER OF THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION TO
TAKE THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION IN THAT DIRECTION
THAT WAS MY QUESTION. CERTAINLY
NOT MY INTENT AND WILL LIKELY
NOT SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO DO AND THE
CAPACITY AS A- SOCIAL SERVICES
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
COMMISSION. WHAT I DO BRING A
DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF THE WAYS
IN WHICH MANY OF OUR- MOST.
FEDERAL AND STATE STRUCTURES AND
SYSTEMS CAN SERVE TO. TO
MARGINALIZE AND TWO SQUARED ARE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES I AM
WHO ARE IN DIRE NEED OF THOSE
REPORTS AND HOW WE CAN BE MORE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT DESIGNING. AND
TO THOSE MARGINS TO ENSURE THAT
THE FOLKS WHO ARE MOST IN NEED
OF OUR SERVICES AND OUR SUPPORT
OUR IMPACT- AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THERE WOULD BE ANY BALLS OR
NEED TO EITHER A REQUEST
LITIGATION TO MEDICATE MYSELF.
I'M MORE TO CHANGE THE SCOPE OR
THE NATURE OF EACH JURISDICTION
AND IMPORTANT THE SECOND STATE
TO COMMISSION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT RESPONSE AND I
REALLY DO WANT TO KNOW THAT I
APPRECIATE. AND EVEN DURING THE
LITIGATION PIECE OF THE L. R. B.
AND YOU MENTIONED IT HERE IN
YOUR COMMENTS LANGUAGE ACCESS
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF THOSE
FARMWORKERS WERE. ONLY SPANISH
SPEAKING BUT THERE IS ALWAYS
REPRESENTATION THERE WITH
MULTIPLE LINGUISTS THERE BECAUSE
AMONG COMMUNITY IN THE SPANISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITY. AND M. AGAIN
FOR YOU MAKING THAT STATEMENT
TODAY THAT IS AND- IS ONE GOOD
THING THAT I APPLIED YOU ONE AND
I THINK THAT I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE HE SAID SOMETHING
REALLY POSITIVE. AND BECAUSE I
KNOW I CAN MATCH YOU WITH THE
ELLERBEE STUFF SO- THANK YOU
MA'AM FOR RESPONDING. TO THOSE
QUESTIONS I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU
A SENATOR GROVE. CENTER LAYERED
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IN THANK YOU. MR A CRUISE FOR
YOUR SERVICE HOME ONE MEME STAND
BACK BECAUSE THE QUESTION THAT
HAPPENED WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON.
ON PAST SERVICE TO FIFTEEN
MEMBERS OF THE SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION AND WHILE YOU ARE OF
FILLING A CERTAIN- A SLOT IN THE
APPOINTMENT OF PROCESS. HOW DO
YOU VIEW THE GLOBAL-
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COMMISSION
WHAT DO YOU THINK- IT NEEDS TO
DO NOW AND IS DOING WELL OR
ISN'T DOING WELL. THANK YOU
CENTER FOR THAT QUESTION- I
MOVED AND TO REFER TO YOUR
RECENT REPORT THAT WAS DONE
AFTER THE RICH BY OUR EARTHQUAKE
EVENTS AT THE RIDGECREST
EARTHQUAKE EVENT THAT WAS
COMMISSIONED AND THAT WAS DONE
BY THE COMMISSION AND THEN- WERE
MADE YEAH AND THERE WAS AN
INVESTIGATION UNDERTAKEN TO SEE
WHAT WAS. THE RESPONSE LIKE WHAT
. LET ARE PREPARED WHAT WERE THE
THINGS WERE ABLE MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF THE EVENT. AND THEN
WHAT CAN WE LEARN FROM THIS
EVENT TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
DOING BETTER IN THE FUTURE. I
THINK IT'S THAT KIND OF REALLY
DEEP THINKING- THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE COMMISSION TO TRULY PLAYED A
ROLE IN DEEPENING CALIFORNIA'S
RESILIENCE TRAFFIC OFFENSE- I
LISTEN TO SOME AMAZING BUNKERS
THE OTHER DAY TALK ABOUT
RESILIENCE AND HOW. HOW THAT
WORD CAN ACTUALLY. NUMBER
HOWEVER OR OR ALLOW FOR US TO
USE SITE OUTSIDE OF OUR-
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACTUALLY BE
THERE TO PICK UP THOSE PROGRAMS
JUST TO ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES
ARE ARE IN FACT. RECOVERY AFTER
THESE EVENTS AND- AND TO ENSURE
ALSO THAT WE ARE MORE PREPARED
FOR FUTURE EVENTS AND I THINK
IT'S THAT IDEA- UNDERSTANDING
THAT RESILIENCE ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN JUST PUT ON A
COMMUNITY AFTER AN ADVENTIST
HAPPENED BUT RESILIENCE IS
ACTUALLY BUILT. WHEN WE ARE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
AND HONORING THE SUFFERING THE-
FONT CARE. AND VERY CLEARLY
ARTICULATING WHAT ARE THOSE
LESSONS LEARNED AND ONLY THEN
ARE WE ABLE TO BUILD THAT
RESIDENTS ITSELF. I AM I AM
REALLY MOVED BY THE ASSAM WORK
PRODUCT OF THE COMMISSION- WITH
VERY LITTLE RESOURCES IN THE
PAST AND TO BRING THAT KIND OF
WORK PRODUCT TO THE STATE- AND I
AND I THINK THAT IT SPENDING A
VERY IMPORTANT SIGNIFICANT- AND
STRUCTURAL SHIFTS AT AGAIN HOW
THE COMMISSION SECOND SIDE OF.
YES MARIN- BECAUSE IN THAT. WAY
THAT KIND OF THOUGHTFULNESS AND
NOT. AND- I WOULD SAY THAT.
ANYONE USE THE WORD POSTMORTEM
BECAUSE THAT TO TWO MORE. THIS
PARTICULAR SAID. BUT ABILITY TO
LOOK BACK. ON TO LEARN. FROM THE
EVENTS AND TO LIFT UP THE
EXPERIENCES OF THE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES- RICH CREEK BRIDGE
WEST. PRESSED EARTHQUAKE
OCCURRED IN A VERY LITTLE PART
OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW THAT.
ARE REAL CALIFORNIA FACES.
SPECIFIC INSIGNIFICANT AND VERY
UNIQUE CHALLENGES ARE BOTH
SHOOTING TO BE PREPARED AND TO
MITIGATE ANY IMPACTS AS WELL AS
TO ENSURE THAT. THEY ARE
RECOVERING AND HAVE ACCESS TO
THE KINDS OF RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED GIVEN THEIR LOCATION AND
THEIR JOB. THAT IS. IT CAN BE
KIND OF REMOTE TO AND REMOVED
FROM. MANY OF THOSE RESOURCES
SO. I'M AT THAT REPORT AND I
RECKON. THE POWER OF THAT
THINKING. I'M AND THE RECORD
THAT THEY ARE SOME VERY CRITICAL
ANDPOWERFUL RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT HAPPENED THE INDISPENSABLE
TO LOOKING DEEPER AT AROUND. I
CAN IMAGINE THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE COMMISSION WOULD I'M NOT
ONLY NEVER DO AGAIN BACK
CONTINUE TO DO BETTER NOW IN
THIS LARGER CALLAWAY ASKING.
WELL. IF- JUST TO COMMENT AND-
SO THE CONVERSE CATEGORY- I HAD
THE MISFORTUNE. TO BE HONEST
CITY COUNCIL IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE OF THE CITY THAT 60% OF THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE IN THE CORE
DOWNTOWN WAS DESTROYED BY AN
EARTHQUAKE WE HAD REMOVED THE-
THE BUILDINGS DOWNTOWN WAS CLOSE
FOR TWO OR THREE YEARS THERE
WERE A WHOLE HOST. OF ISSUES AND
WE HAD SOMEBODY COME TO US TWO
YEARS OUT FROM THAT EARTHQUAKE
CAN SAY. ARE YOU HAVE BUILDINGS
IN THE DOWNTOWN THAT ARE
STRUCTURALLY SOUND AGAINST AN
EARTHQUAKE IN THE STATE DID A
REQUIREMENT THAT WE HAVE A
COMPLETE INSPECTION ON ALL THE
BUILDINGS AND THEIR STRUCTURAL
INTEGRITY DOWNTOWN. IT TURNED
OUT OF A SCHEDULED TO COME TO US
THE TUESDAY AFTER THE
EARTHQUAKE. AND NOT STUDY
ACCURATELY PREDICTED. THE PLACES
THAT PEOPLE DIED THE PLACES
PEOPLE TRAPPED AND THE BUILDINGS
THAT WERE DESTROYED. AND IT
SPEAKS TO THE LARGER ROLE THAT
YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT BECAUSE I
THINK. IN THE COMMISSION. IT IS
ALWAYS NOT A MATTER OF- IF
THERE'LL BE ANOTHER EARTHQUAKE
BUT WHEN. AND THERE'S A MATTER
OF HOW WE WILL BE PREPARED AND I
THINK WHAT YOU JUST TOLD ME. IS
THAT YOU REALLY WANT TO LOOK AT
THE ANALYSIS OF PREVIOUS QUAKES
LEARN FROM THEM. AND INCORPORATE
THAT IN POLICY AND I WAS JUST
THINKING WHEN I WORKED HERE. MY
GRANDMOTHER EVEN LIVED IN SANTA
ROSA FOR THAT EARTHQUAKE THAT
HAPPENED WHENEVER IT WAS FIFTY
YEARS AGO IT WAS TRAPPED IN A
BEDROOM UNTIL SOMEBODY CAME IN.
AND GODART AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL HAPPEN
EVERYWHERE SO WILL YOU. HE JUST
TO CLOSE THIS YEAR YOU REALLY
THINK THAT IT'S YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THAT KIND
OF WORK ON THIS COMMISSION AND
YES YOU'VE YOU HAVE AN EQUITY
LINES BECAUSE OF THE CATEGORY
RAN BUT YOU'RE ONE OF FIFTEEN
COMMISSIONERS AS THE GLOBAL
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR EVERYTHING
HERE AND YOU'RE READY TO TAKE
THAT SERIOUSLY THAT'S WHAT I WAS
HEARING FROM YOU. YES CAPTURE
THAT BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SO MUCH US SENATOR
TOM WALKER. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM AND I APOLOGIES IF SOME OF
MY QUESTIONS- WE'RE ALREADY
ANSWERED- BUT I WASN'T TRANSIT
WALKING ACROSS THE STREET- SO
THANK YOU MISS DELA CRUZ I AM.
SORRY THAT YOU AND I WERE NOT
ABLE TO- SPEAK BEFOREHAND BUT-
X. I'M EXCITED TO HAVE YOU-
BEFORE US AND I HAVE TO TELL
YOU- NEAR EARTHQUAKES DO NOT GET
ALONG I AM A GIRL FROM THE
MIDWEST AND SO AND I AM BLIND
WITHOUT MY GLASSES AND SO. YOU
KNOW I SHAKING EARTH WITHOUT ANY
WARNING IS JUST A BAD
COMBINATION FOR ME- SO I APPLAUD
YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST IN THIS
SPACE. I- HAVE TO ALSO COMMENDED
YOU FOR- YOU KNOW SERVING ON THE
MANY AND DIVERSE ORGANIZATIONS
ON WHICH SHE SAID I PRESUME AS A
BOARD MEMBER I CAN CERTAINLY SEE
FROM YOUR- SELECTION THAT YOU
ARE COMMITTED TO COMMUNITY AND I
THINK THAT'S ALSO BEEN
REFERENCED AND- MANY OF YOUR
RESPONSES. AND I TOO WAS ABLE TO
READ- THE- LETTER OF OPPOSITION-
REGARDING YOUR APPOINTMENT AND I
WILL JUST SAY THIS YOU KNOW- YOU
CAN'T HAVE HATERS IF YOU DON'T
HAVE FANS. SO I HOPE YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT- I HAVE ONE QUESTION
ABOUT- EARTHQUAKES AND THEN I
HAVE ANOTHER ABOUT- TSUNAMIS.
AND I TEND TO BE WHEN I HAVE
INSOMNIA TURN ON THE TELEVISION
AND FOR THE LIFE OF ME I DON'T
KNOW WHY THE DAY AFTER TOMORROW
KEEPS SHOWING UP- ON LATE NIGHT
TV. AND THEN IT CAUSES ME TO
THINK ABOUT THE TSUNAMI WARNING
SIGNS THAT I SEE WHEN I AM
TRAVELLING OUT OF MY DISTRICT
GETTING CLOSER TO THE WATER- AND
JUST WOULD LOVE TO KNOW FROM YOU
WHAT IS THE STATUS OF THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO PROTECT. OUR
COASTAL POPULATIONS AGAINST THE
THREAT POSED EITHER BY A DISTANT
OR NEAR SOURCE TSUNAMI EVENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR FOR
THAT QUESTION- I LOVE LIVING AND
NUMBER COUNTY THERE ARE MANY
BENEFITS TO IT AND THERE'S ALSO
AN AMAZING WELL- OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US TO LEARN. I'M VERY
CRITICALLY AND VERY CAREFULLY
ADD WHAT IS WORKING ON OUR
COASTLINE TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE SAFE. WE AND CINEMA COUNTY
ARE ALSO- I WOULD SAY- WE LIVE
ON A COAST THAT REMINDS US EVERY
DAY OF THE POWER OF MOTHER
NATURE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
RESPECTING AND UNDERSTANDING OUR
IMPACT ON HUMAN BEINGS I'M SO
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF VERY
TRAGIC DEATHS WITH REGARDS TO
LARGE SNEAKER WAVES THAT CAN
SNEAK UP ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH OUR COASTLINE.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THE
INCREASING LEVEL- SIGNAGE AND
WARNINGS INCREASING PRESENCE
ARMS RANGERS AND COAST GUARD- ON
OUR COAST I THINK HAS REALLY
UPPED THE INTEREST AND THE-
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RECOGNITION
OF THAT OF THE DANGER BOTH
AROUND KIND OF WAVES WHICH WE
KNOW WILL INCREASE WITH
INTENSITY AS CLIMATE CHANGE
INCREASES. THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE INCREASE BUT ALSO- ALL OF
THOSE NOMINEES SIGNS ARE ALL OF
OUR CALL SIGN AND SO I WOULD SAY
THAT THAT WHAT I SEE IN SONOMA
COUNTY AND WHAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO MAKE SURE THAT I'M PAYING
CLOSE ATTENTION TO AND BRING TO
THE COMMISSION IS HOW ARE WE
ENSURING THAT THOSE THAT
INFORMATION IS BEING SHARED WITH
ALL OUR WITH OUR PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY. I
MOVED FIVE EIGHT THE SIGNAGE
BEING IN SPANISH AND ENGLISH I
AM ALWAYS LOOKING TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE PROVIDING NOT ONLY
LANGUAGE ACCESS BUT MEMBERS
JUSTICE AND THAT WE ARE BRINGING
INFORMATION THAT IS RELEVANT AND
ACCESSIBLE. TO PEOPLE WHO DON'T
NECESSARILY. WE ENGLISH OR ARE
UNDER WHAT'S ON THE SIGN. OR
READ SPANISH THAT FOR THE MATTER
- AND SO ARE MY UNDER. OF THIS
STAGE IS THAT MUCH OF THE-
INITIAL STAGES ARE PROVIDING
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SIGNAGE
THROUGHOUT OUR UP AND DOWN OUR
COAST LINES AS WELL AND PROCESS.
AND AND THIS IS THAT IS A ISSUE
THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART GIVEN MY HOME COUNTY AND-
THE IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE
THAT ALL PEOPLE HAVE A SECOND
CHANCE. GREAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AD YES BECAUSE- WE YOU
KNOW WE WERE IN A SESSION NOT
LONG AGO AND- WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CONSERVATION AND CLIMATE
AND WE WERE- IT WAS SHARED WITH
US THAT NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE DROUGHT BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO CONTEND WITH FUTURE
FLOODS- AND SO A TSUNAMI
ACTIVITIES I THINK ARE REALLY
REAL. MY SECOND LAST QUESTION-
DOES HAVE TO DO WITH- MY
FAVORITE MY FAVORITE TOPIC
EARTHQUAKES- AND I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW WARNINGS ARE ONE ASPECT OF
THE GAME BUT I FEEL LIKE-
ANOTHER ASPECT IT SORT OF IS
SEISMIC RETROFITTING AND WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO REALLY- SHORE UP
AND STRENGTHEN. OF CIVIC
INSERTED INTO STRUCTURE IT'S
REALLY INTEGRAL TO HOW WE LIVE
AND OPERATE AND I HAVE BEEN.
ODDLY ENOUGH HEARING MORE AND
MORE FROM FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT.
WHO EITHER- RUN A SOCIAL SERVICE
NONPROFITS- HOSPITALS. SHELTERS
RULES I'M TALKING ABOUT SEISMIC
RETROFITTING AND- SORT OF
SUPPORT THAT IS NEEDED FROM THE
STATE MORE GUIDANCE THAT IS
NEEDED FROM THE STATE
EXTENSIONS- HELP AND- YOU KNOW
AS I'M WALKING BACK AND FORTH
FROM THIS BUILDING TO- OUR OTHER
OFFICE SPACE AND IT'S HOT AND
IT'S HOT IN JANUARY WHEN IT'S
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE HOT WHICH IS
MY TRIGGER FOR EARTHQUAKES- I
JUST WONDERING HOW CAN YOU. CAN
YOU HOW CAN YOU ELEVATE THE
ISSUE OF YOU KNOW SORT OF A
STATE WIDE TO THE SEISMIC
RETROFITTING PLAN OR SOMETHING
THAT KIND OF MOVES US CLOSER TO
HER BUT I THINK UNDERSTANDING
AND ACKNOWLEDGING I THINK HOW
CRITICAL IT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN.
TO SHORE UP SO MANY OF THESE-
BUILDINGS AND FACILITIES THAT
THOUSANDS IF NOT MILLIONS OF
CONSTITUENTS EITHER NEED- WILL
WATCH AS IF THE ACCESS THERE IS
A PROBLEM OR GOING IN AND OUT OF
EVERY DAY TO WORK FOR TO LIVE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. SO I- WE
RECENTLY REVIEWED THAT ONE OF
THE COMMISSION- NEWEST
PUBLICATIONS WHICH IS AN UPDATE
FOR BOTH HOMEOWNERS AS WELL AS
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OWNERS-
AROUND. HOW TO ENSURE- HOW DO
YOU EVEN UNDERSTAND CURRENT
STATUS OF YOUR PROPERTY WHETHER
OR NOT IT IS IN FACT. EARTHQUAKE
RESILIENT EARTHQUAKE READY AND I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE MORE
THAT INFORMATION GETS OUT.
THROUGHOUT COMMUNITIES TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT TO LOOK FOR AND
WHAT TO SEE- WE WERE WE ARE
GOING TO GET A MUCH BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
AND SO I AM REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE PUBLICATION OF
THIS UPDATE IT'S A IT'S A GUIDE
THAT IS YOU KNOW. THE TO BE VERY
ACCESSIBLE AND READER FRIENDLY
AND TWO AND TO BEGIN TO DEVELOP
SOME OF THOSE SKILLS THAT MAY
NOT YET BE AND ARE LARGER
POPULATIONS TO BE ABLE TO GO
CHECK OUT WHAT IS YOUR BRACING
ON YOUR FOUNDATION LOOKS LIKE.
AND- AND ALSO TO DIRECT OUR
HOMEOWNERS AND COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY OWNERS- TO. TWO PEOPLE
WHO CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
SOME OF THESE THINGS FOR THEM
WERE TRAINED TO OUR LICENSE TO-
HAVE ACCESS TO. AND TO THE RIGHT
SKILLSET AND TO THE RIGHT- SET
OF TOOLS IN ORDER TO TRULY MAKE
THESE PROPERTIES- SAFE AND
READY. AND SO I THINK THAT'S THE
FIRST THING AND THE SECOND THAT
WE RECOGNIZE AS THE NEED FOR
FUNDING TO FACILITATE AND TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION- I WOULD SAY THE OTHER
THING IN THIS IS REFLECTING A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT SENATOR
LAYERED ASKED. ABOUT LOOKING
BACKWARDS AT EARLIER EVENTS. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT STRUCK ME
IN THEIR FRENCH. PRESSED A
RECORD WAS THAT DOES. REQUESTS
FOR SEISMIC SAFETY OR STRUCTURAL
SOUNDNESS TRACKS WERE VOLUNTARY
AND NOT MANDATORY IN CERTAIN
AREAS. AND I THINK THOSE ARE
CALLED INTO QUESTION AND
DEFINITELY EQUITY QUESTIONS FOR
ME AND SO- WHILE IT MAY NOT BE
NECESSARY THE MOST POPULAR THING
I DO THINK IN CERTAIN AREAS
THERE IS A MANDATORY EQUIREMENT
THAT YOU GO GET CHECKED OUT FOR.
AFTER STRUCTURAL SOUNDNESS AND
I'D LOVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
EXPAND THAT MANDATORY. OF THE
INSPECTION AND WEBER SAID A
RECOGNITION THAT IF YOU MEET
THOSE THOSE MANDATORY
REQUIREMENTS IF YOU'RE YOU'RE
COMING AND EVEN IF YOU'RE
VOLUNTEERING STYLE. THERE IS
ACCESS TO FUNDS THAT WILL OPEN
UP TO FACILITATE AND ENCOURAGE
YOU TO MOVE TOWARDS RECORD
RESILIENCE. AND I THINK THAT THE
COMMISSION IS VERY CLEAR THAT.
AT THOSE FUNDS DO NOT IT GEN AND
INSUFFICIENT. WAYS FOR FOLKS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. ANOTHER
ADDITIONAL. THREATS AND RISKS
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE OWN OF THEIR
OWN. THESE. THAT WOULD. AND
PRESIDENT CELANESE AT RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE IS A PRESS THAT MAY
NOT KNOW- HOW MAY NOT THE
WHATEVER ARE THE RIGHT NOW TAKE
OUT TO MAKE PLACE IS A THEY THAT
THEY RUN FAVOR FOR THEM I'M
SORRY THIS IS A AREA THAT I AM
AREN'T VERY INTERESTED IN MOVING
FOR. FORWARD WITH AND I FEEL.
I'M BACK- COLLEAGUES TO SIMILAR
INTEREST AND OUT SOME OF THESE
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES AND-
MEETING OUR NEEDS WITH THE RIGHT
TOOLS AND WITH THE RIGHT
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STATE AS A WHOLE IS PROTECTED
AND MORE RESILIENT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. GREAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT I HAVE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU SENATOR COM LOGGER- MAKING
SURE MEADOW VICE CHAIR DID YOU
WANT TO. FINISH UP. VERY QUICKLY
ON. GET MY- THE PRESS HERE I
THINK YOU MITHILA CRUISE FOR-
WHAT APPEARS TO BE A VERY ROBUST
- ROLE THAT YOU'VE TAKEN THAT
WAY AND ON IF NOT VOLUNTEER WORK
WITH A LOT OF THE OTHER NON
PROFITS AND THE PUBLIC AGENCIES
OVER YOUR CAREER AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT I DO
HAVE A QUESTION. REGARDING
APARTMENT THE TO MAKE THE RULES
STAFF AND LET ME BOB GIVE A
PREAMBLE TO THAT I AM VERY
STRONG ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND LOCAL CONTROL AND YOU
ACTUALLY SAID ARE YOU SUGGESTED
THE COMMISSION COULD PUT OUT A
BROCHURE TO RENTERS EXPLAINING
HOW TO DETERMINE IF THE HOUSE
THE RENT IS UP TO CODE AND WHAT
THE RAMIFICATIONS WOULD BE IF
THEY ASK THE COUNTY TO DO AN
INSPECTION. AND I'M I'M KIND OF
WONDERING WHY WE WOULD WANT THE
FIVE MAKE COMMISSION SHOULD BE
REACHING BEYOND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OUR CODE
ENFORCEMENT AND GOING DIRECTLY
TO RANCHERS WITH SOMETHING I
THINK COULD BE VERY CONFUSING TO
THEM AND ALMOST WITH. THAT THERE
COULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY ONCE
AGAIN FOR LITIGATION THAT MIGHT
HAVE NOT BEEN YOUR PURPOSE BUT.
BACK TO BEING A- OFFICIAL IT
WILL. OUR CITY AND THE KING
LEVEL. THAT COULD CREE REAL. OUT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW NOT BECAUSE-
SUGGESTING THAT. ARE WHAT THEY
ARE RENTING IS WHO POTENTIALLY
MIGHT NOT UP TO CODE AND START
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO CONTROL. AND ADVICE AND THEN
DRAFT CODE ENFORCEMENT OUR TO DO
WHAT COULD BE A MASSIVE-
INVESTIGATION MANY PROPERTIES SO
I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT AND I DON'T
WANT TO BE READING IT
INCORRECTLY BECAUSE THAT WASN'T
IN THE MEETING. YES COULD HAVE
BEEN IF SOMETHING DIFFERENT BEDS
ARE I'D LIKE TO HEAR YOUR
EXPLANATION ON THAT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION CENTER BATES-
ONE OF THE THINGS I REALLY
APPRECIATED ABOUT THE KIND OF
REMAKING OF THE INSIDE OF THE
COMMISSION AS THE RECOGNITION.
SPECIFIC INTERESTS THAT COME
FROM FOLKS WHO ARE SERVING IN
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES AND WE HAVE
ROBUST REPRESENTATIVES FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ON THE
COMMISSION- AND I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT I ONE OF THE THINGS I HAVE
QUESTIONS. ABOUT THE COMMISSION
AND IT'S- RECOGNITION THAT
STAKEHOLDERS ARE MUCH BROADER
THAN. FIFTEEN OF US
COMMISSIONERS AND THAT- WE ARE
EACH TASKED WITH THE IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITIES OF BRINGING
THINGS HERE ARE YOU ARE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITIES AND- AND
AS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT. OFFICIAL
I SEE THAT AS BEING HYPOCRITICAL
TO MY ROLE I'M IN THE STATE LIKE
HI CITY AND SO. I DON'T SEE ANY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN- MAKING
AVAILABLE A PAMPHLET THAT'S
DIRECTED TO OUR COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL. PROPERTY OWNERS ARE
HOMEOWNERS AROUND HOW THEY COULD
KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE- AND A
PAMPHLET THAT WOULD ALSO GO TO
RENTERS OF THOSE OF THOSE SAME
PROPERTIES AND- THAT WOULD
CHALLENGE LOCAL CONTROL IN
PARTICULAR- I THINK AS YOU KNOW.
WE RECOGNIZE THE POWER OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND BEING
ABLE TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHT FROM
ONE PERSPECTIVE WHAT THEY ARE
SEEING. WHAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ATTEMPTING TO ENFORCE THEIR
EXISTING RIGHTS ARE BRINGING TO
THEM IT IS A REALLY CRITICAL
FUNCTION. OF THEIR CAPACITY. AND
SO I- I THINK THAT I'M I'M-
ADJUSTING AT ALL THAT- M. THAT
WOULD BE DIRECT TO RENTERS PLAN
- WHAT THREATENS LOCAL CONTROL
AND ANYWAY IN FACT IT WOULD JUST
BE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
MORE AND MORE UNDERSTANDING AND
COMFORT WITH UNDERSTANDING HOW
WE BECOME MORE RESILIENT AS YOU
KNOW IN IN EACH OF OUR ROLES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WHETHER YOU ARE
A PROPERTY OWNER OR WHETHER YOU
ARE VENTURA WHO CAN HELP YOUR-
AND- YOUR- YOUR LANDLORD OR YOUR
COMMERCIALS AND MORE AND TO FIND
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO KEEP.
THEIR PROPERTY SAFE AND AS A
RESULT TO KEEP YOUR LIFE SAFE- I
THINK THE OTHER THING THAT I
WOULD SAY IS THAT WORKING AS AN
AS AN EQUITY ADVOCATE- WE REALLY
COME AT THINGS WITH AN ASSET
FRAME NOT A DEFICIT AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A GREATER AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION IN THE HANDS OF
GREATER NUMBERS OF PEOPLE AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY ABLE TO ACTIVATE
PEOPLE'S SKILL SETS AND THERE
ARE CONNECTIVITY TO GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTIONS. AND THEIR OWN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY AND OUR STATE'S
LARGER. EFFORT AND SO. JUST JUST
THREE. I AM SUGGEST THAT WE
REMOVE LOCAL CONTROL OVER
IMPORTANT ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
JUST THAT ANY MORE INFORMATION I
THINK IN THE HANDS OF MORE
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY AROUND THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE OF. PUBLIC
SAFETY AND STRUCTURAL SAFETY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES I'M IS A GOOD
THING. THANK YOU FOR THAT
RESPONSE I GUESS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO NOT TOTALLY AGREE ON
THAT BECAUSE IT SOUNDS TO ME
LIKE. THE SIZE MAKE COMMISSION
WOULD ACTUALLY SUPERSEDE THE
ROLE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
THEIR ENFORCEMENT ON PROPERTIES
THAT ARE NOT UP TO. SNUFF
ACCORDING TO WHATEVER. THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE IN A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THOSE DIFFERENT OF
FOR LET'S SAY COASTAL PROPERTIES
WHICH IS A HUGE PART OF MY
DISTRICT. AND THOSE THAT MIGHT
BE MORE IN LAND IN TERMS OF THE
RISKS THAT ARE INVOLVED WITH THE
NOMINEES ARE FOLLOWING
EARTHQUAKES AND WE HAVE A VERY
ROBUST WARNING SYSTEM ALONG THE
COASTAL PROPERTIES ALREADY. SO I
JUST THINK THAT SOMETHING- THAT
SUBORDINATES LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
A SEISMIC COMMISSION IN IN
PARTICULAR YOUR APPOINTMENT TO
THAT WHICH IS AND SOCIAL
SERVICES NOT CODE ENFORCEMENT.
INSTABILITY OF THE BUILDINGS AND
WEBER WITH THE CODE FOR A AND
VARIOUS REGIONS IS A LITTLE
OVERREACH- BY THE WAY I LOOK AT
IT LAST QUESTION. ABOUT WHAT YOU
SEE IS FOR TRADITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF FOR THE
APPOINTMENT TO THE SOCIAL
SERVICE FEET. ON THE SEISMIC
COMMISSION AND I ASK YOU THAT
BECAUSE ONCE UPON A TIME I WAS
AN EMPLOYEE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. AND HAPPENED TO
BE THERE DURING A COUPLE AT
LEAST ONE OF THE EARTHQUAKES WE
HAVE A CASELOAD THAT DEFINE
WHERE THOSE ARE VERY LOW INCOME
AND VERY VULNERABLE PROPERTIES
OLD ONES BY THE WAY. SO IT WOULD
BE VERY EASY THROUGH THE SOCIAL
SERVICES AGENCY IF YOU ARE THE
REPRESENTATIVE. IN THE ADOPTION
OF WE NEED EDUCATION TO USE THAT
AS A VEHICLE BY TWO TO BE
RELATING TO THROUGH THE COUNTIES
TO THERE ARE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS. OF HOW TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION TO THOSE FOLKS THAT
ACTUALLY ARE. OUR IN. OUR SOCIAL
SERVICES CASELOADS. THANK YOU
SENATOR SO- YOUR LAST EVER. THE
IT SHOULD HIS. OF THIS POSITION
APPOINTMENT- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS FIRST
POSSESSION OF THE SOCIAL
SERVICES REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
COMMISSION IS ACTUALLY A NEW
POSITION AS A RESULT OF THE
RESTRUCTURING THE COMMISSION.
AND SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS. A TRADITIONAL
HISTORICAL ROLE IN THIS CAPACITY
I WOULD SAY THAT. AGAIN GIVEN MY
EXPERIENCE. IN LOOKING AT OUR
PREPAREDNESS AS WELL AS DISASTER
IMMEDIATE DISASTER RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY. AND OTHER DISASTERS
HAS PREPARED ME VERY WELL FOR
BEING ABLE TO LUCK WITH A
CRITICAL EYE TOWARDS. OUR
CURRENT BENEFITS STRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE. TO ENSURE EQUITABLE
APPARENT NURSES WAS AFFABLE
RECOVERY AS I MENTIONED IN MY IN
MY COMMENTS EARLIER. AND WE ARE
SEEING NATIONAL DATA THAT SHOWS
US THAT THERE GREATER NUMBER OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT FLOWS INTO
A CAMINO. COMMUNITY AFTER A
DISASTER ACTUALLY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS INEQUITIES- IT DEPENDS
AND EXACERBATES THEM AND SO I
THINK AND MY ROLE AS- THE SOCIAL
SERVICES COMMISSIONER. AND IN
THIS. IN THIS COMMISSION BE TO.
A REAL UNDERSTANDING OF THE WAYS
IN WHICH SOME OF THOSE EXISTING
SYSTEMS AND STRUCTURES ACTUALLY
SERVE TO EXCLUDE PEOPLE. WHO
MOST NEED TO BE SERVED AND HOW
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
SOCIAL SERVICES ADMINISTRATION
AS I HAVE DONE IN PAST
DISASTERS- I WAS. VERY VERY
HAPPY TO FIND- SOME OLD FRIENDS
AND SOME AND SOME NEW FRIENDS
AND SIDE OF. AND CDSS DURING
THIS THE COUNTY FIRE IS WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE ON IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WERE AVAILABLE AND A NEW AND
CREATIVE. FUNDING STREAMS TO
ADDRESS A PARTICULAR NEEDS AND
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
ACTUALLY EXCLUDED FROM BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS FEDERAL- AND
OTHER STATE BENEFITS PROGRAMS
AND S- IT WOULD BE THAT
COMBINATION OF MY- DEEP
EXPERIENCE IN DISASTER RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY. AS WELL AS AND MY
CLOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND MY
KNOWLEDGE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
MANY OF THE STATE INSTITUTIONS-
ARE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT BEING
CREATIVE AND RECOGNIZING SOME OF
THOSE GAPS. AT WHEN HEARING OF
THE FEDERAL AND SOME OF THE GAPS
THEN WE KIND OF. CREATE BUYING
THEM AND NOT BE MORE CREATIVE
RECOGNIZING THAT. THE UNIQUENESS
OF CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY AND
THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT THAT
CREATES FOR SO MANY OF US IN
PUBLIC SERVICE TO. BE CREATIVE
AND HAVE OUR EYES I'M JUST A
LITTLE BIT WIDER OPEN TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE SEEING AND SERVING
EVERYONE WHO NEEDS US. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE RESPONSES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF MEADOW VICE CHAIR- I
THINK I PROBABLY HAVE A ONE
QUESTION AND THEN A COMMENT
BEFORE WE GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. I'M JUST GOING
TO QUICKLY- ASK IN TERMS OF. WE
HAVE A LETTER OF SUPPORT HERE I
KNOW WE'VE GOTTEN WE GET THIS ON
OUR WEBSITE WE GET IT AND ARE
BACK UP- A KNOWLEDGE AND WE HAVE
A LETTER OF SUPPORT- FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR MIKE MCGUIRE-
WE ALSO HAVE A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION FROM THE CINEMA
COUNTY FARM BUREAU- MYSTICAL
CHRIS I JUST WANT TO ASK ONE OF
THE COMMENTS IN THE- LETTER FROM
THE SONO MY COUNTY. FARM BUREAU
. WHAT BASICALLY SUGGESTED THAT
MAYBE YOU DO NOT HAVE THE TIME
OR THE TO DO THIS AND I JUST I
JUST WANT YOU TO STATE FOR THE
RECORD. YOU SERVED IT LOOKS TO
ME LIKE SIX MONTHS- YOU'VE
ANSWERED A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
HERE IT SEEMS TO ME YOU'RE
ENGAGED BUT I JUST WANT TO.
CONFIRM THAT OBVIOUSLY YOUR
COMMITMENT IS TO DO THIS AND- I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THAT ON THE
RECORD GIVEN. THE APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
MADAM CHAIR- THAT'S WHY IS NOT
NECESSARILY AN APPOINTMENT THAT
I SOUGHT OUT- I RESPONDED TO OUR
QUESTION THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
TO CONSIDER THIS APPOINTMENT
GIVEN MY EXPERIENCE AND DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY DURING THE SONOMA
COUNTY WILDFIRES AND IT WAS AN
HONOR FOR ME TO CONSIDER AND
THEN TO MAKE THE DECISION THAT
IN FACT THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT.
AREA FOR ME TO DEEPEN MY SKILLS
AND TO ENSURE THAT I WAS ALSO
BRINGING THAT PERSPECTIVE FROM A
VERY UNIQUE IN PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY AND TO- INTO THE
LARGER STATE AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE CINEMA COUNTY- DEALS WITH
THE THREATS OF TSUNAMIS WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY SUFFERED FROM MAJOR
EARTHQUAKES AND WE ARE NOW
GROUND ZERO FOUR- THESE NEW
URBAN WILDFIRES THAT WE WILL SEE
INCREASING IN INTENSITY AND SO
THAT COMBINATION OF EXPERIENCE
AND MY DEEP DEDICATION AND LOVE
TO. ALL OF MY COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT I COME
FROM THAT I SEE IN THAT I LOVE
ON- WITH ALL OF MY HEART AND
MAKES IT CLEAR TO ME THAT THIS
IS NOT ONLY SOMETHING THAT- HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO DO BUT THE
DESIRE TO DO- I WOULD SAY THAT
MY WORK ETHIC IS- IS. IS VERY
STRONG AND. COME FROM FAMILIES
THAT. THAT HAVE SHOWN. HOW AND
HOW CRITICAL IT IS TO DEVELOP. A
WORK ETHIC THAT IS STRONG AND
POWERFUL THAT ALSO CONNECTS YOU
TO YOUR PURPOSE AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE NOT CITING OUT OF IT
BECAUSE THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT. FIND YOUR WAY THAT. KIND
OF LOOKS LIKE IT COULD BE COOL
BUT TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT IT
IS CONNECTED TO. YOUR HEART'S
WORK AND TO WHAT IT IS THAT YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY AND CAPACITY TO
DO AND THAT IS A DECISION THAT I
MADE. WHEN I SAID YES YOUR THIS
AGREEMENT AND THAT I HAVE I HAVE
IN FACT BEEN DEEPLY ENGAGED
DIVAN TO EVERY MEETING I HAVE.
LEARNED A WHOLE NEW AREA- WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S CHALLENGES ARE- AND
HOW AND STARTED TO DREAM I'M
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMISSION ABOUT HOW WE CAN MEET
THOSE CHALLENGES. IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY- IN A WAY THAT
ENSURES JUSTICE AND IN A WAY
THAT RENT RESPECTS- THE NEEDS OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES- AND WHAT THEY
COULD BRING AS ASSETS. TO THE
LARGER STATE EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE MORE RESILIENT. AND
NOW WE ARE ABLE. TO WITHSTAND
THE CHALLENGES THAT OUR FUTURE
BRINGS. THANK YOU ARE VERY MUCH
FOR THAT- RESPONSE- WE ARE GOING
TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
FOR. A COMMENT WE START WITH
SUPPORT BUT I AM BEING ASKED BY
OUR STAFF. ALL RIGHT NOW WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE TELECONFERENCE-
MODERATOR TO. SEPARATE OUT-
THOSE THAT MAY NEED TRANSLATION
SERVICES. SO THAT WE CAN DO THIS
EFFECTIVELY SO I'M GONNA TAKE A-
JUST A QUICK PAUSE DON'T ANYBODY
GO AWAY. I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN KEEP THIS MOVING ON WHERE WE
HAVE ONE MEMBER WHO NEEDS TO GO
PERCENT OF BILL AND HEALTH. SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE- ARE ABLE
TO DO THIS EFFICIENTLY AND THAT
OP PEOPLE'S. VOICES WILL BE
HEARD SO. WE'RE JUST KOTECHA A
MOMENTARY PAUSE. NOT A RECESS
JUST A PAUSE.
OKAY ARE YOU THERE.
WE NEED YOU JUST A MOMENT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE ABLE TO
INFORM THE PUBLIC SHE'S GOOD
OKAY.
MEMBERS OF THE- AS WE GO TO THE
PUBLIC I'M GONNA MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS GOING IN AND WE WILL
START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
WE ARE NOTHING IF NOT FLEXIBLE
AND FLUID IN TERMS OF ALLOWING
REMOTE PARTICIPATION-
HISTORICALLY WE'VE DONE IT. IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND WE HAVE HAD
ORGANIZATIONAL ARM TRANSLATORS
ABLE FOR- TRANSLATION SERVICES
WE DO NOT HAVE OUR- TYPICALLY WE
ARE WE ARE ALERTED IN ADVANCE
THAT WE WOULD NEED TRANSLATION
SERVICES. ARM AND SO WE DID NOT
GET THAT INFORMATION IN ADVANCE
OF THE HEARING IN ORDER TO HAVE
SOMEONE THAT COULD TRANSLATE.
OUR FOR EXAMPLE I WE ANTICIPATE
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF- SPANISH
SPEAKING- SPEAKERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK SO- I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WE
WANT COMMENTS- WE EXPECT
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC. WE DO
NOT HAVE A TRANSLATOR ON STAND
BY RIGHT NOW TO DO THAT AND IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING WE DON'T HAVE
AN ORGANIZATIONAL REPRESENTATIVE
WHO CAN DO THAT. ON THE
TELECONFERENCE FROM THOSE WHO
MAY WISH TO SPEAK- WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO. IS WORKING WITH OUR
MODERATOR- MAKE SURE THAT.
WHATEVER TESTIMONY WE GET WILL
BE TRANSCRIBED WE ARE
VIDEOTAPING THIS AS WELL AS HAVE
A COURT REPORTER BUT IT WILL BE
THE TRANSCRIPTION OF THE VIDEO.
THAT WILL ALLO US TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THE PROPER TESTIMONY
FOR OUR RECORD AND FOR THE RULES
COMMITTEE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
HAVE THEIR- THEIR COMMENTS AND
THOUGHTS HEARD- WHAT MAY BE A
LITTLE DIFFICULT IS- I WILL OUT
A LITTLE BIT OF LEEWAY IN THE
BEGINNING BUT- PHAM WE WILL HAVE
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO SPEAK AND
REGISTER SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION
AND I CLEARLY UNDERSTAND SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- AS WORDS BUT-
EXTENSIVE TESTIMONY WILL BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT AND AT
SOME POINT I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE GETTING THE SUPPORT.
AND THE OPPOSITION AND THE NAME
OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO'S CALLING
IN AND WE WILL DO OUR BEST. TO
MAKE SURE WE DO THAT- SO ONE
SECOND.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA START WITH
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO- TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE I ACTUALLY SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
NUMBER- AND I HOPE WE WILL PUT
THAT NUMBER ON THE SCREEN- IT
IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ONE. AND MADAME MODERATOR I
WILL GO TO YOU AND WE WILL ASK
OUR FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
QUEUE. IF YOU IF YOU ARE IN THE
QUEUE AND- NEED TO SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH- BUT
IF YOU CAN'T SPEAK ENGLISH WE
WILL TAKE THE TIME WE NEED AND
ASK THAT YOU DO THAT IF YOU CAN.
MATAMATA RATER FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT. YOU CAN QUEUE UP THE
ARM THE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. I
APOLOGIZE I WAS INTO THE OTHER
ROOM BUT IF YOU WANT A PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW YES MADAM MODERATOR
THANK OU FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT I HAVE GIVEN
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER AGAIN AND
THE ACCESS CODE. DO YOU SEE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IF YOU ARE
IN THE PARKING LOT AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND I DO NOT SHOW
ANYBODY QUEUING UP IN SUPPORT AS
OF NOW AND HERE OKAY MADAM
MODERATOR US STAY WITH US- WE- I
SEE NO ONE FROM THE PUBLIC WE
WILL GO TO PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION
AND I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO
MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL COME
BACK TO YOU. AND ASKS ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I
AND YOU CAN LET ME KNOW IF YOU
HAVE HOW MANY CALLS YOU HAVE IF
YOU CAN DO THAT THANK YOU. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION IT IS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
OPPOSITION ONE NINE ZERO YOUR
HONOR SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK
UP YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
THE NUMBERS. WE DO HAVE ABOUT
SIX QUEUING UP FOR APPLICATION
HERE. HE JUST ONE MOMENT OKAY
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL START
WITH LINE NUMBER TWELVE THE BILL
HAS. HI HELLO THERE WILL DO IT
MY NAME IS A LITTLE BIT. I'D
LIKE TO ASK QUALITIES AND
QUALIFICATIONS IF ANY ARE NEEDED
FOR THE IDEAL CANDIDATE IN THE
COMMISSION- LET ME LET ME LET ME
STOP YOU THIS IS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU CANNOT ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OR
THE APPOINTEE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION GIVE ME YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. AND YOUR
POSITION. I'M SORRY I CANNOT
QUESTIONS DO NOT KNOW IS THAT IS
THAT IS THIS IS FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION WE ARE TAKING
OPPOSITION CALLS YOU CAN GIVE
YOUR NAME. AND THAT YOU OPPOSE
AND THAT IS FOR THE RECORD-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC DO NOT ASK
QUESTIONS THE QUESTIONS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ASKED BY THE-
SENATORS- PRIOR TO OPENING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT SO YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION. OKAY WELL MONEY
FOR THE LOCAL RIGHT AND I OPPOSE
AND- I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
POINT OF PUBLIC COMMENT IS IF
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA LET IT. SPEAK
AND ASK QUESTIONS THAT WE
BELIEVE ARE. EVENTS RATHER THAN
YOU ARE SPEAKING ABOUT YOUR LIFE
STORY AND WE'VE BEEN TRYING FOR
THREE HOURS AND A LEADING US TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR-
POSITION OF OPPOSITION NOTED
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. MY NUMBER FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NUMBER
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
YES GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS ONE
GLORIA- AND I DO HAVE A
QUESTION- SO WITH A SIMPLE
GOOGLE SEARCH I WAS ABLE TO FIND
OUT AT THE STATE. COULD BE
SAFETY COMMISSION IS CHARGED
WITH INVESTIGATING EARTHQUAKE
DAMAGING EARTHQUAKES RELATED
ISSUES. IT ALSO MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE ON POLICIES AND
PROGRAMMES HERE TO BECAUSE
AGUIAR-CURRY- MOST KNOWLEDGES
WHO WHO LOST THEIR- EARTHQUAKER
FIGHTER KNOWLEDGE COMMERCIALLY
AT A MASTER'S DEGREE AND EITHER
GEOPHYSICS OR OTHER RELATED
BUYING. AGREES I LIKE YOU KNOW
HOW I WOULD GATHER FOR THE
CLINTONS I KNOW I WITH WITH
GREAT. RESPECT- I YOU TO JUST
STATE YOUR- OF BOB. IF YOU WANT
TO SAY YOU DON'T THINK THE
PERSON HAS QUALIFICATIONS YOU
CAN SAY THAT AND I AM OPPOSED.
WE CAN'T WE DON'T ASK WE DON'T
HAVE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT- SO YOUR NAME. YOUR
POSITION. OF OPPOSITION IS
WHAT'S ACCEPTABLE AT THIS POINT
. OKAY HELLO MY NAME IS
FINALIZING APPLES. MR TAURUS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THE BOTTOM LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JENNIFER
LAWRENCE AND I OPPOSE GALA
CRUISE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS. BY NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I NEVER
FORTY EIGHT. WELCOME GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. OKAY SO YOU
KNOW BACKGROUND LOOKED ON THE
COURT IS. I'M NOT HOME ALL ARE
LOCKED IN FOR MONDAY. THREE
YOU'RE GOING A LOT. WAS NOBLE
WILL TO SUNDAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU MY NUMBER FIFTEEN. HELLO.
ALL RIGHT AND I OPPOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. YOUR LINE NUMBER FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS ALI A LOT A LOT YES AND
AYE OPPOSED MRS ELLA GROUP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I NEXT WITNESS
. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER FIFTY ONE.
ALL OF THE NUMBERS FONG EFIA
GOLF BALL WELL I'D LIKE TO GET
OUT OF THAT BUBBLE. THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
OF MADAME MODERATOR OTHER
WITNESSES. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN OPPOSITION AND THANK YOU
ANSWER. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAME MODERATOR LET ME JUST-
WHILE PEOPLE ARE STILL CONNECTED
TO OF PEOPLE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION- I'D LIKE TO SAY. IF
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU WEREN'T ABLE
TO MAKE YOUR POINTS IN THE VERY
SHORT TIME OF JUST LISTING YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION LET ME ASK
YOU TO PLEASE- SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS IN WRITING- YOU CAN DO
THAT VIA THE RULES COMMITTEE-
AND REGULAR MAIL OR YOU CAN GO
TO OUR WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS.
WE DO REALLY WANT YOUR INPUT
INTO THIS PROCESS AND WHILE. IT
IS NOT OUR CUSTOMARY OR PRACTICE
TO ALLOW MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO ASK QUESTIONS. THE
REPRESENTATIVES THE SENATORS
HAVE DONE THAT BUT YOUR COMMENTS
STILL CAN BE SENT TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND I GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING THE TIME
TO BE WITH US TODAY- HAVING
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. AND IN
OPPOSITION I WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES
AND SEE IF MEMBERS WISH TO. MAKE
A COMMENT OTHER QUESTIONS OR TO
MAKE A MOTION. OKAY SENATOR
BROKE AHEAD AND MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS. YOU MADAM PRO TEM I
JUST WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO YOU
FOR- ADDRESSING THAT THE WAY YOU
ALWAYS ADDRESS EVERY SITUATION
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS BUILDING
WITH THE QUORUM AND KINDNESS.
AND REALLY GENUINELY CARING
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO WHO- WHO
EITHER HAVE A VOICE OF
OPPOSITION OR A VOICE SUPPORT OR
HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION IN
ANY TYPE OF SITUATION WE FIND
THEMSELVES YOU ARE IN MY OPINION
THROUGH ALL THE LEADERSHIP THAT
WE SHARED TOGETHER THE FIRST TWO
YEARS AND EVEN NOW A CLASS ACT.
AND I JUST THINK YOU'VE- SENATOR
I APPRECIATE THAT AND- I WOULD
JUST SAY. THE PANDEMIC HAS MADE
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR US AGAIN.
TRADITIONALLY IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE PEOPLE IN FRONT OF US. AND
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK. AND TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO HAVE TRANSLATION
SERVICES SO. IT IS NOT OUR
DESIRE TO HAVE ANYONE'S VOICE.
STIFLED AND I KNOW THAT THE
APPOINTEE. OUR WEATHER AND THE
SUPPORT IT IS SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION I WOULD ASSUME YOU
AGREE WITH THAT. SENTIMENT SO.
WITH THAT THANK YOU SENATOR
GROVE- DO I HAVE THE SENATOR IT
COME LONGER. THANK YOU A MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE R. TO CONFIRM OUR
MAN SECRETARY CAN I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'M
LONGER. AND LONGER FIVE LAYERED
I HEARD I EIGHT EIGHT SNOW
ATKINS HI ON A THREE TO TWO IT
IS THREE TO TWO OUR
CONGRATULATIONS MISS DALY CREWS
YOUR APPOINTMENT WILL MOVE TO
THE- SENATE FLOOR I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE ARE
GREATLY APPRECIATED AND
CONGRATULATIONS. MANY THANKS
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS- I
WILL THIS IS THE OF. PUBLIC
PORTION OF THE AGENDA IS
INCLUDED FOR TODAY WE WILL HAVE
EXECUTIVE SESSION BUT AGAIN LET
ME REPEAT MYSELF. AND SAY THANK
YOU- FOR MADAME MODERATOR FOR
HELPING US TODAY- I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON ALL OF THE
APPOINTEES TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS AGAIN
YOUR COMMENTS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
INCLUDE THAT IN OUR TESTIMONY.
LET ME THANK OUR COURT REPORTER
ESPECIALLY TODAY IT WAS A LONGER
DAY THAN NORMAL. I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES AND- AGAIN EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE COOPERATION
AND THE STAFF FOR THE ASSISTANCE
GREATLY APPRECIATED- THE
COMMITTEE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES WILL NOW MOVE TO EXECUTIVE
SESSION.